NUMBER ONE IN EDUCATION FOR
THOSE YOU WERE WONDERING I SEE
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE OF THAT'S A GOOD THING.
EXCEPT IN THE FIRST ROW VERY
VERY BAD. AND THEY HAVE A
HEALTH PROGRAM TO GO FIGURE
WE'LL GET TO THAT LATER. WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED WE
HAVE A PRETTY ROBUST AGENDA
HERE'S SO WE'LL TRY TO MOVE
THROUGH IT QUICKLY AND- MOVE
YOU THROUGH THIS ROOM AND OUT
OF THE CAPITAL LET'S GO AHEAD
AND- TAKE OUR FIRST PANEL THIS
IS- ITEM OF COURSE SIXTY FOUR
FORTY UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST PANEL IS CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
YOU ALL OF THE TABLE WOULD
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT
YOU'RE RIGHT SIR EUROPE READY
CAST UPON A FINANCE. DECENT
CONCENTRA SOLELY- NICE TO SEE
YOU CAN NUMBER TO HIS IN GOOD
TO SEE YOU AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE
DOING THIS IN ORDER TO VERY
GOOD VERY GOOD GOOD MORNING
CENTER ROTH SAY OF BIRTH CANNON
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I CAN
TELL THIS IS EDUCATION YOU'RE
ALL IN A ROW. OKAY ONE SISTER.
FINANCE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY SENATOR ROTH. SO
AGAIN READY CATS PART OF
FINANCE REGARDING CAP OUT WAY.
THIS IS A AND THIS ISSUES IN
REGARDS TO THE ANNUAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY- SUBMISSION AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- SO WE JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT SO EACH YEAR YOU SEE
SUBMITS TO US PROJECTS IN
SEPTEMBER- AND THIS YEAR THERE
IS EIGHTEEN PROJECTS THAT OLD
FAMILIAR WAS LISTED. IN OUR
FEBRUARY HAVE PRELIMINARY
APPROVAL LETTER. AND THE LARGE
MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE SEISMIC
INNATE. AND THIS IS A PROCESS
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED- IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WITH
AB NINETY FOUR WHICH ALLOWS YOU
SEE TO USE A UP WITH THEIR
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION IN ORDER
TO SELL BONDS ARE PAID PAID
THAT SERVICE ON BONDS TO FUND
THESE PROJECTS. AS LONG AS IT
DOESN'T EXCEED MORE THAN 15% OF
THEIR NET SUPPORT BUT. SO FOR
REFERENCE IT MIGHT HELP TO GO
TO PAGE SIX OF YOUR AGENDA THAT
LISTS ALL OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS- IN THIS ITEM UP FOR
CONSIDERATION. I'M AS THE
MINISTRATION NOTED- AND YOU CAN
SEE IN THE FIGURE MOST OF. THE
PROJECTS ADDRESS CRITICAL LIFE
SAFETY SEISMIC PROJECTS. I'M IN
THERE A FEW OTHER PROJECTS IN
ADDITION TO THAT- THE-
UNIVERSITY'S OVERALL APPROACH
OF EMPHASIZING SEISMIC LIFE
SAFETY PROJECT SEEMS REASONABLE
TO US WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNED
WITH THAT OVERALL APPROACH. WE
DO HAVE- THREE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS AT ALL WALK THROUGH
QUICKLY. ALL THE FIRST RELATES
TO ALL THE PROPOSALS IN THIS
FIGURE AND THAT IS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY- IS GENERALLY
REQUESTING A PRE AUTHORIZATION
OF ALL OF THE PHASES OF. BOTH
THE PLANNING PHASES AND
CONSTRUCTION THIS IS SOMETHING
THE UNIVERSITY REGULARLY
REQUESTS FOR AND IN PREVIOUS
YEARS THEY HAVE PROVIDED
AUTHORIZATION FOR THESE PHASES.
WE THINK A MORE INCREMENTAL
APPROACH MAKES MORE SENSE
APPROVING THE INITIAL PLANNING
PHASES FIRST AND THEN HAVING
UNIVERSITY COME BACK ON WHEN
MORE INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
ON THE SCOPE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE AND THEN
AUTHORIZING THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE ONCE THAT INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE. IT'S APPROACH THAT
THE STATE DOES TAKE FOR OTHER-
AGENCIES LIKE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FOR EXAMPLE. I'M AND
WE THINK THAT APPROACH GIVES A
LEGISLATURE MORE INFORMATION ON
THE SCOPE OF THAT PHASE ONCE
MORE INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE.
WE THINK THAT COULD BE HANDY
EVEN IN CASES LIKE A SEISMIC
RENOVATION THAT. ON PAPER OFTEN
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD THAN A-
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT FOR
EXAMPLE FOR SEVERAL OF THE
SEISMIC RENOVATION PROJECTS-
CAMPUSES IN THEIR PROPOSALS TO
US NOTED THAT THERE STILL WHEN
SOME OF THE SCOPING DECISIONS-
FOR EXAMPLE A LOT OF THESE.
BUILDINGS ARE CURRENTLY AT A
LEVEL SIX WHICH IS THE SECOND
THE WORST RATING YOU CAN HAVE
FOR A SEISMIC. OFFER A BUILDING
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THEY'RE THERE SOME EXCITEMENT
PROJECTS THIS YEAR. IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE FIVE YOU CAN SEE V.
ARMED. A LEVEL THAT THE
UNIVERSITY USES FOR SEISMIC
READINGS. AND CURRENTLY THE
PLAN IS TO GET AT LEAST TO A
LEVEL FOUR WHICH IS THE-
MINIMUM ACCEPTED STANDARD- OF
FOR. FOR A CLASSROOM BUILDINGS
AN ACADEMIC BUILDINGS. THE
CAMPUS IS NOTED THAT THERE
STILL WEIGHING THE OPTIONS OF
TRYING TO RENOVATE TO A LEVEL
THREE. AND THEY KNOW THAT THIS
CAN OFTEN BE A COMPLEX ANALYSIS
IT. ON THEIR THEIR HIGHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THERE IS
SOME BENEFITS SO THEY HAVE TO
WEAR THOSE INDIVIDUALLY BY EACH
PROJECT. THAT'S THE KIND OF
INFORMATION WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO HAVE.
AT THE READY BEFORE ALL THE
FULLY AUTHORIZING THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WE
RECOMMEND. TAKING A MORE
CURRENT INCREMENTAL APPROACH
AUTHORIZING. THE INITIAL
PLANNING PHASES FIRST. THIS IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT HERE
WITH THE UCAS OPPOSED TO.
HAVING COME FROM BUDGETS OF
FOUR WERE WE DEALT WITH THESE
ON STATE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
OVER THE SIX YEARS THAT I HEAR
THAT SUBCOMMITTEE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT FROM YOU SEE IS AN
AND THAT THEIR OWN BINDING BE
UC'S BINDING CAPACITY IS THE-
IS THE CAPACITY IS BEING.
CHARGED WITH THE PROJECT CAN IN
MOST IF NOT ALL CASES EXCEPT
PERHAPS ONE. SERVED THE DEBT
SERVICING IS BEING COVERED BY.
YOU SEE ISN'T IT IN THESE
PROJECTS. SO WHILE IT IS OUR
FUNCTION TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
AND CERTAINLY OUR FUNCTION TO
IMPROVE AND WE SHOULD KNOW WHAT
WE'RE APPROVING WHEN WE- TAKE A
VOTE. THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
A DIFFERENCE IN THESE PROJECT
VIS A VIS THE OTHER PROJECTS
AND OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
I EMBARK ON JUST BECAUSE OF THE
ARCHITECTURE WITH WHICH THESE
PROJECTS ARE STRUCTURED AND
THEN FINANCED BRECHT. IT'S TRUE
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT IN
THAT THE PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER- STATE
AGENCIES ARE USING STATE BONDS
THOSE. SO OFTEN REQUIRES AN
APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET-
THESE DON'T REQUIRE AN
APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET. ON
THEY'RE NOT USING STATE BONDS
THEY'RE USING UC'S BONDS ON
THEIR PAYING THE DEBT SERVICE
WITH THEIR GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
DOESN'T REQUIRE. YEAH WITHIN
THE CAP THAT'S CORRECT DOESN'T
REQUIRE A DIRECT APPROPRIATION
FROM THE STATE OF THE STATE.
SOMETIMES DOES ADJUST THEIR
BUDGET TO SERVE REFLECT THESE
AND OTHERS ARE COST INCREASES.
WE STILL THINK AN INCREMENTAL
APPROACH MAKES SENSE DESPITE
THESE DIFFERENCES TO GIVE YOU
SOME MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SCOPE AND THEY'RE OPEN SOME
PROJECTS WHERE WE HAVE TAKEN AN
INCREMENTAL APPROACH. ON THERE
WAS A PROJECT I FORGET WHICH
CAMPUS IT WAS AND BUT THERE WAS
A PROJECT- I THINK WAS AT SANTA
CRUZ WHERE WE DID APPROVE THE
INITIAL PLANNING PHASES AND
THEN LATER THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE SO IT'S NOT AN
UNPRECEDENTED TO TAKE FOR THESE
KINDS OF PROJECTS WELL
CERTAINLY WE EXPECTED. DUE
DILIGENCE IN A FAIRLY DETAILED
AMOUNT OF PLANNING TO GO INTO
THIS AND YOU'RE RIGHT WE IT'S
OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT
OCCURS BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY. THE STATE GENERAL FUND
MAY BE THE BACKSTOP. THAT'S
CORRECT IF THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT ERROR YEAH I DIDN'T
MEAN TO CUT YOU OFF THAT'S OKAY
I CAN I AM HAPPY TO WALK
THROUGH SO WITH THAT WAS OUR
FIRST KIND OF BROAD COMMENT WE
HAVE TWO MORE. I'M OUR SECOND
SET OF CONCERNS RELATE TO THE
PROPOSAL OF THE PROJECT- IN
LINE SEVENTEEN WHICH IS AS I'M
SORRY ON PAGE SIX AGAIN. WHICH
IS A STAR SYSTEM WIDE- BUT VERY
PLANNING ACTIVITIES- IT'S AN
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR BONTA
FORTY THERE AND YOU'RE REALLY
LOOKING UT A NUMBER OF A VERY
PROPOSALS IN THIS ITEM FIFTY
MILLION OF THIS WOULD FUND THE
INITIAL PLANNING PHASES OF
SEVERAL PROJECTS OTHERS
PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY
SUMMARIZED INTERNET SIR TO FLIP
AROUND A LOT BUT ON PAGE SEVEN
YOU CAN SEE THE LIST OF THOSE
PROJECTS. I'M AN ORPHAN ABOUT
ARE YOU CONCERNED HERE'S JUST.
PUZZLES CAME FAIRLY LATE I'M IN
THE PROPOSALS WERE SOMEWHAT
INCOMPLETE. THEY DIDN'T CONTAIN
A LOT OF INFORMATION YOU WE
NORMALLY GET ENOUGH CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSAL THINGS LIKE A
FULL. DESCRIPTION OF THE
PROJECT JUSTIFICATION-
ALTERNATIVES THAT WERE
CONSIDERED. AN INITIAL-
ESTIMATED TIME LINE INITIAL
ESTIMATED CONSTRUCTION COSTS.
ON SO WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO. ASSESS THE
MERITS OF THESE PROPOSALS WERE
GIVEN THE- I WILL SAY APPARENT
DEMISE OF THE PROP SIX PROP
THIRTEEN. CONSTRUCTION BOND
STATEWIDE BOND WHAT IMPACT
ASSUMING THAT IS IN FACT THE
WHAT HAPPENS WHAT IMPACT WILL
THAT HAVE ON THE PARTICULAR
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM THE EIGHTY
MILLION- FOR PLANNING ACTIVITY
OTHER THIRTY GOOD QUESTION FOR
THE UNIVERSITY IN TE
ADMINISTRATION THEY THEY HAD
COMMUNICATED TO US THAT THEIR
INITIAL PLAN WAS TO USE UP ON
TO FUND THE LATER PHASES.
ANOTHER TOP ON DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT IT WILL PASS- BUT IT'S
KIND OF AN OPEN QUESTION IN OUR
MIND- WHAT THE PLAN WOULD BE
THE PRESUMABLY THE UNIVERSITY
COULD STILL CONTINUE TO USE
THEIR BONDS AND AFTER FROM THE
FUTURE COSTS BUT THAT WOULD BE
A GOOD THING TO EXPLORE WITH
THE UNIVERSITY. I'M JUST ON
THAT SO IT THERE WAS FIFTY
MILLION THERE'S ANOTHER THIRTY
MILLION IN THAT PROPOSAL AND
THAT IS FOR A SEPARATE-
INITIATIVE THAT WOULD FUND.
ODDS ADDITIONAL SEISMIC STUDIES
FOR BUILDINGS ONLY THE
UNIVERSITY HAS TAKEN NUMEROUS
SEISMIC STUDIES WITH ITS
EXISTING BUDGET ARM AND THE
THESE ARE STANDING IS THAT
THESE STUDIES APPEALED IT MORE
IN DEPTH AND WOULD HELP-
FURTHER DETERMINE THE SEISMIC
READINGS IN CASES WHERE THERE
ARE SOME WORDS STILL AMBIGUOUS
USING STANDARD METHODOLOGY. MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S SOME
ISSUE ABOUT. CAMPUS IS DOING
STUDIES BUT THE QUESTION WAS IS
WAS THE METHODOLOGIES.
STANDARDIZED IN OR THE RESULT A
ROOF COMPARING APPLES TO APPLES
AND- APPLES TO ORANGES YEAH
THAT WAS NOT REMEMBERING THE IS
YEAH THAT THERE WAS AN ISSUE
FOR MAINTENANCE PARTICULARLY
THEY WERE SOMETHING
UNIVERSITIES CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING A SYSTEM WIDE STUDY
OF. THE CONDITION OF ITS
FACILITIES THAT AND WITH THE
AIM OF HAVING A MORE ACCURATE
ESTIMATE OF THEIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG. THESE
STUDIES ARE ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT THEY'RE FOCUSED ON
SEISMIC STRUCTURES FOR
BUILDINGS AND SO THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THEIR ABILITY TO
WITHSTAND SEISMIC FORCES. ON
THEY'VE CURRENTLY DONE A NUMBER
OF OBSERVATIONAL STUDIES WHICH
IN A LOT OF CASES IS. ON BUT IN
SOME CASES NOT ON THESE STUDIES
ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
QUANTITATIVE AND- ARE A LITTLE
MORE HANDS ON REQUIRE A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL AND SO THAT'S-
THAT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THESE
STUDIES ARE. WE DON'T TAKE
ISSUE WITH THE WITH THE GOAL OF
THE STUDIES- OUR CONCERN HERE
IS THAT IT'S A- ONE TIME STUDY
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD US. COMMENT
BEFORE WE THINK BONDS ARE NOT
THE APPROPRIATE FOR A ONE TIME
STUDY I AGREE WITH WE THINK
CASH WOULD BE A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE UNIVERSITY HAS. BEEN
APPEAR. APPEARS TO BE USING ITS
EXISTING BUDGET FOR A LOT OF
THE STUDIES ALSO HAS. A
RESERVES AND SO WE THINK THOSE
WOULD PROBABLY BE BETTER- FUND
SOURCES THEN- BOND FUNDING. SO
WE RECOMMEND YOU REJECT- THIS
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
ONCE ENTIRETY. THAT BEING SAID
IT'S NOT THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
SIGNALING THE PRODUCTS DON'T
HAPPEN IT'S JUST SIGNALING
EITHER THAT THE UNIVERSITY COME
BACK WITH. MORE INFORMATION
WERE COMPLETED- PROPOSALS OR
THAT IT USE EXISTING RESOURCES
IN THE CASE OF THE SEISMIC
STUDIES FOR WE- SUPPLEMENT THE
GENERAL FUND. APPROPRIATION BY
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE
SURE THE SEISMIC STUDIES DONE
STEP THAT'S THAT'S ANOTHER
OPTION THERE WOULD BE ONE TIME
IN THAT CASE AND PRESUMABLY
INSTEAD OF ON GOING DEPENDING
ON. THE NATURE OF THE STUDIES
SEISMIC STUDY WOULD BE PRETTY
IMPORTANT TO. PAYING FOR TO
ANOTHER ISSUE BUT WE CERTAINLY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO
QUANTIFY WHAT THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM IS AND THEN FIGURE OUT
EVER GOING TO PAY FOR THIS. AND
YOU MIGHT RECALL LAST YEAR THE
STATE. ADOPTED SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE REQUIRING
YOU SEE TO. COME COME BACK WITH
AN ESTIMATE OF IT SEISMIC.
READINGS AND SO IT'S AN
ACTIVITY THAT UC'S DOING IN.
CONJUNCTION WITH EXPECTATIONS
SET BY THE STATE RIGHT. AND
THEN JUST THAT THE THIRD SET OF
CONCERNS ARE WILL BE SIMPLER
JUST ONLINE SIXTEEN ON PAGE SIX
YOU'LL SEE. A PROPOSAL FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. WE JUST
RECOMMEND YOU GET AN INITIAL
LESS BEFORE AUTHORIZING- BOND
FUNDING FOR THAT WE DON'T HAVE
INITIAL LIST AT THE MOMENT. THE
PROJECTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR. NICE ANALYSIS YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU CENTER ROTH AND
CENTER LEYVA- I WOULD FIRST
BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD LIKE
THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR PLACING THE
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND ON THE
BALLOT ABOUT A WEEK AGO. WHILE
IT'S LOOKING LIKE PROP THIRTEEN
DIDN'T PASS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
TECH KNOWLEDGE MEN OF
UNIVERSITIES. SIGNIFICANT
CAPITAL OUTLAY NEEDS AND YOUR
SUPPORT FOR US- THE SERGEANT I
BELIEVE HAS HANDED OUT- OF
PRESENTATION THAT HAS AN ORANGE
COVER ON IT- I'LL BE REFERRING
TO SLIDE THREE THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
IS REQUESTING CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS FUNDED THROUGH THE A.
B. NINETY FOUR PROCESS. OF AND
AS THE LA ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE EXPLAINED- UNDER THE AB
NINETY FOUR PROCESS YOU SEE
ISSUES BONDS THAT ARE PAID FROM
OUR OWN OPERATING FUNDS. AND ON
SLIDE THREE YOU SEE THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE- PROPOSED TO
BE FUNDED DURING TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. OF THE TOTAL ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION IN
STATE FUNDS AND- AND WE WOULD
FOCUS ON ADDING SYSTEM WIDE
EDUCATIONAL CAPACITY AND LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES- AS THE LA
MENTIONED- YOU SEE HAS BEEN.
CONDUCTING EXTENSIVE SEISMIC
EVALUATION OF OUR BUILDINGS TO
DATE WE HAVE EVALUATED OVER
FIFTY SIX MILLION SQUARE FEET
OF BUILDINGS. OF IDENTIFIED FOR
THE PROJECTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE HAVE FOURTEEN BUILDINGS
IN CREEK NEED OF CRITICAL
REPAIR THAT ARE CONSIDERED
SEISMIC SAFETY SIX. UP
BUILDINGS. AND WE ARE ALSO OF
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE HAVE SUBMITTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE A JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE A LIST OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
TOTALING SIX BILLION DOLLARS
CROSS OUR CAMPUSES WE WOULD
SELECT ALL OF THE PROJECTS FROM
THAT LIST. AND WE WOULD DIVIDE
THE FUNDS BETWEEN THE CAMPUS IS
BASED ON THE AGE OF THE
BUILDINGS AND THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE OF THE BUILDINGS ON THE
CAMPUS WHICH IS A FORMULA THAT
WE'VE USED IN THE PAST. IN
DIVIDING ARE A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS BETWEEN OUR
CAMPUSES. IN ADDITION WE'RE
REQUESTING ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME STATE GENERAL FUNDS
FROM THE LEGISLATURE FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PURPOSES.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION OF
THAT WOULD BE FOR THE MORE
TRADITIONAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. AND THREE
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD BE FOR
MORE MODERNIZATIONS OF.
BUILDINGS AND ENERGY USAGE OF
THOSE BUILDINGS WHILE ALSO
TAKING CARE OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES. YOU
MENTIONED SO SICK THE TOTAL WAS
SIX BILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT IS
OUR CURRENT LIST. CAMPUSES
MAYBE YOU MENTION SEISMIC
WHAT'S THE TOTAL FOR THE
SEISMIC DO WE HAVE IT YET WE DO
NOT YET HAVE THE TOTAL ESTIMATE
FOR THE COST OF THE ACTUAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. IT WAS
OUR PLAN SHOULD THE BOND HAVE
PASSED TO USE ALMOST THE ENTIRE
TWO BILLION FOR SEISMIC
PROJECTS. OF SOMEONE SUGGESTED
TO ME THAT THAT WOULD TAKE YOUR
BERKELEY- THAT'S IT WOULD NOT
TAKE CARE OF ALL OUR SYSTEM
WIDE NEEDS THAT'S CORRECT SIR.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT SYSTEM MY
NEEDS FOR SEISMIC. SO WE ARE
INTERNALLY AT THIS POINT
EVALUATING- THE PROJECTS THAT
THE LA- OF RECOMMENDED YOU
REJECT BECAUSE THEY WERE
DEPENDENT ON THE BOND PASSING
SO WE ARE- TAKING A LOOK AT
THOSE PROJECTS TO SEE. HOW WE
WOULD PROCEED FORWARD WITH THEM
AND WE WILL BE IN COMMUNICATION
WITH YOU SHORTLY ABOUT THAT.
AND YOU'LL- I ASSUME YOU WILL
TRIAGE THEM FOR US AS WELL I
WOULD BE MOST INTERESTED IN. IN
IN LEARNING WHICH ONES ARE
SEISMICALLY CRITICAL. OF THE
PROP ALL OF THE PROJECTS THAT
WE WERE REQUESTING FUNDING FOR
OR OF THIS BUDGET YEAR OUR
LEVEL SIX OR LEVEL FIVE PROJECT
THE FIFTY. FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROJECTS TO SEVEN
PROJECTS TO RECEIVE PLANNING
FUNDS IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT OF THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE PLANNING FUNDS
AND ALSO THE- ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OR
SYSTEM WIDE- SEISMIC PROGRAM
THOSE PROJECTS BUT THAT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION INCLUDES THE
CONSTRUCTION COMPONENT OF THOSE
PROJECTS SO THOSE PROJECTS
WOULD BE FULLY COMPLETED.
WITHIN THE NEXT. TWO YEARS SO
ITEMS ONE TO FOURTEEN ON THE-
EIGHT ON THE FACILITY PROJECTS
LIST ON PAGE SIX OF THE AGENDA
ARE ALL. SEISMICALLY RATED AT
THE SIX LEVEL. DID I HEAR THAT
RIGHT UP THAT THAT IS CORRECT
SEISMIC SIX OR SEISMIC FIVE.
JUST TO CLARIFY THERE ARE TWO
SEISMIC FIVE THEY'RE THERE TO
LEVEL FIVES IN HERE. ON THE
ROSTERS ARE LEVEL SIXES. THANK
YOU I DIDN'T MEAN TO. I DO IT
BUT I DIDN'T MEAN TO DERAIL YOU.
THAT'S THAT'S ALL RIGHT SIR OF
AND JUST TO ADDRESS THE ALEJO'S
CONCERNS REGARDING THE TIMING
OF THE CONSTRUCTION PART OF THE
REASON WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR US TO RECEIVE BOTH THE
PLANNING FUNDS AND THE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS AT THE SAME
TIME. IS THAT AS UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES WE DO HAVE A CERTAIN
SCHEDULE BASED ON WHICH IT'S
MUCH EASIER FOR US TO SHUT DOWN
A BUILDING SO WE WANT TO
UTILIZE THOSE SUMMER MONTHS AS
PART OF THE CONSTRUCTION
PROCESS. OF AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE STATED EARLIER WE
ARE EXPECTED TO TURN IN OUR
PLANS IN SEPTEMBER FOR APPROVAL
TO FOLLOWING JULY SO IF WE
COMPLETE OUR PRELIMINARY PLANS
AND WE HAVE A COST ESTIMATE. WE
WOULD HAVE TO WAIT TO START TO
CONSIDER XIN FROM SEPTEMBER THE
FOLLOWING JULY. WITHOUT
APPROVAL WELL AS IF YOU APPROVE
OUR HONOR PLANTS AND
CONSTRUCTION. THE SOONEST PLANS
ARE DONE TO MOVE INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE AND NOT HAVE
DELAY. I'M A CONCERT I KNOW THE
ALEJO'S SERMON THEN I'M LESS
CONCERNED WITH. WITH. TREATING
YOU SEE THE WAY WE TREAT D. G.
S. AND THEY CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT I'M ACCUSTOMED TO
DEALING WITH. ALTHOUGH TRUST
BUT VERIFY SO AS SOON AS SOME
REPORTING REQUIREMENT BUILT IN
HERE THAT WE WILL HAVE REPORTS
ON ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
PROGRESS SO AT SOME POINT IN
TIME SOMEONE CAN STEP IN IT
LOOKS LIKE. UNEXPECTEDLY YOU
ARE GOING TO GO OFF THE TRACKS
WE IN. PULL YOU BACK IN YES SIR.
THAT'S IT THAT'S IT. HELLO I'VE
ACTUALLY WHAT THE SUPPLEMENT
BOTH YOUR COMMENTS AND UC'S OR
AGREE THAT- SINCE THIS IS
THROUGH THEIR SUPPORT BUDGETS-
IT'S IN LINE WITH THE AB NINETY
FOUR PROCESS AND FROM FINANCE
RESPECTIVELY DON'T FEEL THAT
THERE IS A NEED TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS TWICE ONCE
FOR DESIGN AND ONCE FOR
CONSTRUCTION. I ALSO JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON
THE- ON THE LA US. IN REGARDS
TO USING G. O. BONDS FOR TO
SEISMIC STUDIES. AND JUST A
NOTE THAT IT'S OFTEN THE CASE
WITH SAY- GEO BOND SUCH AS THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL BONDS OR PROP
FIFTY ONE WERE A SMALL PORTION
OF IT IS USE FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
TASKS. OKAY. IT WAS JUST I WAS
JUST REMINDED. OF THE WE DON'T
GET THE SAME SORT OF REPORTING
HERE THAT WE'RE THAT I'M
ACCUSTOMED TO SEEING. IN THE
OTHER BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE I
USED TO HAVE SO LET'S THINK
ABOUT SOME LANGUAGE TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE- BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON THESE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND SEE IF THAT FORMAT
THAT WE'RE ACCUSTOMED TO USING
I THINK WITH SOME OF THE TGS
MANAGE PROJECTS STATE
CONSTRUCTION AROUND HERE FOR
EXAMPLE. WE COULD APPLY THAT TO
THIS SO WE AT LEAST KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON. IF LA IS CONCERNED.
THAT MAKES SENSE. RIGHT GUEST
IS A QUESTION MAKE SENSE THE
STATEMENT AND THEN WE CAN
FIGURE OUT IF WE CAN DESIGN
SOME REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT MAKES SENSE. I'M I THINK
IT MAKES SENSE I WILL SAY THE
LAW DOES PROVIDE AN ANNUAL
STATUS REPORTS ON N ALL OF THE
PROJECTS WHERE DOES AGO DOES
NOT A GOES TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND TO THE ADMINISTRATION IT'S-
WELL LET'S TAKE IT IS AN US
TAKE A LOOK AT WHO'S WE-
CRAFTED SOME. BUDGET LANGUAGE A
COUPLE BUDGETS AGO. FOR SOME
VERY SPECIFIC PROJECTS WHERE
THERE WERE SOME REPORTS THAT
WENT BACK TO THE CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT LANGUAGE AND SEE IF THAT
COULD APPLY HERE WITHOUT UNDULY
RESTRICTING UC- OR- CAUSING A
LOT OF WORK FOR YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND- THAT WAY MY-
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIR WILL BE IN THE
LOOP. SO AT LEAST IN THE
INFORMATION LOW SO HERE SHE
KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON MAKES
SENSE. IT'S PERFECT. OF THAT IS
IT FOR THIS PANEL THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH A QUESTION SIMILAR.
NUMBER TWO ISSUE TO YOU SEE
MEDICAL EDUCATION. YEAH WE CAN
CERTAINLY TRY TO ADD A CHAIR
CHESSER. WE'LL HAVE SOMEBODY
BRING IT YOU'RE BRINGING. OTHER
DUTIES AS ASSIGNED. JUST LIKE
WORKING HERE. GAINES. WHEREVER
YOU LIKE TO BE YOU WANT TO BE
YOU WOULD YOU YOU WANT TO.
SOCIAL DISTANCING REMEMBER.
COLLECTING PAPER UP HERE. OKAY
IF WE COULD HAVE. YOU FOLKS
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT
YOU'RE RIGHT CHANCELLOR CAME
ACROSS SOME THE CHANCERY UC
RIVERSIDE. DEBT FOR DAYS VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR HEALTH SCIENCES
AND DEAN OF THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AT UC RIVERSIDE BEING
GOOD TO SEE YOU YES MA'AM I
MEAN ALL. AT THE YOU SEE ARE
SCHOOL BUT- THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT. WHAT IS IN CONSTANT FOR
US AGAIN I'M STILL ERE I'M
STILL GLAD YOU'RE STILL WITH
US. YES SIR BRIAN RELIGIOUS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COULD
HAVE MORNING. REBEKAH KIRK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY WHO
WANTS TO START. THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN INTRODUCE SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
A FORTY MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
ON GOING GENERAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED ENROLLMENT IN
OPERATING CAPACITY FOR MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WOULD SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORT THE UC ARE UC RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND FIFTEEN
MILLION WOULD SUPPORT THE UC
SAN FRANCISCO. FRESNO BRANCH
CAMPUS AND THAT WOULD BE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UC MERCED.
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
STATE HAS SOME REGIONS THAT ARE
UNDER SERVED WITH AND THEY HAVE
A PHYSICIAN SHORTAGES AND
HEALTH OUTCOMES ISSUES SO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
THESE RESOURCES TO HELP BOOST-ENROLLMENT AND ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. AND I THINK BY THE WAY
REPRESENTING THAT AREA THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION- FOR YOUR
EFFORTS OVER THE YEARS ACTUALLY
IN THIS AREAS OF THANK YOU.
WHO'S NEXT. YES SIR WE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON SO ARE WE HAVE
THREE- I'LL GO THROUGH THREE
BROAD MESSAGES WE HAD THE FIRST
IS THINKING ABOUT. A PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE ISSUES BROADLY AND
THEN THE SECOND WILL BE FOCUSED
ON UC RIVERSIDE'S- PLAN UNDER
THE PROPOSAL AND THEN THE THIRD
WOULD BE THE UCSF PROPOSAL. THE
THING ABOUT WORKFORCE ISSUES
BROADLY THIS PROPOSAL APPEARS
TO BE AIMED AT AN INCREASING
THE SUPPLY OF PHYSICIANS
REGIONALLY. I'M IN THE CASE OF
RIVERSIDE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
IN THE CAS OF FRESNO IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND THE
EMPHASIS ON THESE REGIONS
APPEARS WARRANTED THESE REGIONS
DO YOU HAVE A LOW. OF SUPPLY
PHYSICIANS PER CAPITA RELATIVE
TO OTHER REGIONS IN THE STATE.
I THINK THE THINK THE CRITICAL
ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER IS. THINKING ABOUT THE
BEST WAYS TO ADDRESS THESE
REGIONAL- NEEDS. ON THE MISS
REGION'S PROPOSING INCREASING
MEDICAL SCHOOL ENROLLMENTS
THAT'S CERTAINLY ONE APPROACH
IT- LIKELY WILL HAVE- AN
INCREASE IN THE STATEWIDE
SUPPLY PHYSICIANS. REGIONAL
IMPACTS OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE
A LITTLE BIT HARD TO EVALUATE-
AND THAT'S BECAUSE MEDICAL
SCHOOL STUDENTS- AFTER
COMPLETING MEDICAL SCHOOL GO ON
TO- COMPLETE POST GRADUATE
TRAINING. IN SOME CASES IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS WHERE THEY
COMPLETED MEDICAL SCHOOL AND
SOME ARGUE THAT STUDENTS WHEN
THEY GO ON TO DO THE RESIDENCY
PLANT ROOTS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THE STATE HAS-
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT DO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS ANOTHER INCENTIVE
BASED PROGRAMS LIKE A LOAN
REPAYMENTS. THE PROGRAMS. COULD
HAVE A STRONGER REGIONAL
CONNECTION BECAUSE THEY'RE TIED
AT THE BACK END OF THE- OF THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PIPELINE. THAT'S SAID THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH- EVIDENCE THAT ARE
A DATA ACROSS ALL THESE.
PROPOSALS TO REALLY OFFER
SOMETHING MORE DEFINITIVE TO
THE LEGISLATURE SO JUST AN AREA
OF UNCERTAINTY AS YOU'RE
WEARING THESE PROPOSALS. I'M
MOVING ON TO UC RIVERSIDE THE
UC RIVERSIDE- DID SUBMIT TO US
A LONG TERM- MULTI YEAR PLAN
UNDER THE PROPOSAL. AND THE
ELEMENTS OF THAT PLAN ARE
SUMMARIZED AT A HIGH LEVEL ON
PAGE FOURTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
WE UNDERSTAND THE CRUX OF IT TO
BE ESSENTIALLY THREE. THINGS
THE FIRST IS IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE CAMPUS TO- REPLACE
IT. AS AN EXISTING AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT THAT A PROVIDES TO ON
THE MEDICAL SCHOOL ABOUT SIX
MILLION. ON RE DIRECTED FOR
OTHER PRIORITIES IT SECONDLY
WOULD- ADDRESS A DEFICIT THAT
THE SCHOOLS EXPERIENCING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND THEN THIRD AS
YOU WAIT AS THE ADMINISTRATION
NOTED A GROWN WOMAN THERE
HELPING TAT. AB THEY CURRENTLY
ENROLLED ABOUT EIGHTY STUDENTS
IN THE COHORT THEY'RE HOPING TO
UNROLL ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE STUDENTS IN THE COHORT WE
HAVE THREE ISSUES TO CONSIDER
AS REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL. OF
THE FIRST JUST TO GET MORE
INFORMATION ON THE CAMPUS IS
PLANNED TO RE DIRECT. SOME OF
THE REDUCING THE AMOUNT OR OR
EXPECTING MORE MOMENT GROSS BUT
YOU WOULD WANT TO WORK WITH THE
SCHOOL TO UNDERSTAND ALL THE
ELEMENTS OF THAT. ON THE
SECOND- ISSUE TO CONSIDER IS
THAT A LOT OF THE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH- WOULDN'T OCCUR IN TOLL
ON. A LATER YEARS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL FIRST HAS TO
CONSTRUCT A BUILDING TO
ACCOMMODATE THE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH ONE OF THE FUNDING IS
COMING IN THIS YEAR- WENT WHEN
ISSUE WHEN IT CONSERVE YOU
COULD CONSIDER IS UP AS A-
APPROACH THAT FUNDS THE TIMES
THE FOUR. TIMES FUNDING CLOSER
TO WIN WOMAN GROWTH WOULD BE
OCCURRING. THAT'S A MORE
STANDARD PRACTICE- WHEN THE
STATE PROVIDES A MOMENT OF
FUNDING FOR THE SEGMENTS. AND
THE THIRD ISSUE TO CONSIDER IS
CURRENT THE CURRENT PROPOSAL.DOESN'T HAVE AN ENROLLMENT
TARGET AND IT'S STANDARD
PRACTICE IN THE STATE BUDGET TO
SAID IN ROMAN TARGET. ON WHEN
THERE'S FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH INSURES THAT- THIS STATE
COURT ON ITS EXPECTATIONS. AND
THEN MOVING JUST YOU SEE. UCSF
FRESNO THIS WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT IN THAT THERE ISN'T A
MULTI YEAR PLAN CURRENTLY
ATTACHED TO THE PROPOSAL LEAST
ONE IS NOT SUITED TO OUR OFFICE
YET- SO WE RECOMMEND YOU FIRST.
GET A PLAN IN PLACE AND REVIEW
THAT PLAN BEFORE APPROPRIATING
FUNDING. WE THINK OF A PLAN
THAT WOULD BE MOST HELPFUL THE
LEGISLATURE WOULDN'T JUST. ALL
PROVIDE ONE OPTION IT WOULD
PROVIDE SEVERAL OPTIONS RANGING
IN COST AND EFFECTIVENESS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THE
TRADE OFFS OF. A LOWER COST
OPTION COULD BE TO. PRIORITIZE
SORT OF EXISTING MEDICAL SCHOOL
SLOT SET YOU SEE YOURSELF AND
YOU SEE A FRESNO FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE THEY BELIEVE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO STAY IN THE REGION.
AND THEN THE MORE COST
INTENSIVE ONES WOULD BE TO
EXPAND YOU SEE US ARE FRESNO AS
A FOR YOUR CAMPUS OR TO CREATE
A JOINT PROGRAM WITH MERCED.
ONCE THAT ONCE THOSE ARE PLANS
ARE IN PLACE WE CAN RECOMMEND
YOU HAVE A HEARING TO VET EACH
PLAN AND WAIT EACH OPTION AND
ULTIMATELY DECIDE WHICH
APPROACH LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE
TO. TAKE TAKING THAT APPROACH
WOULD IT WOULD GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE MORE OF A BASIS ON
A MULTI YEAR APPROACH TO.
PROVIDE FUNDING TO EXPAND.
SERVICES IN THE REGION MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM READING THE
MATERIAL. VARIOUS MATERIALS IS
THAT- YOU CO P. AND YOU SEE AS
A WHOLE IS IN THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING TOGETHER A MORE
DETAILED PLAN. TO EITHER ADOPT
ONE OF THE THREE OPTIONS THAT
HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT FOR SOME
TIME INCLUDING HAVING UC MERCED
PROVIDE THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THE BASIC SCIENCE EDUCATION FOR
MEDICAL STUDENTS. AND THEN
HAVING THOSE MEDICAL STUDENTS
GO SOME. TWO YEARS WHICH
FRANKLY IS THE WAY THAT THE UC
YOUR CAMPUS DID IT FOR FORTY OR
FIFTY. YEARS GIVE OR TAKE- DO
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA AS TO WHAT
THE TIME LINE IS FOR THAT- FOR
THAT BINDING DOCUMENT AND
WHETHER WE WILL HAVE IT BEFORE
WE HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS.
FOLLOWING THE MAY REVISION TO
THE BUDGET. OF THE UNIVERSITY
DID SIGNAL TO US THAT IT WAS
THEIR GOAL TO GET US A PLAN
BEFORE- DECISIONS WOULD BE MADE
IT'S AN OLD I'M MARCH WHEN THEY
WHEN WE COMMUNICATED WITH THEM
WHEN WE'RE READING ANALYSIS BE
GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO GET AN
UPDATE ON THAT TIMELINE. I'M IN
ADDITION TO THIS PROPOSAL YOU
MAY RECALL THAT THE STATE
BUDGET LAST YEAR AUTHORIZED- A
CONSTRUCTION OF A NOT ONLY A
PROJECT UC RIVERSIDE BUT A
PROJECT THAT YOU SEE MERCED AND
IT APPEARS YOU SEE HAS SIGNAL
TO US THAT THEY INTEND TO-
APPROVE SOME SOME PROJECT
CONNECTED TO THIS- IN MERCED-
IN THE REGION SO I THINK IN
APRIL SO GOING TO BE MORE IT
COULD BE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
MORE OF THAT WITH THAT SORT OF
PROBLEM. HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
A B. NINETY FOUR. THIS RARE
BIRDS PROPOSED. MYSTIC THROUGH
FINANCE. TO COME TO US AND
THAT'S NOT ON THE LIST THIS
YEAR SO I ASSUME WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TWENTY. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. BUDGET PLANNING
DOCUMENT FINANCE I DON'T MEAN
TO NO GO AHEAD THAT'S CORRECT
THE IT WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE AB NINETY FOUR PROCESS TO
IF IS ACTUALLY A PROPOSAL FOR
NEW FACILITIES. RIGHT SO WE
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE THAT- WE
WOULD NOT EXPECT TO SEE
ANYTHING THIS YEAR. OKAY I
DIDN'T MEAN TO I JUST WANTED TO
FIND OUT WHAT WAS GOING. AND IT
WOULD BE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK ASK YOU SEE ABOUT ITS PLANS
FOR THE FACILITY SEE IF IT'S-
GOING TO SUBMIT SOMETHING FOR
NEXT YEAR IF IT'S- UNDER
DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW. UC'S
LEVITATING OFF THE CHAIRS BACK
THERE THEY'RE DYING TO GET
APPEARS WELL WE'LL HAVE
EVERYBODY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH IN ON THIS I'VE- I'M
INTERESTED IN IN IN IN FACT
HEARING WHAT THE TIME LINE IS
BUT- THAT'S THE EXTENT OF OUR
ANALYSIS WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTION. THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS BY THE WAY I REALLY
APPRECIATED. OKAY WHO'S NEXT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- FORGET
IT THANK YOU FOR DRIVING UP-
SOCIAL DISTANCING. NO AIRPORTS
NORPLANT'S. NOW IT. THE IF THE
DRUG. THAT IT'S GREAT TO BE
HERE WITH THREE SENATORIAL
FRIENDS- REALLY IS AN OPTICALLY
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK FOR HELP
I NEED TO POINT OUT THAT MS
ALFARO IS FROM CHINO. SO MAYBE
CONNECTION ENERGY DRIVE TO LA I
THINK SHE PLAYED WITH THE TEAM.
YEP BUT IT'S FROM SUPPORT LIKE
THE THREE OF YOU THAT HAS MADE
YOU SEE OUR WHAT IT IS MONEY
MAGAZINE NOW HAS US IDENTIFIED
AS THE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
UNIVERSITY IN AMERICA. US NEWS
AND WORLD REPORT SAYS WE'RE
NUMBER ONE IN THE COUNTRY AND
SOCIAL MOBILITY. AND WE CAN'T
DO THAT FIRE CELLS THAT COMES
WITH A GREAT GREAT SUPPORT FROM
GREAT GREAT FRIENDS LIKE ALL OF
YOU. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR HIS RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
SUPPLEMENT- FOR THE UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE BELIEVE
TO BE A UP A CIRCLE OF SUPPORT
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO US- IN
PARTICULAR TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR US WILL HELP US
MAINTAIN OUR CURRENT OPERATIONS
AND PLACES ON A PATH FORWARD AS
THE LA- SUGGESTED FOR A- TOTAL
IN ROME ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MEDICAL STUDENTS. OUR MEDICAL
SCHOOL STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN IS THE FIRST NAME
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THE UC SYSTEM
IN NEARLY FORTY YEARS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE GOT FULL
ACCREDITATION FROM THE LC
ARMENIAN GRADUATE AT OUR FIRST
QUARTER STUDENTS AND- OF FORTY
STUDENTS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SO. OF AND THE
SENATOR WAS THERE TO. GREET
THOSE STUDENTS. TODAY WE ENROLL
TWO HUNDRED NINETY ONE MEDICAL
STUDENTS FORTY. 2% OF WHOM. ARE
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES TO
COMPLETE A MATCH BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. AND 39% ARE FROM GROUPS
UNDER REPRESENTED IN MEDICINE.
MORE THAN 80% OF OUR MEDICAL
SCHOOL GRADUATES ARE BETWEEN
RESIDENCY TRAINING IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS REMAINING IN CALIFORNIA
NEARLY ONE THIRD. IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. WE OPERATE THE ONLY
COMMUNITY BASED MEDICAL SCHOOL
IN THE UC. WHICH MEANS THAT OUR
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS
ARE BEDDED WITHIN EXISTING
HOSPITALS WE DON'T RUN A
SEPARATE HOSPITAL. AND THAT'S
CRUCIAL TO THE IMPACT WE HAVE
ON MEDICAL SERVICE ACROSS THE
REGION. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
NOT HAVING A HOSPITAL AS A
LIMITED RUN RESOURCES SO IT'S A
TRADE OFF BETWEEN THIS
INDEBTEDNESS. AND THE EXTENT TO
WHICH WE CAN RUN AN ENTERPRISE
THAT GENERATE REVENUE TO THIS
TO FEED ITSELF. WE'VE GOT OUR
SAID A CHALLENGES- WE WERE
UNDER. UNDER CAPITALIZE FROM
THE BEGINNING- AND AS A RESULT-
WE'VE BEEN SUBSIDIZING FROM THE
FROM THE GENERAL UNIVERSITY
BUDGET THE ALEJO'S CORRECT.
WHEN HE POINTS OUT THAT I'LL
SEE ME THOUGH. THE ACCREDITING
GROUP AN AGENCY JIMMY THE FIRST
FOR MEDICAL SCHOOLS A SECOND
FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION.
HAVE ACTUALLY RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS FUNDING- GAP IN THE
FACT THAT WE WERE ALWAYS KIND
OF BACK FILLING. THE IITIAL
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT
STARTED THE SCHOOL. HAS NOT
BEEN INFLATED OR INCREASED AT
ALL SINCE THE BEGINNING IT
WASN'T ENOUGH THEN- TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS- WE HIRED SOME
PRIVATE CONSULTANTS THE TRUMP
TRUMP TRIP- ON BOX. WHICH IS A
CONSULTING FIRM THEY DID A
NATIONAL COMPARISON AND THE
REST AND- TO SUGGEST THAT WE
NEED AND ANOTHER THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION DID
ANALYSIS THEY FORGET ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE MILLION BUT
ENDORSED THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR SUPPLEMENT.
WHICH I THINK IS A FAIR WAY OF
DEALING WITH THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE. OF RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
HUGE COURT OF UNPAID VOLUNTEER
FACULTY MEMBERS OF ABOUT 60% OF
OUR OUR- ADJUNCT FACULTY ARE
ARE UNPAID. TEACHER MENTOR
UNIVERSITIES STUDENTS FOR FREE.
OTHER UC'S A AND PRIVATE
MEDICAL SCHOOLS CLINICAL FACT
WE ARE NOT ONLY IN DEMAND BUT
ARE PAID COMPETITIVE SALARIES
FOR THIS IMPORTANT WORK. SO
WE'RE REALLY WORKING ON THE
KINDNESS OF STRANGERS RIGHT
NOW- SPACE WISE WE'RE UP
AGAINST IT AT- YOU SEE ARE. THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL HAS BEEN
BORROWING SPACE IN THE SCIENCE
LIBRARY- OF LATE. THEY'VE
UTILIZE SPACE OFFICE SPACE AT
THE UC PATH CENTER WHICH IS
ABOUT FIVE MILES DISTANT FROM
THE CAMPUS. WE HAVE THEIR
MEDICAL STUDENTS- MISSILE FAR
WILL. WILL TO A TEST FOR
MEDICAL STUDENTS IN TRAILERS IN
THE PARKING LOT- FOR STUDY
SPACE- SO WEIRD. EIGHT FULL FOR
THE EFFORTS ON THE- ON OUR
BEHALF. TO FIND MONEY TO
BUILDING UP BUILDING FOR
MEDICAL SCHOOL AND I'M
EMBARRASSED TO SAY I WAS NOT
AWARE OF THE- AGAINST THE
REPORT BECAUSE THE MODULATORS
BUT TRAILING. PREFERABLY SORRY
WE'RE YOUR INTERNET I WAS NOT
AWARE OF THE- FACT THAT WE WERE
USING TRAILERS ON A UC CAMPUS
TO. EDUCATE ANY STUDENTS
ACTUALLY BUT CERTAINLY THE
MEDICAL STUDENTS BUT I DIDN'T
IT IS INTERESTING TO. READ THAT
AND I PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE USED
MORE APPROPRIATE MODULAR BUT-
SOMEBODY WHO LIVED IN A TRAILER
ONE TIME A DAY WITH ACTORS TO
ME- SO WHAT'S THE FUTURE. FIRST
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
EFFORTS TO GET ASSISTANCE TO
THIS PLACE WE'RE IN A VERY
DIFFERENT PLACE WE WERE. FEW IT
FOR YEARS AGO- PLENTY FOR THE
BUILDING IS UNDER WAY. WE
EXPECT AS THE LA OPEN- REPORTED
WE EXPECT MOVE IN AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS NOW IS
CRUCIAL IN TERMS OF TIME FOR A
FEW REASONS. FIRST IT'S A CURE
IS THE FINANCIAL. SECURITY FOR
THE- SCHOOL. DIRECTLY IN THE
EYES OF THE CREDITORS. BUT NOT
JUST THE CREDITORS. OTHERS
AROUND THE COUNTRY MEDICAL
SCHOOL FACULTY DEANS AND OTHERS
TALK TO EACH OTHER AND KNOWING
THAT THIS. A SOLID SCHOOL WITH
A SOLID FINANCIAL FOOTING AS
IMPORTANT TO OUR REPUTATION AND
ABILITY TO RECRUIT. STUDENTS
AFTER THE ALIVE. NUMBER TWO
THERE'S A LOT OF START TO HIRE
THE FACULTY WE CAN'T SIMPLY
INCREASE THE ENROLLMENT IN THE
SCHOOL. WITHOUT A BUILDING
WITHOUT PEOPLE TO TEACH THE
STUDENTS AND IT TAKES OF WILD
START TO DO THAT WE HAVE TO
COMMIT CELL REASON AND RESOURCE
OF BOTH RECRUITMENT PROCESS AS
WELL AS TO THE- TO THE OP
PEOPLE THEMSELVES GET THEM HERE
AND GET THEM INTO INTO THE- THE
THROW THINGS. CHANCELLOR ME
JUST I HATE THAT. I TEN
INTERRUPT PEOPLE COLLEGES IN
DVANCE- HAVING JUST DONE THAT
TO YOU. BUT IT OCCURS TO ME
WHEN WE HIGHER MEDICAL FACULTY
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT AS
IN IT THAN HIRING A- NO LESS
IMPORTANT A POLITICAL SCIENCE
PRESS PROFESSOR WERE AN ENGLISH
PROFESSOR IN THAT THERE IS
ULTRA THERE IS- OTHER
EMPLOYMENT THAT TYPICALLY IS.
TIED TO THE RECRUITMENT AND
HIGHER OF A MEDICAL FACULTY
MEMBER OF PHYSICIAN IS THAT NOT
TO GET I'VE IF I COULD ONLY
ANSWER PART OF THE QUESTION
LISTED IN TO ANSWER FOR THE
QUESTION TO- BECAUSE AT YOUR
QUESTIONS RIGHT ON POINT. OF
FOUR EIGHT LET'S LET'S TAKE IN
A CHEMIST WHEN WE HIRE A
CHEMIST IT TAKES ABOUT A YEAR
TO DO THE RECRUITMENT THE
SEARCH IDENTIFY THE PERSON WE
NEED AND- WHETHER IT IS-
ORGANIC OR WHATEVER MIGHT BE.
UP WITH AND FIND A WAY TO BRING
THEM TO CAMPUS INCLUDING A FAIR
AMOUNT ANYWHERE FROM TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO A MILLION-DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
IN ADDITION TO THEIR SALARY TO
FACILITY TAKE THEIR LABORATORY
RESEARCH AND ALL THE REST. FOR
SUMMER MEDICAL SCHOOL FACULTY
THAT IS THE CASE- THAT WE HAVE
THANK YOU IN PROMOTE MANY OF A
HUGE INVESTMENT IN RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THEIR WORK BUT THEY CAN
SEE AN END TO THE RESEARCH WE
NEED TO. DEFEND A FIGHT
CORONAVIRUS. BUT YOU'RE ALSO
RIGHT A FAIR NUMBER THEM A
LARGE NUMBER OF THEM ARE
INVOLVED IN CLINICAL ACTIVITY
AND THAT MEANS ALL THIS
EMBEDDEDNESS ON PUTTING TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. I'M JUST
TO ADD TO THIS- THE CLINICAL
FALLACY THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
HIRE THEY NOT ONLY DO PLAN A
WAR BUT THEY ALSO. EDUCATION
AND KEEPING IN MIND THAT WE ARE
COMMUNITY BASED MEDICAL SCHOOL
WITHOUT A MEDICAL CENTER WE
CREATE VARIOUS PLATFORMS THAT
PROVIDE THE EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS SO WHEN I HIRE A
CLINICAL FACULTY I MAY SAY THAT
FORTY A 50% OF YOUR TIME WILL
BE DEDICATED TO CLAN OF A WORK
IN THE PLANET. ANOTHER 3040%
WOULD BE DEDICATED TO TEACHING
AND THEREFORE I HAVE TO HIGH
THE WHOLE F. T. E. NOT JUST THE
TEACHING PART BECAUSE AS A
CLINICIAN THEY DON'T JUST TEACH
THEY DO. CLINICAL WORK AS WELL.
TO THE PLACEMENTS NOT ONLY IN
THE LAST BUT ALSO IN A- SETTING
SOME ABSOLUTE EITHER OF YOUR-
OR SO. ELSE AND OF COURSE YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE CLINICAL
VOLUME TO DO THAT BUT ALSO THE
DEANS THEN RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING. A HOST OF CONTRACTS
WITH OTHER PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
REGION. SO WE HAVE TO COMMIT.
FOR INSTANCE RUN IN AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND THAT
MEANS EX NUMBER FIFTY EASE THAT
AS THE DANGER WENT OUT IS NOT.
PEOPLE ITS OTHERS UP A HOST OF.
ARRANGEMENTS THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONAL AS WELL AS
PERSONAL THESE INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLE HAVE TO DECIDE. THEIR
WHAT THE FUTURE'S GOING TO BE
SO DID THERE'S A LONG RAMP UP
PERIOD. THANK YOU FOR. THE
DIVERSION. MY ARE A PLEASURE- A
THIRD. UP ON THIS LIST OF WHY
WE NEED THE MONEY NOW IS
FACILITIES AND EQUIPMENT- WERE
VERY PROPER MEDICAL SCHOOL BUT-
WE'RE DOING A GREAT JOB THEY'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB WITH. LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE REALLY BEEN
SIMULATION I MEAN. FOR ALL OUR
STUDENTS. RIGHT NOW. AND THAT'S-
OKAY TRIBUTE TO THE PEOPLE THE
SCHOOL TO MAKE THAT WORK BUT IT
IS NOT A FUTURE. WE HAVE A LOT
OF FACILITIES INVESTMENTS WE
NEED TO MAKE BE READY TO DO A
OF A REALLY GOOD JOB AS WE AS
WE EXPAND THIS GROUP. THE CLASS
SIZES BEEN NOTED ARE ARE THIS
WILL PUT US ON OUR PATH TO FIVE
HUNDRED MEDICAL STUDENTS BY THE
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
WHICH IS A PRETTY AGGRESSIVE
SCHEDULE- I BELIEVE. AND THEN
LAST THE LA- IS CORRECT A YOU
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE ASKING WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO. AS WE RECENT
RESHAPE THIS WE'VE BEEN PUTTING
OUR NUMBERS ARE SEVENTY NINE
ONLY BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SIX
AND TEN LET'S AGREE. OF GENERAL
UNIVERSITY FUNDS HAVE BEEN.
SUBSIDIZING THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
REALLY FROM CONCEPTION AND
THAT'S JUST OPERATING THAT'S
NOT INCLUDING CAPITAL THE
SMMIT OF HAD HAD BY THE
MODULES AND SET HIM UP AND-
LEASES SPACE IT DOES YOU SEE
PATH AND SO FORTH. SO WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THAT A- I.
IT IS THE CASE THAT. ARE YOU
SEE ARE AS YOUR DOLLARS PER
STUDENT THAN MOST OF THE REST
OF THE UC- NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO WE'VE BEEN PART OF A
PRETTY. AGGRESSIVE AS A LOT OF
OTHER. HAVE AND WE'VE DONE THAT
WITHOUT NON RESIDENT FUNDS IN
LARGE LARGE. LARGE MEASURE SO
WHAT THIS WILL LET US DO IS GET
BACK TO. PROVIDING A SORT
RESOURCES IN THIS REPORT FOR
THE OTHER STUDENTS- THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. WE WISH WE
HAD BEEN ABLE TO DO FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. THOUGH IT
THE MONEY WILL GO TO THE TO
HELP THE STUDENTS FOR THE
GROWTH HAS BEEN. AND TO HELP
THE FEDERAL BUST NATURE OF WORK
WE WANTED TO THE STUDENTS WE'VE
HAD. WE WON A NATIONAL AWARD
FOR IMPROVED GRADUATION RATE.
IN A GRADUATE LEVEL. US WITH A
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS BUT WE'RE
STILL NOT WERE RELUCTANTLY. I
GUESS IT'S A FAIR STATEMENT TO
SAY THAT. BECAUSE IT'S OBVIOUS
FROM WHAT HOW. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND- TWELVE REALLY AND
BEFORE BUT CERTAINLY TWELVE
THIRTEEN AND TODAY. THAT THE
CAMPUS AND THIS CHANCELLOR. ARE
COMMITTED. TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE MEDICAL SCHOOL SO WHATEVER
RESOURCES THE CAMPUS HAS. YEAH
TO ENSURE THAT THE SIX ARE
MANAGEABLE IT'S NOT A
SUPPLEMENT. WE'RE ALL PART OF
THE FAMILY. WELL AFTER DARK
SOCIAL DISTANCE LEFT. LOVE TO
TALK TO YOU SEE YOU THE OTHER
ISSUE WAS THE USE UP CONTINUED
SUPPORT WILL HAVE YOU SEE OF P.
I'M SURE IN A SECOND. COME UP
AND TALK TO US ABOUT THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU IN AND ALL THREE OF US ARE
READY FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY
SEVERAL OF THE QUESTIONS WELL
NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION AS A
STATEMENT- YOU JUST A GREAT
SOURCE OF PRIDE FOR THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND- CANCER WILCOX DR
DEAN'S MS ALFARO A GREAT SEE
BOTH OF YOU AGAIN IT WAS JUST
LAST WEEK THAT WE'RE OUT OF THE
CAMPUS- AND WAS WONDERFUL TO
HAVE OUR YOUNG WOMEN'S
CONFERENCE THERE WITH OVER
THREE HUNDRED YOUNG WOMEN TO
HEAR ABOUT YOU SEE ARE AND HOW
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL YOU ARE AND
WHAT YOU'RE DOING BUT I JUST
THINK YOU KNOW WE DO DO A LOT
FOR OTHER C'S AND TO ME IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
THE SAME IF NOT MORE. FOR YOU
SEE OUR IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND REALLY BUILD A EVEN IN EVEN
MORE ROBUST MEDICAL SCHOOL
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE ARE WOEFULLY
SHORT WHEN IT COMES TO
PHYSICIANS AND RESEARCH SHOWS
THIS AS YOU WELL KNOW THAT WHEN
FOLKS TO THE RESIDENCY IN A
CERTAIN AREA THEY STAY THERE
AND WE WANT MYSELF FARO FROM
CHINO WHO WOULD IT HAVE SO I
WENT TO THE LOGO AND YES THAT
YOU SEE ARE TO STAY IN THE
REGION AND TAKE CARE OF OUR
FOLKS SO I WILL ALWAYS BE IN
SUPPORT OF WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE ADEQUATE
FUNDING. I THINK YOU'VE DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB ON THE LITTLE
BIT WE HAVE BEEN YOU SO I JUST
LOOK FORWARD TO DOING MORE AND
THANK YOU FOR MAKING US LOOK SO
GOOD IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. ZERO
YEAH I JUST WANNA SAY AGAIN
THANK YOU AS WE WORK TOGETHER
OVER THE YEARS AND JUST KEEP
MOVING FORWARD AND- WITH
SENATOR LEYVA WE ARE IN NEED OF
THAT MEDICAL SCHOOL- YES I
THINK WE ALL KNOW SO THANK YOU.
WELL I HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
LET'S DO THIS- MAYBE I CAN ASK.
FINANCE IN LA- TO SHIFT TO
THEIR TRADITIONAL CHAIRS UP
HERE IF YOU DON'T MIND
APPRECIATE. YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO LEAVE
CHANCES SOMEBODY MAY HAVE
SOMETHING UNLESS YOU TRYING TO
GET OUT OF YOUR- ARE YOU TRYING
TO SOCIAL DISTANCE FROM ME. AND
LET ME INVITE. OUR OTHER UC
REPRESENTATIVES UP. BECAUSE I
DO MY FAMILY TOO I COMPLETELY.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND I DO
THINK WE OUGHT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FRESNO UCSF
OPERATION AND ALSO MADE PERHAPS
YOU COULD TOUCH N THE LA THOSE
POINTS- HAVING TO DO WITH
CONTINUED COMMITMENT- AND
FUNDING OF THE UC OUR MEDICAL
SCHOOL I BELIEVE THERE WAS A
COMMENT IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS
ABOUT. THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FUNDING- ANNUAL. SO THOSE
ISSUES MA'AM OKAY. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US IF YOU TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD. COME ON NOT YET ONE
MORE PUSH. NOW YOU ARE ALL
RIGHT THERE WE GO. RED
ORDINARILY MEAN STOP I'M SO-
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KATHERINE NATION I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR HEALTH SCIENCES
WHICH MEANS THE HEALTH SCIENCES
INSTRUCTIONAL SYSTEM FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
INCLUDES HAPPILY ARE SIX SCHOOL%
OF MEDICINE- BUT FIVE LONG
STANDING SCHOOLS- I ALSO BRING
A VANTAGE POINT OF LONG SERVICE
ON THE STATE'S CALIFORNIA HELP
WORKFORCE POLICY COMMISSION.
WHICH IS REALLY GIVEN ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK IN TRACK
STATE WORKFORCE NEEDS ACROSS
THE REGION BOTH FOR PHYSICIANS
ADVANCED PRACTICE PROVIDERS AND
OTHERS AND THEN IS AN ADDITION
I SERVED AS THE SENIOR ADVISER
FOR PRESIDENT IMPALA CANO IN
HER CAPACITY AS THE CO CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE WORKFORCE
COMMISSION. SO ALL OF THAT DOWN
BRING SO A BIT OF A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON I ALSO WANT TO
ECHO TRANSFER WILCOX'S
GRATITUDE- BEFORE THEY DIED
GOVERNOR IN ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT ATTENTION- TO BOTH OF
THESE REGIONS OF THE STATE- I
AM AT A LONG DEEP BELIEVER IN
THE FUTURE ON THE PROMISE OF
THE RIVERSIDE- SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE THOSE RESOURCES ARE
VITALLY NEEDED- WITH ME IN
SPIRIT- BUT BUT NOT NEXT TO ME
TODAY OR THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
UCSF SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
CHANCELLOR HOW GOOD- DEAN
TALMADGE KING IN THE VICE DEAN
FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION WHO'S
DONE EXTENSIVE WORK WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU SEE FRESNO
AND- WE'RE SAID- AND WITH. MY
INVOLVEMENT REALLY THROUGHOUT
ON THE POSSIBILITIES FOR
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM THERE
SO- I THINK- SHORTEN DECK HAS
BEEN CIRCULATED IN A FIVE
MIGHT- I TAKE A FEW MINUTES-
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A
DRIVER FOR CONSIDERATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE WITH
THESE PROPOSED FUNDS AGAIN BOTH
REGIONS IN VITAL NEED. FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THIS
IS MISSION ALIGNED- WE HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO OPERATE- AMONG
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL AND HIGHLY
REGARDED MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN THE
NATION AND INTERNATIONALLY AND
WE BELIEVE THAT CABLE. SHOULD
BE LEVERAGED. IN AREAS LIKE THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THAT ARE NOT
HOME TO A MEDICAL SCHOOL
RIVERSIDE BY CONTRAST HAD A
LONG HISTORY WITH UCLA THAT
HELPED BUILD THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I KIND OF BE
BEGIN WITH A DEMOGRAPHIC-
IMPERATIVE- SO WE'LL SWITCH NOW
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HERE YOU SEE-
THE REGION WITH EIGHT COUNTIES
IS HOME TO FOUR POINT THREE-
MILLION PEOPLE AND IS ALSO
AMONG THE FASTEST GROWING
REGIONS OF THE STATE- SIMILAR
TO THE CHALLENGES WE KNOW THAT
EXIST FOR THE INLAND EMPIRE- WE
HAVE THE S. A. J. V. THAT. LAGS
IN VIRTUALLY ALL SOCIO ECONOMIC
AND HEALTH CARE INDICATORS
AGAIN AND I CAN SAY THAT I'VE
WATCHED THAT BE TRUE IN MY ROLE
AS COMMISSIONER I'VE WATCHED IT
BE TRUE AS WE WATCH MEDICAL
STUDENTS FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SEEK ADMISSION TO A
PUBLIC MEDICAL SCHOOL WITH NO
PLACE TO GO. INLAND EMPIRE
BEYOND S. JV HAVE HIGH RATES OF
POVERTY- THE S. JB IN
PARTICULAR HAS POOR AIR
QUALITY- TROUBLESOME FOR OUR
KIDS AND OLDER ADULTS AND YOU
SEE FOUR OF THOSE COUNTIES THAT
ARE AT THE BOTTOM OF THIS
STATE- FOR THEIR RESIDENTS AND
HEALTH OUTCOMES. SO WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER ABOUT
SHORTAGES OF POSITIONS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE THE SHORTAGES ARE
AS DIRE FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY- YOU HAVE DATA BEFORE
YOU AND I WON'T GO INTO DETAIL
BUT IT IS AVAILABLE SHOULD IT
BE OF. INTEREST THAT THIS EIGHT
COUNTY REGION HAS AMONG THE
LOWEST RATES OF PROVIDERS- IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATION WITH REALLY A GENERATION
OF PROVIDER SLATED TO RETIRE
AND ALL ALL PUT A PAUSE ON.
THAT BECAUSE- I SPEND TIME WITH
COLLEAGUES IN A NATIONAL
CONTEXT IN TERMS OF MEDICAL
SCHOOLS THE CHANCELLOR
MENTIONED. THE EYES OF MEDICAL
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WATCHING FOR THEIR SUCCESS IN
THE INVESTMENT OF YOU SEE ARE.
ON BUT ALL ALL ALSO SAY THAT WE
KNOW A LOT ABOUT- DEMANDS FOR
MEDICAL STUDENT EDUCATION THE
THINGS THAT LEVERAGE SUCCESS
THE PREDICTIVE VALUE WHICH
INCLUDES RESIDENCY TRAINING BUT
WHAT'S PREDICTIVE OF. WHERE
STUDENTS WERE ULTIMATELY
PRACTICES WHERE THEY HAVE TIES
TO THEIR COMMUNITY. DO YOU SEE
OUR IN OUR EXTRAORDINARY
MEDICAL STUDENT HERE WITH TIES
TO THE COMMUNITY THE OBVIOUS
PART OF THAT AND RIVERSIDE HAS
PREFERENTIAL CONSIDERATION FOR
STUDENTS WHO COME FROM THE
REGION. PROGRAM ALL TALK ABOUT
SHORTLY WOULD ALSO SIMILARLY
HAVE PREFERENTIAL CONSIDERATION
FOR STUDENTS THAT COME FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THIS IS PREDICTED. AND IF
WE KEEP THEM THERE AND TRAIN
THEM THERE WE STACKED TOGETHER
THE BEST PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW
OVER. DECADES AND DECADES OF
TIME ABOUT HOW TO ENHANCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF STUDENTS GOING
THROUGH MEDICAL SCHOOL THEN
TRAINING AND THEN ENTERING
PRACTICE FOR ENTIRE PRACTICE
CAREER IN A REGION. THERE'S NOT
ANY INDICATION THAT STUDENTS
FROM- OTHER COMMUNITIES WITH NO
CONNECTION ARE LIKELY TO
MIGRATE. ON SO. I EASY YOU SEE
THE EVIDENCE OF THIS IS LOW-
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE HAS AMONG
THE OLDEST PHYSICIANS. IN THE
NATION I THINK WERE MAYBE
BEHIND IN MEXICO- THAT MEANS
THE SHORTAGES THAT OFSTED
REPORTS ON EVERY YEAR THOSE ARE
GOING TO GROW WE'RE WE'RE
LOSING PACE- OUR RELIANCE ON IN
MIGRATION OF. STUDENTS AND
RESIDENTS TRAINED ELSEWHERE IS
NOT FILLING THE GAP THE GAPS
ARE WIDENING AND WHEN THIS
WHOLE GENERATION GETS READY TO
RETIRE OVER THIS NEXT YEAR-
THOSE THOSE SHORTAGES ON WHAT
WILL BE GREATER TODAY- THAN
THEY ARE. SO YOU SEE IT'S A
FRESNO- I THINK IS THE TITLE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S- LINE ITEM
BUT LET ME SAY THAT THAT BEGAN
FORTY THAT THAT. THAT PROGRAM
IS PRIMARILY GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION FOCUS THIS IS
RESIDENCY TRAINING IT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS.
UCSF AND UC DAVIS SEND STUDENTS
IT'S ALSO HOME TO MEDICAL. FROM
OTHER SCHOOLS WHERE IT- IS
POSSIBLE TO ACCOMMODATE THEM SO
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE TEACHING
FACULTY WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
RESIDENCY PROGRAM- THAT HAVE A
RECORD OF SUCCESS IN PREPARING
THE REGION'S WORKFORCE. WHICH
IS THE AIM OF THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
GM ME FOR THE INLAND EMPIRE
IT'S PROVEN IT'S PREVENT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IT'S
PROVEN IN THIS STATE. WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS IN
THIS REGION- OF CALIFORNIA SO
THIS FOUNDATION AT UCSF IS.
REALLY ON THE CRITICAL RESOURCE
FOR MEDICAL STUDENT ROTATIONS
FOR RESIDENCY TRAINING FOR
REGIONAL PRODUCTS PRESENCE THAT
WOULD LEVERAGE. CLINICAL
FACULTY EXPERIENCE FACULTY- WHO
KNOW HOW TO TEACH FROM THE HOW
TO TRAIN RESIDENTS RESIDENTS
ARE INTEGRAL TO THE INSTRUCTION
OF MEDICAL STUDENTS SO. THAT
YOU CASF RUST ON FRESNO MEANS
THAT THAT RESOURCE DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE BUILT IT'S AN AND
DURING STATE RESOURCE THAT
COULD BE LEVERAGED- FOR THIS
PURPOSE. WE DID WE JUST MAKE A
COMMENT. I HAVE BEEN A
SUPPORTER. OF ESTABLISHING A
MEDICAL SCHOOL OPERATION. IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. THE TIME I
ARRIVED HERE. IN THE BEGINNING
OF TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
SAME TIME THAT I CAME UP AND
OBVIOUSLY WAS ADVOCATING AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA. GROUP SO YOU HAVE A.
A FRIENDLY CROWD HERE I KNOW
THAT- I KNOW THAT AND I SAID
THAT ACTUALLY LEAVING HIS MY
TIME RIGHT NOW IS ALL COVERED
NINETEEN I THOUGHT AS I LEFT MY
STAFF AND HOME AND I WAS LIKE
IT'S A COMMITTEE WHO
UNDERSTANDS THESE ISSUES AND I
I'M ALSO PERSONALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT LEADERSHIP AND INSIGHT
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THESE
ISSUES THAT YOU ALL BRING
BECAUSE WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
TANGIBLE BENEFITS OF.
ESTABLISHING A OF A MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN A PARTICULAR REGION
AND- WHETHER IT TRAINS DOCTORS
AND WERE ABLE TO RE TRAINED WE
RETAIN PHYSICIANS AND- WEAVES
THROUGH THE- SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. THIS GOVERNOR
AND THE FORMER GOVERNOR WE'VE
DIRECTED. SURPRISINGLY BUT
THANKFULLY STATE MONEY TOWARD
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF ADDITIONAL
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS BOTH. AS
THROUGH THE TOBACCO TAX MEASURE
IN SONG BROWN IN ADDITION TO
THE FEDERAL MONEY THAT FLOWS TO
US THROUGH- OF THE MEDIC HERE A
RELATED PROGRAMS- BUT THEY'RE
ALSO INTANGIBLE BENEFITS TO
ESTABLISHING. A MEDICAL SCHOOL
IN A REGION THAT ARE ALMOST IN
SOME CASES IN CAPABLE OF BEING
MEASURED OR QUANTIFIED AND
YOU'RE- YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
TALKING WHO CONSTANTLY SPEAKS
ABOUT GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND
METRICS. BUT I DO READ
RECOGNIZE ON OCCASION THERE ARE
INTANGIBLE BENEFITS THEY'RE
HARD TO MEASURE YET ARE JUST AS
VALUABLE. AS THE TANGIBLE STUFF
SO I DON'T WANT TO BE. SEND
YOUR TRAIN OFF THE TRACK BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET TO HOW
WE- DO WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE
HAVE THESE OPTIONS AND I
REALIZE THEIR POLITICS UP THERE
AND- WE ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THAT SO. OKAY IS
SO I'M A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK WITH THE UCSF LEADERSHIP
MY DIRECT INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S SUPPORT WITH MERCED
WITH UCSF FRESNO ON WE HAD THE
BENEFIT OF THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN OUR SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PRIME PROGRAM I'M AN
ORIGINAL ARCHITECT OF THE PRIME
PROGRAM THAT STANDS FOR STANDS
FOR PROGRAMS IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION. BEST AB PROGRAM IS
OUR ONLY GEOGRAPHICALLY
DESIGNATED PRIME PROGRAM
MEANING IT FOCUSES ON THE
REGION SO WE'VE GOT OTHERS ON-
BUT THAT FOCUS OF AIR SO THAT
ONE POINT EIGHT FIVE FIVE
MILLION THAT THAT WAS PROVIDED
A SEVERAL YEARS AGO WAS MODELED
ON A MEDICAL STUDENT-
CONTRIBUTION OF THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR MEDICAL
STUDENTS THIS DOESN'T COVER THE
COST. INSTRUCTION OR
SUPERVISION COSTS ARE HIGHER
WHEN YOU HAVE SMALLER CLASSES
THIS COMES ALSO WITH TUITION
BUT THAT WAS THE MODEL AND THE
BASIS FOR THAT FIGURE- AT THAT
TIME SO THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT. TO SUPPORT
AN ULTIMATE TOTAL ENROLLMENT OF
FORTY EIGHT MEDICAL STUDENTS
COOPER CLASS- LAST YEAR WITH
THE INCOMING- CLASS OF FIRST
YEAR MEDICAL STUDENTS. BY
LEADERSHIP AGREEMENT WITH A
COMMITMENT ON THIS REGION WE
MIGRATED TO- DEAL SAMMY
ACCREDITING SCHOOL FOR AS JV
FROM THE DAVIS CAMPUS. TO UCSF
AND THIS IS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF CALENDARS AND TO LEVERAGE
THAT RELATIONSHIP AT UCSF AND
THE RESPONSIBILITY THE UCSF
HOUSE. FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION SO THIS WAS A SHARED
DECISION THAT THIS WAS IN THE
REGION'S BEST INTEREST TO MY
GREAT THIS. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN- AND I WOULD SAY THAT
LEADERSHIP- COMMITMENT TO
WORKING ON THIS ACROSS
LOCATIONS HAS BEEN HIGH AND
GENUINE IT'S BEEN A PRIVILEGE
FOR ME TO BE PART OF IT-
THROUGHOUT WE RETAIN DELOITTE
ON TO HELP US LOOK ON. LOOK AT
MODELS AND SO THIS WAS NOT
ANTICIPATING THE THIS YEAR'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS WAS TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH A VISION FOR
WHAT MIGHT BE POSSIBLE FOR
EXPANDING MEDICAL EDUCATION. SO
WE LOOKED AT A HYBRID MODEL WE
LOOKED AT TWO YEARS AT UCSF.
FOR BASIC SCIENCES TWO YEARS AT
FRESNO WE LOOK AT A FULL BRANCH
CAMPUS MODEL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
GREATER INVESTMENT RIGHT WITH
TWO YEARS AT UCSF FRESNO WARMER
SAID. THERE'S VALUE IN
CONTINUITY OF MEDICAL EDUCATION
IN OUR REGION. AND WE LOOK AT A
JOINT MODEL WITH- SO EITHER
BASIC SCIENCES AT UCSF. FRESNO
OR AT RISK SAID BUT RECOGNIZING
WE NEED TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPABILITY
FOR TEACHING. AS WE CONTINUE
THE DISCUSSIONS WITH THIS- WITH
THIS LEADERSHIP GROUP AND
THINKING ABOUT THE FUTURE WE
BEGAN TO TALK ABOUT AN
ALTERNATIVE MODEL AND THAT WAS
FIRST PROPOSED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND THAT MODEL IS-
UNIQUE WITHIN THE STATE- AND
ALIGNS. VERY NICELY WITH THE
NEEDS AND THE VISION FOR THIS
PROGRAM- GOING FORWARD THIS
WOULD BE A COMBINED. AND THE
ONLY SUCH PROGRAM OF ITS TYPE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH WOULD BE A COMBINED
BACCALAUREATE- MD PROGRAM. THIS
WOULD BE AN EIGHT YEAR PROGRAM.
WITH INCOMING FRESHMEN-
ADMITTED TO A- TRACK IN A
PROGRAM WITH ACADEMIC
ENRICHMENT AND SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE. FUNNELING THEM
THROUGH- A PROCESS. LEADING TO
A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE FROM UC
MERCED. AT AND ENABLING THEN
THE TRANSITION TO BECOME A
FIRST YEAR MEDICAL STUDENT.
WHERE FROM WHERE FOUNDATIONS IN
MEDICAL EDUCATION COULD BE
TAUGHT AGAIN. CONTINGENT AS- MY
CAN COLLEAGUES TO THE RIGHT OF
OBSERVED ON ADEQUATE. STABLE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT EDUCATION WE
CAN'T STOP AND START THESE
THINGS AND PUT OUR CAMPUS
REPUTATIONS AT RISK FOR OUR
STUDENTS AT RISK TO ACT AND
THIS DOES REQUIRE ADVANCE
INVESTMENT FOR THE REASONS THE
CHAMP ON DEAN HAVE DESCRIBED WE
NEED TO HAVE THE FACULTY IN
PLACE TO DO THIS. BUT STUDENTS
COULD COMPLETE THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE. ON THE
LCM ME- WOULD RECOGNIZE UNDER
THIS MODEL AND WE'RE DOING- A
GREAT DEAL OF ACTIVE MODELING
AS WE SPEAK AND THERE WILL BE
THE ABILITY TO COME BACK. I
THINK AND THREE TO FOUR WEEKS
WITH MORE DETAIL ON BUDGET AND
USE AND SITE AND TIMING- BUT
BUT I'M PREPARED TO SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT MAY BE
POSSIBLE- TODAY SO THIS EIGHT
YEAR PROGRAM- COULD POTENTIALLY.
INTENTION AGAIN UPON STABLE
OPERATING ROSE- REVENUES AT
ADMITTED CLASS OF TWELVE
STUDENTS WITH THE FALL CLASS OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WHICH IN
MEDICAL EDUCATION. THESE WOULD
NOT BE MEDICAL STUDENTS THESE
WOULD BE FRESHMEN RIGHT I MEAN
SO THE ADMISSIONS IS AHEAD OF
OUR- WITH MISSION PROCESS IS
THE HEAD OF THE MOVE OF
STUDENTS TO CAMPUS TO BEGIN AN
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS. THE CURRENT
YEAR AND NEXT WOULD BE AIMED AT
AT PLANNING- PREPARATION OF
MERCED FACULTY INVESTMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENABLE THIS
POSSIBILITY BUT THIS IS- WHERE
WE ARE IN DIALOGUE WHICH IS.
VERY ACTIVE- AMONG THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE SITES THAT I
HAVE NAMED- IF THIS WERE
POSSIBLE. THE UC MERCED CAMPUS
COULD OPERATE AS A REGIONAL
CAMPUS OF THE UCSF SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. WHERE SITE IS NOT
AUTHORIZED OR CREDITED BY THE
LCM ME AND WOULD NOT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ANYTIME IN THE
NEA FUTURE AND ON ITS OWN SO
THIS LEVERAGES CAPABILITY AND
SCALE OF A LONGSTANDING TOP
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THIS COUNTRY
BY ABILITY WHICH I AGAIN WE'VE
SETTLED LAW ALL ALONG ITS
MISSION ALIGNED WE KNOW HOW TO
DO THIS- THE FACULTY AT RISK
SAID. WOULD HAVE TO BE
RECRUITED TO DO THIS TEACHING
THERE IS NO MEDICAL SCHOOL
FACULTY EVEN FOR A SMALL COHORT
pNEED TO BE IN A POSITION TO
TEACH THE UCS OF CURRICULUM SO
THE L. SAMMY REQUIRES-
COMPARABILITY. INDEPENDENT OF
GEOGRAPHY GEOGRAPHIC SITE
MERCED WOULD NOT HAVE DEGREES
OF FREEDOM TO DO SOMETHING LAST
BECAUSE IT WAS A NEW PROGRAM.
STUDENTS IN A UCS UP PROGRAM
REGARDLESS OF SITE WE NEED TO
BE ASSURED OF THE SAME ACCESS
TO ACADEMIC RESEARCH IS THE
SAME CALIBER OF INSTRUCTION THE
SAME LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
PREPARING THEM TO GRADUATE WITH
A MEDICAL DEGREE SO JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND IT'S SOMETHING
SIMILAR BUT NOT. TOTALLY
SIMILAR TO WHAT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE HAD BEEN
DOING FOR YEARS PRIOR TO TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN SO THE
STUDENTS WHO WERE ADMITTED
WOULD COMPLETE THEIR FOR YOU
THE NORMAL FOUR YEARS OF AN
UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAM HOWEVER
THERE ADMITTED. AND THEN
COMPLETE THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THE BASIC SCIENCE. CURRICULUM
FOR OF THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
CURRICULUM. IF THIS PLAN
HAPPENS TO BE THE ONE THAT'S
ADOPTED. AT THE UC MERCED
CAMPUS. TAUGHT IN THOSE TWO
YEARS USING THE UCSF. CARRILLO
CURRICULUM BY. A RECRUITED
FACULTY WHO ARE. ACCUSTOMED TO
TEACHING MEDICAL STUDENTS. AND
THEN MOVING IN IT THERE'S
ACTUALLY I WON'T TAKE THAT
COMMITTEES TIME THIS THIS
MORNING BECAUSE THE DOUBLES IN
THE DETAIL AND IT THIS IS
COMPLEX TERRITORY THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET RIGHT. ON
BUT WE ACTUALLYBE CLOSER TO
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS THAT
WOULD BE AT UC MERCED TO ALIGN
WITH UCSF PRACTICES OF TO.
SPLIT INTO A BRIDGES CURRICULUM
THAT LAND WOULD END ITSELF-
BUT BUT FOR OBSERVATION THAT
THIS WOULD BE THE UCSF
CURRICULUM. IS RIGHT BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE REQUIRED IN ORDER FOR
YOU CASF TO BE THE DEGREE
GRANTING- MEDICAL SCHOOL FOR
THE STUDENTS AND THEN AFTER
THAT EIGHTEEN MONTHS LATER YOU
SEE MERCED A FLIP SOMEWHERE
THEY WOULD THEY WOULD GO TO THE
REGIONAL CAMPUS A SECOND
REGIONAL CAMPUS OF UCSF WHICH
IS YOU CASF- PRESENT PRESS NO.
FOR CLINICAL CLERKSHIPS MOST OF
WHICH ARE LONG ESTABLISHED AND
THEY WOULD COMPLETE SELECTIVE
ROTATIONS WHERE THOSE EXIST
WHICH IS A SUBSTANTIAL ARRAY.
MEDICAL STUDENTS SOMETIMES
ROTATE TO OTHER INSTITUTIONS
DEPENDING UPON THE SPECIALTY
THEY MIXED SO THAT WOULDN'T
PRECLUDE THAT OPTION- THE
BENEFIT HERE. IS THAT THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BE INTENTIONALLY
DESIGNED IN A MANNER THAT IS
VERY YOU UNIQUE BY EITHER I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE HISTORY
OF THE RIVERSIDE PROGRAM. AND
YOU'RE CORRECT THAT THERE ARE
SIMILARITIES BUT THERE ARE
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES-
ADMISSION OF STUDENTS INTO THIS
TRACK IS TO INCOMING FRESHMEN.
WOULD BE PRIORITIZED FOR
STUDENTS FROM THE REGION. RIGHT
THE THIS THAT THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE NOT LOOKING TO ADMIT
STUDENTS FROM WEST WOULD. OR
SAN DIEGO THE STUDENT WOULD
THAT THIS PROGRAM WOULD
PRIORITIZE. THE RECRUITMENT OF
INCOMING FRESHMEN WITH TIES TO
THE TO THE BROADER REGION NOT
JUST MERCED COUNTY BUT THE
BROADER AND BROADER INLAND
EMPIRE AND YOU SEE THAT BY HIGH
SCHOOL LOCATION FAMILY TIES ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU WOULD KNOW
WELL. IT MUST BE AN INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM SO YOU'RE IN YOU'RE IN
ESSENCE TAKING WHAT THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL CURRENTLY DOES FOR
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND EXPANDING
IT. MOVING IT BACK TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE COLLEGE
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE AND THERE
ARE FEW OF THESE PROGRAMS IN
THE UNITED STATES THEY HAVE A
RECORD. OF SUCCESS IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY- THERE ARE NOT MANY
THIS WOULD HAVE THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF BEING UNIQUE AMONG.
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
UC MERCED CAMPUS- WHICH IS ALSO
LIKE RIVERSIDE GROWING QUICKLY-
WITH WITH STUDENTS WHO COME
FROM THE REGION IS INCOMING
UNDERGRADUATES. ON THIS WOULD
BE A DIFFERENTIATOR BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE THE ONLY EIGHT YEAR
PROGRAM. YES AND MD IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND ALL
COME COME BACK FOR ONE MINUTE
ON. THE RELEVANCE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE WE'VE NOT
APPRECIATE. BANDED MEDICAL
STUDENT ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- FOR DECADES. AND
TELL. RIVERSIDE WE HAVE A PRIME
INITIATIVE WHICH IS NOT A TOPIC
FOR TODAY BUT THAT WAS SOME
ENROLLMENT EXPANSION. WITHIN
OUR EXISTING SCHOOLS. THERE IS
THERE ARE STILL NOT INVESTMENT
OF STATE FUNDING FOR TWO THIRDS
OF THOSE SLOTS- BUT WHAT WE DO
KNOW IS WORTH THE BOTTOM IN THE
NATION AND MEDICAL STUDENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THE
NATION BUT- WE ARE AT THE TOP
OF THE NATION IN TERMS OF THE
RETENTION OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WE EDUCATE HERE AND
THAT IS MISSION ALIGNED SO FOUR
OF OUR SIX UC MEDICAL SCHOOLS
ADMIT A 100% CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS YOU SEE A SEVEN UCLA
DID YOU TAKE STUDENTS- FROM
OTHER STATES WHO ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY- COMPETITIVELY
ELIGIBLE. BUT WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO WANT TO
STAY HERE ON ONE REMAIN HERE
THEIR FAMILY TIES AND SO IF
THERE IS PROOF AND EVIDENCE OF
THE VALUE OF THE RETURN ON THE
INVESTMENT OF STATE RESOURCES
WHICH WE'VE- NOT UNFORTUNATELY
SEEN VERY LITTLE OF- BUT BUT I
THINK THE PREDICTIVE VALUE OF
INVESTING IN. YOU SEE AS THE
STATE'S PUBLIC MEDICAL SCHOOLS
THE PRIORITIZE THE ADMISSION
AND TRAINING OF OUR OWN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAS PROVEN
A RETURN ON THE INVESTMENT BY
EVERY NATIONAL MEASURE- SO THIS
IS WHERE WE- WHERE WE ARE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD BE IN A
POSITION WITH MORE DETAILS TO
FOLLOW TO IT TO ADMIT- IN. FALL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- PORT OF THE
FIRST WE WOULD CONTINUE OUR S.
JB PRIME PROGRAM. SO THIS IS A
MEDICAL SCHOOL WE WOULD COULD
BEGIN A FRESHMAN PROGRAM IT
MERCED. CRIME WOULD CONTINUE IT
AND WILL RAMP TO TWELVE
STUDENTS AT UCSF- WITH WITH THE
CLASS NEXT YEAR- UCSF HAS RE
ORDER ORIENTED THEIR OUTREACH
TO STUDENTS TO PREFERENTIALLY
ADMIT AND RECRUIT TIME STUDENTS
FROM THE VALLEY. FOR PRIME
THERE IS IN A IN A MORE ROBUST
WAY THAT WE THINK WILL ADD SOME
VALUE. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE WELL I
JUST WANT TO TELL YOU HOW
SUPPORT OF I AM AND HOW
DELIGHTED I AM TO HEAR THIS AND
PROBABLY NO MORE SO THAN MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT REGION OF THE STATE
AND JUST AS WE ADVOCATE FOR
THOSE OF US WHO REPRESENT
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
NEEDS ARE ESSENTIALLY.
CERTAINLY THE SAME IF NOT IN
SOME CASES GREATER IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT AND I AM.
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND DOING WHATEVER I CAN TO-
HELP WHATEVER THE FINAL PLAN
IS- SUCCEEDS SO. YES THE ONLY
OTHER COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
FOR THE FOR THIS GROUP THIS
MORNING. AND I'M WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE- AS IT WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WHICH IS
LITERALLY WEEKLY THE LEVEL OF
INTENSITY OF WORK ON THIS IS
HIGH AND- AND GENUINE IS. WE
HAVE INTENTIONALLY COME
TOGETHER OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS INCLUDING THIS
ALTERNATIVE MODEL. TO CREATE A
FOUNDATION AND A BONAFIDE
FUTURE PATHWAY. FORMER SAID TO
ALTERNATELY BECOME AN
INDEPENDENT LCM THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL. SO THIS THIS BUILDING
OF THE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE TEACHING CAPABILITY
WITH A SMALL PROGRAM LEVERAGING
UCSF. ACCREDITATION PAVES THE
WAY NOT ONLY FOR GROWTH AGAIN
OPERATING MONEY SEE FOR ME
RIVERSIDE TO GO FROM SEVENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN STUDENTS TO
ONE TWENTY FIVE WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FACULTY. THIS
PROGRAM WOULD START SMALL- BUT
IT WOULD HAVE CONCURRENT
NUMBERS OF MEDICAL STUDENTS AND
UNDERGRADUATES RIGHT THAT COULD
SCALE TO- FULLY ENROLLED SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE ONE DAY OF BEFORE
THE WISH OF THE STATE AND THERE
WERE THE ADEQUACY OF
INVESTMENTS THAT'S WITH.
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY UNIQUE AN
INTENTIONAL TO CREATE A PATH
FORWARD- THAT DISTINCT WOULD
INCREASE AT LIKE THREE HUNDRED
EACH STAGE MY- LAW SCHOOL
PROFESSOR SAID BY THE EDGES TO
SENSE BY THE YARD IT'S HARD. I
THINK INCREMENTAL IS THE WAY TO
GO IT'S NOT OFTEN WHAT WE DO
HERE IN SACRAMENTO BUT- WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S CELL MOVES ALONG.
YES IF I COULD I'M JUST GOING
TO REFLECT ON THIS CONVERSATION
RELATIVE TO THE UC OUR HISTORY
I WE'RE WE'RE PROUD OF OUR
HISTORY BUT IF AND WHEN I SIT
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN. IF IN NINETEEN
NINETY OR NINETEEN EIGHTY OR
SOME TO THE DATE. WE HAVE HAD
THE SAME KIND OF LONG TERM
VISION. MR WE HAD A VISION FOR
TWO YEARS AND RESIDE TWO YEARS
IN A WAY WHICH WAS A GREAT
VISION AND IT SERVED US WELL
BUT IF WE HAD THOUGHT BOUT THE
LONG TERM TRAJECTORY OF OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOL. IN IN RIVERSIDE
IN THE LONG TERM PROJECT WE
HAVE STUDENTS LIKE MARLENE AND
BY WHAT THEIR LIFE WOULD BE
THAT'S THAT'S THE BEAUTY I
THINK OF THIS PROPOSAL IT IT
HAS A DIFFERENT SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL OF US.
AND FOR THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT
AYE AYES STREAM OF FUNDING
OFTEN THE FUTURES HEART- TO
THAT'S- THE HARDEST PART OF
YOUR JOB AND IT HAS AT THE
CENTER RESPONSIBLY FOR US. IN
MERCED NOW THERE WILL BE AN
INSTITUTIONAL COMMITMENT IN A
AND IT'S MERCED BUT IT'S THE
WHOLE UC TO A GROUP OF STUDENTS
WERE FRESHMEN- THAT'S A
DIFFERENT KIND OF
RESPONSIBILITY SET AND I THINK
IT'S ST TO DOCTOR NATION'S
CREDIT TO LOTS OF OTHER
PEOPLE'S CREDIT THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO THINK THAT WAY. AND
IT'S TO ALL OF YOU I APPRECIATE
AGAIN YOUR SUPPORT FOR LETTING
US THINK IN A MORE HOLISTIC WAY.
IT'S HUGE. I AGREE. WELL
INCREMENTALLY IT. OF EASIER TO
HANDLE BOTH FROM A BUDGET
STANDPOINT AND OTHERWISE- IN
TERMS OF PLANNING AND TESTING
IN DECIDING WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T WORK SO AGAIN I LOOK
FORWARD I'M DELIGHTED THAT YOU
ARE MOVING DOWN THIS PATH I
THANK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO HAVE NOT ONLY
SUPPORTING. SCHOOL ANALYSTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA OF COURSE BUT
RECOGNIZING THE NEED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN WHAT SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES BOTH HERE AND
CERTAINLY OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON FOR MANY
MANY YEARS SO WE'LL MAKE IT
HAPPEN. ANY QUESTIONS SO EVERY
ROW THANK YOU SON ANY COMMENTS
FROM. THE FOLKS OVER TO MY
RIGHT WHO PROVIDE US WITH
ADVICE AND HELP. COME ON CASEY.
NO I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY A
YOU HAD ASKED ABOUT THE. THE
STATUS UPDATE ON THE FACILITY
THAT WAS AUTHORIZED IN MERCED
AND SHE WANTED TO CLARIFY MAYBE
THIS DIDN'T COME OUT BUT WE HAD
BEEN. SIGNAL BY THE UNIVERSITY
THAT WAS INTENDING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE FACILITY
PROJECT- WITHOUT NECESSARILY RE
SUBMITTING A PROPOSAL- THEY
WERE PLANNING TO AUTHORIZE IT-
THIS DISC THIS ARE COMING FEW
MONTHS I JUST TO GET MORE
UPDATED ON INFORMATION ON THAT
JUST TO CLARIFY ITS REAL
LEGISLATURE'S EXPECTATION OF
WHAT THAT APPROVAL PROCESS
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. COULD BE THAT
COULD BE BENEFICIAL TO EXPLORE
THAT THIS YEAR WILL IS A
PROCESS FOR THAT. THE FINANCING.
YOU'VE HEARD THE LAST
CONVERSATION SO HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT TO WHATEVER
THE- WHATEVER COMES FORWARD WE
HAVE A FEW MONTHS YEAH. EXACTLY
AND I WILL SAY THAT THAT. THAT
AIM ON AND THIS REGION I COULD
BE SITTING ON BEHALF OF
RIVERSIDE IF THE RIVERSIDE TEAM
WERE WERE ELSEWHERE I'M IF THE
PRIVILEGE TO BE A PARTNER WITH
RIVERSIDE EVERY DAY. BUT MANY
OF THE SAME OBSERVATIONS APPLY
THE VITAL IMPORTANCE OF FULL
FUNDING TO ENABLE US TO DO WHAT
WE CAN. RELATED TO
ACCREDITATION IT RELATES TO
RECRUITMENT IT RELATES TO YOU
KNOW TO PREDICTIONS OF SUCCESS-
AND HAD A HAD SORT OF A HALF
WAY FIFTEEN MILLION WOULD BE
INCREMENTAL TO STARTING. NOT
SCALING A FULL MEDICAL SCHOOL
THAT WOULD BE THERE INCOME ON
THAT FIFTEEN MILLION WOULD OR
NOT NOT ENABLE US O LAUNCH A
SMALL PROGRAM. AND WOULD CALL
INTO QUESTION THE LEVEL OF
STATE COMMITMENT SORT OF GOING
FORWARD WE CAN'T SEND OUR TEAM
OFF ANA. ACROSS STATE JOURNEY
SORT OF WITH A- TANK OF GAS AND
SAYING WE- REFILL WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU GET THERE AND WE ARE
PLANNING INTENTIONALLY- FOR
PROGRAM THAT COULD EXIST OF
THEIR STUDY. IF THERE CITY
OPERATING REVENUE THE LEVEL
THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED WELL OF
COURSE THIS IS ALL OF IN THIS
FORTUNATE THAT THE GOVERNOR PUT
THIS IN THE JANUARY BUT BUT
PROPOSED. SO IT'S COSTING US IS
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WHAT IS
ACTUALLY REQUIRED IS A DETAILED
PLAN YOU SEE AS TO WHAT. BUT
CAN TO DO. WHAT THE TIMING IS.
HOW IT'S GOING TO BE STAGED.
WHAT THE COST ELEMENTS ARE. SO
WE CAN MAKE DETERMINATIONS AND
CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN MAKE
DECISIONS. ALONG WITH US AS TO
HOW HOW WE PAY FOR THIS AND
WHEN WE PAY FOR IT AND WHAT THE
BUDGET ALLOWS US TO AFFORD IN
ANY GIVEN YEAR SO. I LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THE DETAIL.
OF FROM YOU ALL AS I'M SURE-
JASON DOES AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEN WE'LL WORK
THROUGH AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT'S MY
INTENT TO TRY TO MAKE SOMETHING
HAPPEN AT SOME POINT IN TIME
FOR PEOPLE WHO BADLY NEEDED IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SO THANK YOU.
BRING US THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING. DRIVING FLYING.
WHATEVER IT IS DO IT SAFELY AND
STAY HEALTHY. OKAY NEXT ISSUE
IS ISSUE NUMBER THREE BUDGET
OPERATIONS AND TUITION. YOU.
THANK YOU TERRY ROTH OF I'M
GOING TO BE REFERRING BACK TO
THE ORANGE COVERED HAND OUT
THAT YOU RECEIVED EARLIER. AND
BEFORE I GET INTO THE DETAILS
OF THE UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET
REQUEST I'D LIKE TO WALK YOU
THROUGH A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
WITHIN WHICH YOU'LL BE MAKING
THE DECISIONS ABOUT. ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET SO I WOULD
DIRECT YOU TO SLIDE FOUR. OF
WHICH DEMONSTRATES THE
UNIVERSITY'S OVERALL BUDGET
SITUATION ON THE LEFT THERE YOU
SEE THE PIE CHART OF THE
DOUGHNUT CHART. THAT SHOWS ALL
OF THE UNIVERSITY SOURCES OF
FUNDS AND WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
IS CONSIDERING OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR THE UNIVERSITY ARE
THE CAMPUS OPERATING FUNDS THAT
WE USUALLY DISCUSS YOUR LOOKING
AT THAT BLUE SLICE THERE WHICH-
IS ALSO SHOWN IN A- BLOWN UP
WAY ON THE RIGHT HAND SLIDE.
RIGHT HAND SIDE OF THE SLIDE
THAT IS OUR CORE OPERATING
FUNDS THAT'S WHAT PAYS FOR OUR
CAMPUS OPERATIONS INSTRUCTION
STUDENT SERVICES- AND ALL OF
THOSE. THINGS THAT IT TAKES TO
RUN AN ACTUAL CAMPUS. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
FOR TO CAMP SAYS STATE GENERAL
FUNDS ARE ABOUT 42% OF THE
CAMPUS OPERATIONS AT TOP. OF
THE MEANS THAT STUDENT FEES
HAVE TO STEP UP. AND COVER A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT OF THE
CAMPUS OPERATIONS. OF IT ALSO
MEANS THAT ANY INCREASE THE
STATE GENERAL FUNDS UNLESS IT'S
SIGNIFICANT IS NOT ENOUGH TO
COVER INFLATIONARY COSTS FOR
ALL CAMPUS OPERATIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE ONLY AN INCREASE ON OF
ONE COMPONENT OF OUR FUNDING.
THEN ON SLIDE FIVE I HAVE A
QUICK SNAPSHOT OF THE REGION'S
BUDGET REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE
AND FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
ARE REQUESTING FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION IN NEW ON
GOING FUNDING. AT AND I'LL GET
INTO THE DETAILS OF THAT SOON.
BUT THESE BONDS WOULD ALLOW US
TO INVEST IN INSTRUCTION OF
COVER ARE MANDATORY BASED COST
INCREASES OF. INVEST IN NEW
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES AND
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS GRADUATE STUDENTS A
MEDICAL STUDENTS. THEN ON SLIDE
SIX OF I SUMMARIZE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR PROVIDED THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. CAN I
STOP YOU FOR A SECOND JUST GO
BACK SO THAT WAS AN INTERESTING
COMMENT YOU MADE SO WHEN WE-
WHEN WE PROVIDE A- WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT A COAL- OR AN
INCREASE. IN AND WE DO IT ON
THE GENERAL FUND SIDE AND I'M
LOOKING AT. PAGE FOUR YES. SO
IF YOUR COST OF OPERATION GOES
UP AND WE SAY OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO INCREASE YOU BY 3% THAT'S
OUR PIECE OF THE FUNDING. IN
ORDER TO KEEP YOU HOLE IF IN
FACT YOU COST OF OPERATION GOES
UP THEN. YOU WOULD NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MEDICAL CENTER
REVENUE INCREASES THE IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THE MEDICAL
CENTER REVENUE IN INCREASES BY
3% THE- STUDENT FEES INCREASED
BY 3% THE- FORT FOR THE CENTRAL
CAMPUS OPERATIONS WE WOULD NEED
TO STUDENT TUITION. THE NON
RESIDENT TUITION AND THEN A FEW
OTHER SMALLER- FUNDING SOURCES
TO ALSO INCREASE SO THE CENTRAL
CAMPUS ARE PAID FOR WITH STATE
GENERAL FUNDS. TUITION STUDENT
SERVICES BE NON RESIDENT
TUITION WHICH NOW IS 15% OF
CAMPUS OPERATIONS. AND THEN IN
THAT LITTLE YELLOW SLICE THERE
THAT SAYS 4% THAT'S- THINGS
LIKE PATENTS REVENUE INDIRECT
COST RECOVERY IN A COUPLE OF
OTHER. SMALL REFUSE OR SUGGEST.
REVENUE STATE THE MEDICAL
CAMPUS THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
THAT'S CORRECT OF THE MEDICAL
HER REP DUE SOMETIME SUBSIDIZED
MEDICAL EDUCATION BUT WE THE
CALL EDUCATION COMPONENT. OF
CAPS OPERATION. OKAY I DIDN'T
MEAN. I'M TAKING EVERY UP THE
TRACKS TO THE BUT I ALWAYS TRY
I LOVE OUR- I LOOK AFFECTED.
LOOKING AT THE SLIDES AND
REALLY. REALLY WANTING TO KNOW
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE ALL
ABOUT- SO LIKE I SAID SLIDE
SIX. SUMMARIZES THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY TEN BUDGET WE'RE VERY
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR.
FOR PROVIDING US WITH A 5%
INCREASE TO- OF THE ON GOING
CAMPUS STATE GENERAL FUND. OF
BUT LIKE I JUST TALKED ABOUT
SINCE THAT'S 42% OF THE
OPERATIONS FOR THE CAMPUSES
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO COVER THE
INFLATIONARY COST INCREASE FOR.
THE ENTIRE CAMPUS OPERATIONS SO
IF YOU TAKE THAT OF 5% OF THE
GOVERNOR GAVE US AND YOU
STRETCH ACROSS ALL OF THE
CAMPUS OPERATIONS. IT ACTUALLY
BECOMES ABOUT A 2% INCREASE. SO
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO COVER THE
TWO POINT 8% INFLATION THAT
WE'RE FACING RIGHT NOW SO WHERE
YOU GET THE EXTRA MONEY. WELL
WE'LL GET TO THAT WILL- WE'RE
ASKING YOU FOR IT- AND WE MAY
WE MAY BE TURNING TO OUR
STUDENTS HERE VERY SHORTLY. OF
FOR SHERIFF THAT. AND ON SLIDE
SEVEN I SUMMARIZE THE FUNDING
NEEDS OF THE UNIVERSITY. IN
ADDITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND JUST ON A VERY HIGH
LEVEL WE'RE REQUESTING ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OF THE
LARGEST COMPONENT OF OUR BUDGET
REQUEST IS SUSTAINING THE CORE
OPERATIONS OF THE CAMPUSES IN
ORDER TO RETAIN THE MOST
QUALIFIED FACULTY AND STAFF
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE STUDENT
SERVICES MAINTAIN OUR
FACILITIES AND ENSURE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY FOR RETIREMENT PLAN
IS FUNCTIONING AS INTENDED
THERE'S ADDITIONAL COST OF
RUNNING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT TEN CAMPUS SYSTEM
THE REGION'S HAVE REQUESTED TO
STATE FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION FOR THOSE OF BASIC
INFLATIONARY CRITICAL OPERATION
COST INCREASES. AND WHILE IT
SEEMS LIKE A HUGE AMOUNT OF
THAT EQUATES TO JUST TWO POINT
8% INCREASE ON SOME OF THE CORE
FUNDS. OF COURSE THE GENERAL
FUND OF THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROVIDED US WITH- HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE POINT TWO MILLION
FOR THE SPACE COST INCREASES
THAT'S THE 5% THAT I JUST
REFERRED TO- AND WHAT WE ARE
SHORT STILL ON THOSE BASIC COST
INCREASES NINETY FIVE MILLION.
AS SHOWN AT THE TOP OF THE
SLIDE SEVEN. NOW TO CONTINUE ON
THE DISCUSSION OF. WHAT ARE THE
COST PRESSURES AND WHERE HAVE
WE BEEN AS THE SYSTEM MIGHT ASK
YOU TO TURN TO SLIDE EIGHT. ON
SLIDE EIGHT. I'M JUST I HAVE A
VISUAL HERE ON THE FIRST
STUDENT FOR FUNDS OF THE
UNIVERSITY SO NINETY FIVE POINT
ONE MILLION IS WHAT YOU NEED IN
ORDER TO COVER OUR BASIC COST
INFLATIONARY INCREASES IN
ADDITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND SOURCE LIGHT EIGHT.
YOU CAN- THIS GRAPH HERE
DEMONSTRATES THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
INTO OUR STUDENTS AND THE PER
STUDENT AMOUNT OF FUNDING IS
ACTUALLY INCREASING FROM THE
BOTTOM OF THE RECESSION TO NOW
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
VERY GENEROUS LOOK PROVIDING US
ANNUAL INCREASES SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE UNTIL NOW. UP TO ALLOW
US TO INVEST IN OUR STUDENTS
AND TO INCREASED ENROLLMENT IN
THE UNIVERSITY BUT THERE ARE A
FEW THINGS I'D LIKE YOU TO NOTE
HERE ONE IS THE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE NON RESIDENT
TUITION. IN THE. SO ARE NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS PAY OF. PAY
QUITE A BIT THEY PAY ALMOST
THIRTY THOUSAND AND NON
RESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION
TO US OF THAT AMOUNT WE ONLY
NEED ABOUT OF ELEVEN THOUSAND
TO ACTUALLY EDUCATE THEM THE
REST GOES INTO THE CAMPUS
OPERATING BUDGETS TO HELP
SUPPORT AND SUSTAIN THE
INSTRUCTION AND OPERATIONS OF
THE CAMPUSES ALL OUR STUDENTS.
SO IF THOSE FUNDS ARE
RESTRICTED THAT WOULD CREATE
SOME PROBLEMS FOR OUR CAMPUSES
WE'RE NOT PROPOSING THAT RIGHT
OUT YOU'RE NOT PROPOSING THAT
JUST WANTED TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT IT WOULD IT WOULD GREAT UP
SOME ISSUES FOR US. AND
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL NOT CONTINUE
TO NOT PROPOSED THAT. OF BUT
THEN WE DO HAVE SOME ISSUES
EVEN THOUGH THE FUNDING PER
STUDENT HAS CONTINUED TO
INCREASE SLIDE NINE
DEMONSTRATES THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN COST INCREASES AS WELL
THAT THE UNIVERSITY CAN'T
AVOID. THAT ARE EATING INTO
THAT PER STUDENT DOLLAR AMOUNT
THAT WE HAVE OF ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OF THESE IS UC RP THE
UC RETIREMENT PROGRAM. UP FOR
THIS COMING YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
BE HAVING TO DISTRIBUTE OF FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE MILLION FROM
OUR CORE OPERATING FUNDS INTO
OUR RETIREMENT PROGRAM. THAT
REALLY REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY AVAILABLE OF FOR US TO
AND JUST TO PUT SOME CONTEXT ON
AT THE LEGISLATURE UP SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE YOU'VE GROWN OUR
BUDGET BY ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. AND SO IF WE HAVE TO
TAKE A FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
MILLION INPUT INTO YOU SEPARATE
THAT'S ABOUT HALF OF THOSE
FUNDS THAT YOU'VE GIVEN TO US.
GOING TO THIS PURPOSE THE ONLY
RESTORED CUTS THE WEIRD THING.
MADE IS THAT OVER AND ABOVE
WHAT WE CUT OUT OF YOUR BUDGET
AND- SO TWO THOUSAND AND
200-020-0082 TEN YOU CUT OUR
BUDGET BY BILLION DOLLARS AND
SINCE THEN YOU WERE STARTED BY
ONE POINT ONE BILLION SO WE'RE
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION HAD.
WHERE WE WERE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT AND THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE. MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S OF A DOWN PAYMENT ON THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY AND
ASSOCIATED WITH YOUR
RETIREMENT. OF THAT IS NOT A
DOWN PAYMENT ON THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY THAT'S JUST ON THE
PAYROLL OF OUR CURRENT
EMPLOYEES WORK WE HAVE TO PUT
IN FOR THEM. SO AND- STRICTLY
THE CONTRIBUTION SIDE AND THOSE
ARE THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE
RESTARTED IN TWENTY TEN. SO
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
GIVING US MONEY WE'VE BEEN
HAVING TO RESTART THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS SO SIGNIFICANT
CHUNK OF. THE NEW MONEY THAT
YOU'RE GIVING TO US IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO THE RETIREMENT
PROGRAM. AND THE WAY WE
SUPPLEMENT OUR BUDGET HAS BEEN
WITH THOSE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS THAT'S HOW WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GROW. AS HE IS GUYS
SEEM TO HAVE AN UNFUNDED
LIABILITY- YES HAVING GROWN NOW
WITH OUR LATEST ACTUARIAL ARE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY HAS GROWN TO
EIGHTEEN BILLION. IS THAT
ACCOUNTED FOR SOMEWHERE IN. NO
NO IT'S NOT ACCOUNTED FOR HERE
JUST JUST TO CLARIFY THAT-
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION THAT
THEY'RE MAKING A PORTION OF
THAT IS COVERING EARNED
BENEFITS EACH YEAR. AND THEN
ANOTHER PORTION IS COVERING- OF
A PORTION OF THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY OVER MANY YEARS JUST
LIKE- CALPERS AND CAL STIRS YOU
SEE- HAS A PLAN TO PAY DWN THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OVER MANY
YEARS AND THEY'RE- GOING TO
ANSWER THEIR THEIR THEIR RATES
INCLUDE THAT. ELEMENT ON THEIR
THEIR PLAN DOESN'T PROVIDE
ENOUGH FUNDING WE BETWEEN
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTIONS SO THEY'VE BEEN
MAKING THE DIFFERENCE BY. OUR
THROUGH INTERNAL BORROWING AND
THEN THEY PAY OFF THAT INTERNAL
BORROWING. OFF FROM THEIR FROM
THEIR BUDGET TO. GET USER GET
WELL DATE I MEAN WHATEVER GET
WELL MEANS AND IN OUR PENSION
SYSTEM BUT- IS THERE A GET WELL
DATE UNDER THE PLAN. I'VE
THEY'VE SHARED IF THE DATE IS A
KIND OF A MOVING TARGET I DON'T
REMEMBER THE MOST RECENT FAST
BUT IT'S BEEN OVER A FEW FEW
DECADES. WE HAVE TO FOLLOW UP
TO GET. THE RATE. OKAY WHY BE
INTERESTED IN AND AS WE
CONTINUE OUR BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS AND WE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME CHATTING ABOUT
PENSIONS NOT SO MUCH HERE IN
THE HIGHER EDUCATION ARENA-
WITH YOU SEE BUT I'D BE
INTERESTED AT SOME POINT IN
HAVING THAT INCLUDED AS PART OF
OUR CONVERSATION JUST HAVE AN
IDEA WHAT YOU'RE UNFUNDED. WE
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY IS BUT WHAT'S THE GET
WELL PLAN I CAN BECAUSE I
ASSUME THAT'S COMING OUT OF
SOMETHING. OF IT IS COMING OUT
OF OUR- OVERALL BUDGET UP IN
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND- I CAN
ALSO. BRING SOMEBODY BY TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THAT RIGHT IT'S
BEYOND THE CONVERSATION TODAY
IT JUST. SORT OF RELATED TO THE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE MILLION
HECK YEAH SO AT SOME POINT WE
CAN HAVE A FURTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT. EXACTLY EXACTLY PLEASE
PROCEED OF AND OTHER- COST
PRESSURES OF WE ALSO HAVE IS
OUR DEATH SERVICE. OF BOTH ON
THE GEO BOND SUPPORT
TRANSFERRED INTO OUR BUDGETS.
AND ALSO FOR THE AB NINETY FOUR
PROCESS THAT WE'RE USING TO
CONSTRUCT OUR BUILDINGS. THAT
DOES SET ASIDE EVERY YEAR JUST
A LITTLE BIT MORE OUT OF OUR
OPERATING FUNDS THAT CAN THEN
BE USED FOR HIRING OF
INSTRUCTORS ARE STUDENT
SERVICES- SO. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDED THE UNIVERSITY
WITH. A SERIES OF DIRECTIVES OF
REGARDING CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
TRANSFER AND ROMAN AND LIMITING
NON RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT AND THE UNIVERSITY
HAS MET OR EXCEEDED EXCEEDED
ALL THOSE EXPECTATIONS FOR NEW
ENROLLMENT AND STUDENT SERVICES
WITH MINIMAL INCREASES IN
SYSTEM WIDE TUITION AND FEES
OVER THE PAST EIGHT YEARS AND
DOING SO HOWEVER HAS PUT
PRESSURE ON THE UNIVERSITY'S
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION FOR ITS
GROWING STUDENT BODY AND WE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO RESTRICT
TUITION LVELS WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT STATE INVESTMENT.
THE REGION'S HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING AND ARE CONSIDERING
A VOTE ON MARCH NINETEENTH. ON
A NEW TUITION STABILIZATION
PLAN ONE OPTION BEING
CONSIDERED UNDER THIS PLAN IS A
COHORT BASED TUITION MODEL THIS
MODEL WOULD INCREASE FEES FOR
INCOMING STUDENTS ONLY. AND
MAINTAIN THOSE FEES STUDY FOR
SIX YEARS NO CURRENT STUDENTS
WOULD SEE A SYSTEM WIDE BE
INCREASE UNDER THE COHORT BASED
TUITION MODEL. THIS MODEL WILL
PROVIDE PREDICTABILITY TO UC
SYSTEM WIDE STUDENT CHARGES AND
ALLOW FAMILIES TO PLAN FOR THE
COST OF EDUCATION. ON SLIDE TEN
I DEMONSTRATE HOW WHEN THE
UNIVERSITY HAS COST INCREASES
ACROSS ALL FUNDING SOURCES. IT
DOES FUNDING SOURCES DON'T
INCREASE ONE FUNDING OURCE
MUST INCREASE BY MORE IF ALL
THE OTHERS THEN IF ALL THE
SOURCES HAD A SMALL INCREASE.
SO YOU'LL SEE HERE ON IN THIS
CHART. THERE ARE VARIOUS COR
FUNDS AND IF ALL OF THEM HAD A
SMALL INCREASE THE STATE
GENERAL FUND INCREASE WOULD BE
LESS THAN IF ONLY THE STATE
GENERAL FUND COMPONENT WAS
BEING ASKED TO COVER ALL OF
THE- INCREASE. FOR UP FOR THE
COST INCREASES SO WHAT'S THE
DOLLARS SO TO DO SO IF WE'VE
WAITED ALL IT WOULD BE 12%
INCREASE. OF INCREASED THE
STATE FUNDS ONLY IS THAT WHAT
THAT MEANS YES WELL IF SENT YES
IF THE IF ONLY'S THE STATE
FUNDS WERE COVERING ALL OF THE%
ALL OF THE NEEDS OF THE
UNIVERSITY AND WHAT'S THAT DO
WE KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER IS WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION PRICE
COMING IS THAT WHY YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THAT. I MEAN I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE TWELVE PLUS
12% I MEAN IN TERMS OF DOLLARS
THAT IS NOT YOUR TOTAL ASK OR
IS THAT I THINK THAT'S JUST AN
ILLUSTRATIVE GRAPH THAT'S BEING
THAT'S SHOWS THE DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN THOSE THOSE PERCENTAGES
IF ONE SOURCE HAVE TO COVER ALL
OF IT VERSUS JUST LOW COMPONENT
GIVEN THAT NOT ALL OF THE MARS
EQUALLY SIZED 5% INCREASE TO OF
NONRESIDENTS OPTIMAL TUITION IS
LESS THAN A 5% INCREASE TO. OF
TO STATE FUNDS OR TUITION BUT
IN TERMS OF DOLLARS BUT WE YOU
KNOW I'M NOT A MATH PERSON
YOU'VE HAD TWO YEARS OF ME SO
I'M SURE YOU FIGURE THAT OUT
BUT IF NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IS THE DELTA TO
MAINTAIN EQUILIBRIUM BETWEEN
YOU BETWEEN WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED AND WHAT YOU NEED IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN. A FLAT LINE.
IS NINETY FIVE MILLION WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO AVOID A TUITION
INCREASE. OR IS THERE SOMETHING
MORE THAN THAT IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION WHAT WE ALSO WANT TO
GROW OUR SERVICES SO WE HAVE A
WE HAVE A SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO HIRE NEW FACULTY.
AND TO- BRIDGE GRADUATION GAPS
SO WE AS A SYSTEM WANT TO NOT
JUST MEET OUR BASIC COST
INCREASES WE ALSO WANT TO. OF
PROVIDE ENHANCED SERVICES TO
OUR EXISTING STUDENTS. AND FOR
WHAT OUR OPTIONS ARE. INCREASE
DISCUSSION AROUND HERE IS NOT
QUITE THE THIRD RAIL BUT IT
GETS THERE AND I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT IF MY COLLEAGUES
DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL WITH A
TUITION INCREASE WHAT'S WHAT'S
THE OPTION THAT I SAY TO THEM
YOU DON'T LIKE A TUITION
INCREASE THEN WE NEED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
FUND YOU SEE HERE WE NEED
NINETY FIVE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP FUND YOU SEE TO
AVOID A TUITION INCREASE AND
THEN LET'S TALK ABOUT ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS THAT YOU SEE WANTS
TO DO WE WANT TO ADD FACULTY.
YOUR WE WANTED INCREASING
ENROLLMENT BY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS YOU WANT TO DO
THIS YOU WANT TO DO THAT EACH
OF THOSE LITTLE BUCKETS HAS A
PRICE TAG RIGHT AND YES LIKE
GOING TO MAKE DONALD I CAN GET
THE PICKLES THERE I CAN GET THE
DOUBLE BURGER OR THE TRIPLE
BOND OR WHATEVER AND BEACH BUST
I THINK I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
QUITE SO IT WOULD THE NINETY
FIVE MIL. DEL PLUS ABOUT THE
MAIL. FOR TO IT. OF THE TO A
AND- WE WOULD GET FOR YEAR. TO
ADD MORE STUDENTS. SIXTY
MILLION THAT THAT WOULD TAKE
CARE OF DOUBLE K. TAKE CARE THE
COST IF WE ARE PLANNING ON
COVER HOPING TO COVER THAT WE
NEED TO COVER- IF YOU'RE
REQUESTING WE- I WAS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND MY OPTIONS. THEY'RE
NOT MY OPTIONS BY THE WAY I.
CHECKED WITH NUMBERS OUT OF
THEIR DAY OUR EXPECTATION WOULD
BE TO GET THAT SIXTY MILLION
FROM ACCORD TUITION INCREASE-
IN THAT FIRST YEAR. SO WHAT YOU
DO AT THAT NUMBER. YOU KNOW AND
WE NEED THE NINETY FIVE MILLION
ON TOP OF THAT. SEWER OKAY OF.
UP FULL OF MY MATH BOOK AND TRY
TO GO TO WORK ON THAT. YEAH I
DIDN'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
LOOKING AT WHAT BUT WE ARE
WE'RE REQUESTING THE FULL TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
WILL CONTINUE TO REQUEST THAT
AND IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
BY NINE UNDERSTAND YEAH. SO ON
SLIDE ELEVEN- I DISCUSS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CORE HURT
BASED TUITION MODEL AT NEW
STUDENTS NEW STUDENTS WOULD SEE
AN INCREASE OF THEIR FEES IN
THE FIRST YEAR. AND THEN THOSE
FROM PEACE WOULD REMAIN FLAT
FOR UP TO SIX YEARS- BUT FOR
THE POOREST STUDENTS ARE COVERT
BASED TUITION MODEL. OFFERS AN
INCREASE IN FINANCIAL AID.
BECAUSE YOU SEE PUTS ASIDE ONE
THIRD OF OUR TUITION REVENUES
FINANCIAL AID FOR NEEDIEST
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS- AND CAL
GRANTS WHICH COVERED THE
TUITION INCREASE COMPONENT SO
THEY WOULD GET THE CAL GRANT
PLUS SOME INSTITUTIONAL
FINANCIAL AID. SO THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BE SLIGHTLY BTTER OFF
THAN. IF THERE WAS NO TUITION
INCREASE AT ALL. AND CURRENTLY
OFF 57% OF OUR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES. DO NOT
PAY ANY TUITION UP BECAUSE IT'S
COVERED FOR THEM TO OUR
FINANCIAL AID MECHANISM AND
THEN TO SHIFT GEARS- FOR A
LITTLE MOMENT. THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY AND
STUDENTS CONDUCT WORLD CLASS
RESEARCH WE HAVE A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
PROPOSAL. OF TO HELP CONNECT
YOU SEE RESEARCH INNOVATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WE
DO THINK THAT THIS IS.
IMPORTANT WE HAVE FIVE
INNOVATIONS EVERY SINGLE DAY AS
A SYSTEM AND IF WE CAN HELP GET
THOSE INTO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY WE CAN CREATE SOME REAL
GROSS AND REALLY- CONNECT OUR-
OF FACULTY YET AND OUR STUDENTS
WITH THE ECONOMY. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE RECEIVED TWENTY TWO
MILLION. THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
UTILIZE TO SUPPORT FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX STARTUP COMPANIES
WHICH COMBINED ATTRACTED TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS AND PRIVATE
INVESTOR. UP FUNDS INTO
CALIFORNIA INTO THE START UPS
AND WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE THIS
TRAJECTORY BY REQUESTING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT YEAR TO CONTINUE THIS
PROGRAM WHICH HAS SHOWN A
TREMENDOUS RESULTS. AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION ON
OUR OPERATING BUDGET I'D LIKE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE SIR. I DON'T KNOW THAT I
HAVE ANY BUT I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU ALLOWED ME TO
INTERRUPT YOU ALL OVER THE
PLACE TO ASK HIM DURING YOUR
TASTE. AND IT'S A COMMON LA WHO
WANTS TO GO FOR. SO WE'LL JUST
DO A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THE
BIGGEST INVESTMENT WERE
PROPOSING FOR THE UC IS THE 5%
BASING CREASE WHICH WOULD TAKE
THEIR MAIN GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION. AND INCREASE IT
BY A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
POINT TWO MILLION ON GOING.
THAT WOULD COME WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT THE UC WOULD
CONTINUE WORKING TO IMPROVE
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY TO
IMPROVE ACCESS. TO ADDRESS
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND TO
DECREASE TIME 2 DEGREES WELL
KNOWN ON ON THE TUITION PIECE
THAT AT THIS TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T BELIEVE
A TUITION INCREASE WOULD BE
WARRANTED GIVEN THE SUBSTANTIAL
PROPOSAL AND GOVERNOR'S BUGET
OF HUNDREDS SIXTY NINE AND A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE. ON GOING. AT TWO
SEVENTEEN ONGOING. AT AND LAST
YEAR WE THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET THE STATE INVESTED MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND. THOSE ARE BOTH
HISTORICALLY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS- PERMANENT FUNDING
IN THE UC SYSTEM. AND SO-
RAISING TUITION BE- IN
ADVISABLE IN BED FOR STUDENTS
AT THIS TIME. AND I UNDERSTAND
BOTH THE POLITICS AND I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
FINANCE PIECE OF ALL THIS. DOES
IS PROBABLY SOME SCIENCE TO
THIS SIZE SOON AS OPPOSED TO
JUST ARE IN TERMS OF. AN
INCREASE IN COSTS. NO CARS COST
MORE TODAY PIANOS COST MORE
TODAY. LIFE COSTS MORE TODAY
AND THERE'S AN INCREASE IN COST
AND NOT BEING A MATH PERSON.
THAT TRANSLATES INTO SOMETHING
AT THE BOTTOM LINE AND- CAN YOU
RESPOND TO THE TO THE DELTA
ISSUE THE NINETY FIVE WHATEVER
IT WAS NINETY FIVE POINT ONE OR
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS MILLION
DOLLAR DELTA BETWEEN. WHERE
THEY ARE AND WHERE YOU SEE
CLAIMS TO NEED TO BE IN ORDER
TO MAINTAIN SORT OF A FLAT LINE
APPROACH TO WHAT TO THE
DELIVERY OF THE SERVICES THAT
YOU SEE PROVIDES. AND THEN MY
PERHAPS IN ARTFUL QUESTIONS
HAVING TO DO WITH THE TUITION
INCREASE AND WHAT WOULD WE HAVE
TO DO IN ORDER TO AVOID A
TUITION INCREASE IF IN FACT THE
INCREASES RESPONDING TO
INCREASE COSTS DOES ANY THAT
MAKES SENSE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SAY NO BUT THAT THAT
MAY IT'S A 100% SENSE. I THINK
IT. HI WHERE WE GET OUR
PERSPECTIVE FROM SO FOR.
THERE'S A COUPLE WAYS THAT WHEN
WE CHARACTERIZE WHAT THE UC'S
NEEDS ARE WE'RE NOT THINKING US
THIS EARLY IN THE SAME TERMS
THE UC ARE SO. FOR ONE- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ON PAGE FOR THE
UC'S CORE FUNDS- THE STATE
GENERAL FUND PORTION IS LISTED
AS 42% AND THEN THERE'S THE
ORANGE THAT INDICATES TUITION.
BUT THE STATE FUNDS A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THAT-
STUDENT TUITION PEACE THROUGH
CAL GRANT AND SO THE STATE'S.
CONTRIBUTION HERE TO OVERALL
CORE FUNDING IS MORE THAN FIFTY
PERCENT. AND SO. OUR STARTING
POINT FOR THINKING ABOUT THE
UC'S BUDGET IS TYPICALLY A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. WE ALSO
KNOW THIRD THERE'S NOT ALWAYS
IN AGREEMENT ON WHAT THE
MANDATORY COSTS ARE- AND THAT
IN THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET. THE
UC IS REQUESTING FORTY MILLION
FOR INCREASED YOU SEE OUR P.
PENSION PAYMENTS. BUT TWENTY
MILLION OF THAT REFLECTS A
RECENT DECISION MADE BY THE
REGENTS TO- GO FOR MORE
CONSERVATIVE ACTUARIAL.
CALCULATIONS IN TERMS OF RETURN
ON INVESTMENT. AND SO THE
CONSERVATIVE NUMBER THAT THEY
CHOSE AS AS- IS UNDER WHERE CAL
STIRS IN CALPERS ARE AT IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY EXPECT TO
RETURN TO BE WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER YEAH MARKET OF
THE LESS YEAH COUPLE WEEKS. IT
AND SO IT BUT IN THE LONG TERM
THEY HAVE SET THEMSELVES UP TO.
CREATE MORE NEED TO DUMP MONEY
INTO COVER THAT OUTSTANDING
PENSION LIABILITY AND SO IN
TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT THAT AS
A MANDATORY COST IT'S DEBATABLE
AND OUR PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE
THAT MAYBE TWENTY MILLION AS
MORE LEGITIMATE THAN THETWENTY
THAT REFLECTS A RECENT.
DECISION THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY ALIGN WITH WHERE
THE STATE'S OTHER LARGE.
PENSION COMMITMENTS ARE. AND
I'VE I PLEDGE TO SIT DOWN WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE MUCH MORE THAN I
AM INSIDE TO FIGURE OUT MY MATH
BECAUSE I CAN'T DO IT IN PUBLIC
BUT IT DOES SEEM TO ME THAT THE
THAT THE DELTA WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS ABOUT NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO
COURT COVER SOME OTHER PROGRAMS
I REALIZE YOU WANT SIXTY MORE
BUT IT'S GOING TO COVER SOME
OTHER PROGRAMS THE THREE THAT
WERE LISTED SOMEWHERE IN HERE
THAT I JUST. SPOTTED IN WILL
HAVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT. WHETHER NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- OBVIATES THE
NEED FOR OF. STUDENT TUITION
INCREASE OTHER THAN THE FACT
THAT YOU SEE HAS SOME.
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT THEY
WANT TO PUT FORWARD BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ALL TO.
IF YOU CAN. IF YOU CAN IMPROVE
THE BRAIN WAVES OF US
SEPTUAGENARIAN I'M GOING TO
CHALLENGE YOU ON THAT POINT LA.
SO YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES I DON'T
WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT TOO
MUCH ON WHAT MY BRAIN. BUT YOU
KNOW THIS THIS ITEM REALLY HAS
TO KEY. ISSUES THAT ARE
PERENNIAL THE LEGISLATURE FACES
AND EVERY YEAR THEY ARE ONE OF
THE COST INCREASES YOU LIKE TO
SUPPORT YOU SEE AND- HOW TO
THOSE COVERED BE COVERED
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATIONS IN TUITION
INCREASES. ON THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSING UP A SORT OF BASING
CREASE THAT- IS UNRESTRICTED-
IT IS GIVING YOU SEE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE WHAT COST
INCREASE IS TO SUPPORT WITHIN
THAT AUGMENTATION. AND IT IS
ENTIRELY COVERING THAT FROM THE
GENERAL FUND- AND- TUITION
INCREASE SO THINKING ABOUT
THESE TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES YOU
DON'T THINK IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT WHAT COST
INCREASES TO SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S FOR ALL APPROACH
FIGHTING AN UNRESTRICTED BASED
INCREASE. ON BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T- ISN'T CONNECTED TO-
AYE CALCULATIONS OF COST
INCREASES IT DOESN'T IDENTIFY
WHICH PRIORITIES IT'S
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING IT GIVES A
LEGISLATURE. AWESOME DIFFICULTY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT EXACTLY IT'S
BEING OUT TO SUPPORT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- BUT AS YOU. CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO TRACK AGAINST THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON WHAT YOU
SEE IS- PROPOSING SO WE
RECOMMEND TYING INCREASES MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO PRIORITIES THAT
YOU HAVE A- BUDGET. WE ALSO
NOTE AT THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET TOOK THIS EXPECT
ACTUALLY APPROACH THAT WE'RE-
PUTTING IT HI. EVERY OUR
PATIENTS SEVEN PRIORITIES
PROVIDED CLEAR SAID WASN'T THE
STATE'S EXPECTATIONS WERE
REGARDING ITS AUGMENTATIONS. SO
NOW THAT'S- EASY THING IS A
MORE COUPLE QUESTION AS WELL.
OKAY WE SHOULD IDENTIFY
PRIORITIES BUT WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES BEING MUCH OF THAT
AMOUNT BE THAT'S WHAT YOURS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT RIGHT NOW.
THERE WE THINK THERE ARE TWO
WAYS TO THINK ABOUT IT THERE TO
KIND OF CATEGORIES OF INCREASES
THERE ARE. WHAT YOU MIGHT CALL
BASIC OPERATIONAL INCREASES TO
MAINTAIN EXISTING SERVICES AND
TO BE. TOLERANT CREASES BENEFIT
INCREASES OPERATING EXPENSES
AND THEN YOU HAVE A SEPARATE
CATEGORY OF INCREASES THAT
WOULD BE MORE PROGRAMMATIC IN
NATURE. THINGS LIKE EXPANDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OR OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT YOU UNIVERSITY
ABOUT A FIGHT IN ITS-
PRESENTATION. AND WE THINK YOU
YOU WANT TO WEIGH BOTH OF THOSE
AND YOU MAYBE WANNA START WITH
OPERATIONAL COST INCREASES.
THINK ABOUT WHICH OF THOSE COST
YOU LIKE TO SUPPORT WHAT LEVEL
AND THEN MOVE ON TO
PROGRAMMATIC. IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT THIS SORT OF
MANDATORY FOR THE UNIVERSITY.
MORE COMPLICATED QUESTION THE
UNIVERSITY HAS A LOTS OF FLEX.
TO MANAGE COSTS ACROSS ITS
BUDGET AND MANAGE IS IT SIMPLY
BENEFIT PROGRAMS IT DETERMINES
WHAT SALARIES OF LIKE TO
PROVIDE. IT ISN'T ALWAYS THE
MOST USEFUL OFF. ABOUT IT CAN
BE MORE FOR JUST THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE COST INCREASES OF
THESE PROGRAMS ABSENT A POLICY
CHANGE. AND WHAT IS RIGHT AND
WHAT. PURCELL BRING IS. WE JUST
OF THE RIVERS ARE BASIC
OPERATIONAL COST INCREASE SO WE
ASSUME 3% SALARY INCREASES WE
ASSUMED. COST INCREASES TO
BENEFITS AND WE ASSUMED
OPERATING EXPENSES IT INCREASES
WE ALSO NOTED OUT SOME SAVINGS
THE UNIVERSITY ANTICIPATES IT
WILL ON HER. OFF FROM THINGS
LIKE I'M GETTING HIGHER
INVESTMENT INVESTMENT RETURNS
FOR EXAMPLE. IMPROVE BURKE
PROCUREMENT PRACTICES. AND WHAT
WE ESTIMATED THAT BUDGET WHICH
IS A LARGE TREE OF LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO WITH THAT
THEIR MANY OPTIONS FOR IT BUT
THAT. THAT UNLESS YOU HAVE
BUDGET COST ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
IS. A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS. PROPOSING
IN HIS BUDGET. SO THAT'S JUST
OR THE FIRST SET OF ISSUES TO
CONSIDER THE SECOND SET OF
ISSUES IS NOW OKAY WE'VE
DECIDED THE COST INCREASES.
SHOULD BE THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND OR TUITION INCREASE. AND
YOU'VE ACTUALLY HEARD A LOT OF
THE FACTORS THAT YOU'D WANT TO
WAY THERE. I'M WE THINK THEY'RE
BASICALLY ARE THREE KEY
FACTORS. THE FIRST WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION ALLUDED TO WAS
THINKING ABOUT THE SHARE OF
COSTS BETWEEN THE STATE AND
STUDENTS- ABOUT HALF OF STILL
HALF OF UNDERGRADUATE RESIDENT
STUDENTS CURRENTLY- DON'T PAY
TUITION THEY HAVE THAT COVERED
THROUGH FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS.
THE OTHER HALF FOR OUR MOST
MOST OFTEN IS THE CASE THEIR
FULL PAY STUDENTS SOME OF THEM
GET UP. SOME AID THROUGH THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP BUT BY
AND LARGE THERE- GENERALLY FULL
PAY STUDENTS THEY'RE THEY'RE
PAYING ABOUT HALF OF THEIR
COSTS AND SO THE QUESTION
BEFOREYOU IS. DISPATCHER SEEM
REASONABLE AS A TO HIRE IS IT
TOO LOW. THE SECOND FACTOR YOU
COULD CONSIDER IS
AFFORDABILITY. THIS SEEMS TO
BE- ARE CONCERNED- THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM BOTH THE UNIVERSITY
AND THE ADMINISTRATION- AS
UNIVERSITY AND- ALLUDED TO-
IT'S A BIT OF A COMPLICATED
DISCUSSION BECAUSE WHEN YOU
INCREASE TUITION. PROVIDES MORE
AID FOR LIVING COSTS FOR
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS. SO
TUITION INCREASE ACTUALLY HAS
THE COUNTER TO WOULD HAVE
EFFECTIVE IMPROVING
AFFORDABILITY FOR FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS. IT INCREASED
COSTS FOR STUDENTS WHO AREN'T
ON FINANCIALLY RIGHT GETTING
FULL TUITION. A COVERAGE SO.
THERE'S A THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
ON WHO'S PAYING FOR THAT
TUITION INCREASE. AND THEN- WE
ON THE THIRD POINT I'M SORRY
HAD A- MENTAL- SITUATION THERE
SO THAT'S THE THIRD POINT- IS
TO THINK ABOUT. I'M YOU KNOW
YOUR CAPACITY WHAT YOUR PRIOR
IS ARE YOUR YOUR CAPACITOR FROM
THOSE OF THE GENERAL FUND WHEN
YOU ADOPTED TUITION INCREASE
SAID IT PROVIDES FUNDING TO THE
UNIVERSITY AT A POTENTIALLY
LOWER COST TO THE GENERAL FUND.
ALMOND SO THAT FREES UP MORE-
CAPACITY TO FUND ADDITIONAL
PRIORITIES YOU HAVE I JUST
ILLUSTRATE THAT POINT IN THEIR
IN OUR LIST OF THE BUDGET
EXAMPLE A 3% TUITION INCREASE
WOULD REDUCE GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF. A TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
MILLION SO BELOW THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUT PROVIDE EFFECTIVELY
MORE FUNDING TO THE UNIVERSITY
TO COVER A LOT OF ITS OPERATING
COSTS. I'M SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME FACTORS TO CONSIDER. AND
THEN- A FINAL THING TO CONSIDER
THAT SOMEWHERE DIFFERENT THIS
YEAR'S UNIVERSITY IS
CONSIDERING A LONG TERM POLICY-
DID HAVE A GUY TUITION
INCREASES IN THERE THE-
OVERRIDING OBJECTIVE HERE SEEMS
TO BE TO ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE
MORE. PREDICTABILITY FOR THEIR
TUITION INCREASES OTHERS A
FIGURE AN AGENDA THAT SHOWS
THAT IT'S BEEN IT GETS QUITE
FALL TILE AND SOME YEARS IT'S
FLAT NO THREE YEARS THEIR NOBLE
HIKES. SO THEY'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS BY HAVING A
TUITION POLICY AND THEY'RE TWO
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THERE
CONSIDERING. ON WE THINK IT'S
WORTHWHILE TO MAYBE REVIEW
THOSE POLICY SEE IF THEY ALIGN
WITH YOUR EXPECTATIONS. AND IF
THOSE POLICIES ARE ADOPTED TO
WAIT TO FACTOR THOSE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES IN YOUR FINAL BUDGET
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT I'M I'M GRAPPLING
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH THIS AND
I THINK WILL OBVIOUSLY CONTINUE
TO DO THAT AND CERTAINLY I
WILL. YOU KNOW WHERE THERE'S AN
INCREASE IN COST MAKING SURE
THAT THE STATE'S. APPROPRIATION
IN THE BUDGET INCREASES THE-
MEETS THE INCREASE IN COST TO
THE BUT THE BASIC UP UNIVERSITY
OPERATION. AND THEN WHEN
THEY'RE ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS-
EITHER THAT WE WANT TO SEE. PUT
FORWARD OR THAT THE UNIVERSITY
PROPOSES HOW THOSE PROGRAMS
NEED TO BE PAID FOR AND SHOULD
ALL OF THE ADDITIONAL COST OF A
PARTICULAR PROGRAM BE COVERED
OF THE GENERAL FUND BY THE
STATE OR IS THERE SOME
PROPORTIONATE SHARE THAT WE
THINK YOU KNOW US STUDENTS
THROUGH TUITION. SHOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO THE PROGRAMS
STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE- COME
FORWARD AND HAVE A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS THAT THEY WANT TO SEE-
AT THEIR INSTITUTIONS AND YOU
SEE IN GENERAL- AND THEN THE
QUESTION IS WHO PAYS FOR THOSE
DDITIONAL PROGRAMS THIS SHOULD
BE PART OF THE STUDENT TUITION
PACKAGE HOWEVER IT'S CONFIGURED
WHETHER IT'S A COHORT PACKAGER.
AN INFLATION ADJUSTED ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS TUITION PACKAGE
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE
THAT OUT BUT IT WOULD BE YOU
KNOW I'M TRYING TO GET OUT WHAT
THE BASIC COST IS WHAT THE COST
INCREASES GOV AND I UNDERSTAND
YOUR POINT. SIR WHICH IS WE
HAVE SOME DISAGREEMENTS AS TO
WHAT'S INCLUDED IN THAT COST
PACKAGE AND WHAT THOSE NUMBERS
ARE. AND THEN WHO SHOULD BE
PAYING FOR THAT WE'RE GOING TO.
HOPEFULLY COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT THERE AND THEN FIGURE
THIS. THIS OUT ANY ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS MEMBER FOR
I TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE. OF I
THINK I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE-
THE UNIVERSITY HAS MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
PHILANTHROPY COMING IN WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF ADDITIONAL NON
RESIDENTS OF PROMOTE TUITION SO
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW COST.
THAT WE ARE NOW PLANNING FOR IN
THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR BUT NOT
ALL OF THEM ARE COMING FROM THE
STATE SO EVEN THE FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT I DRESSED EARLIER IS NOT
ENTIRELY- IS NOT OUR FULL COST
INCREASES FOR. US NEXT YEAR ARE
WE HAVE WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF THESE MANDATORY COST
INCREASES THAT INCLUDE STAFF
SALARIES THAT INCLUDE. OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED UNFUNDED
UNDERGRADUATES FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF. LOT
OF DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND WE
WANT TO RETAIN FLEXIBILITY IN
THE- THIS BUDGET INCREASE OF WE
RECEIVED TO PROVIDE THE
CHANCELLOR'S WITH THE ABILITY
TO DIRECT THE FUNDS ON THEIR
CAMPUS WHERE THEY NEED IT MOST
OF WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
DIRECTED INVESTMENTS INTO
THINGS LIKE NEW INVOLVEMENT. OF
AND OUR DEGREE COMPLETION
PROGRAM DEFINITELY BUT FOR
THOSE MANDATORY COST INCREASES
WE LIKE TO RETAIN FLEXIBILITY
FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S. RIGHT AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO HAVE A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT OUR
OPTIONS ARE. AND I ASSUME ALL
OF THAT BACKGROUND INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL COST AND
HOW THOSE ARE BEING COVERED.
FINANCES PRIVY TO THAT SO. YES
YES THEY ARE THEY'RE ALL IN THE
REGION'S BUDGET WHICH IS OUR-
AN ACCOUNTING DOCUMENT THAT I
KNOW. YOU DON'T GIVE IT TO ME.
BUT I THINK I. PROBABLY DID
YES. IT'S IN THAT BIG BOOK THAT
YOU RECEIVED THAT HAD THE TWO
HUNDRED PAGE BOOK ON ON OUR-
ZERO OF TRYING TO GO TO SCHOOL
I MAY NEED OF FINANCIAL AID.
YES WE HAVE A GOOD PROGRAM.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY JUST TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT I AM
PARTICULARLY REGARDING THAT THE
DISCUSSION OF MANDATORY COSTS
AND YOU KNOW SOME SOME OF WHICH
ARE PERHAPS OPEN TO SOME
INTERPRETATION OF HOW MANDATORY
IS MANDATORY AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- AS THE ONLY- MENTIONS
LAST YEAR'S APPROACH IN THE
BUDGET TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT APPROACH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF
DELINEATING MORE SPECIFICALLY.
WHAT THE TARGETED- INVESTMENTS
WE'RE GOING TOWARDS A LARGE
COMPONENT OF THAT WAS ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR SUSTAINING CURRENT
OPERATIONS OR YOU KNOW KIND OF
CORE OPERATIONS AND WHAT YOU
SEE OFTEN TERMS MANDATORY COSTS
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT IN THIS
YEAR'S GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
APPROACH. AND ACTUALLY IN IN
THIS YEAR'S. REQUEST FROM THE
UC THE ITEMS THAT THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING IS MANDATORY COST
TO KIND OF SUSTAIN THEIR CORE
OPERATIONS HAVE ADDITIONAL
ELEMENTS THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED
IN THAT LINE ITEM DELINEATION
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ASPECTS IN MY COLLEAGUES SPOKE
TO ABOUT HALF OF THE UC OUR P.
REQUEST FROM. YOU SEE THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
NUANCE APPROACH FROM LAST YEAR
ALSO SOME FACULTY COMPENSATION
SOME KIND OF MARGINAL COST OF
ENROLLMENT DIFFERENCES THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT- WERE. YOUR WERE
NOT NECESSARILY INCLUDED IN.
THE OPERATIONAL FUNDING
PROVIDED TO YOU SEE WHEN IT WAS
DELINEATED. MORE SPECIFICALLY
LAST YEAR- AND THEN JUST TO
ALSO NOTE AS AS THERE'S BEEN
SOME MENTION OF. THE UC DOES
HAVE CONSIDERABLE FLEXIBILITY
AND KIND OF MADE MANAGING ITS
COST. AND AS OUR COLLEAGUE WITH
YOU SEE ALSO MENTIONED THAT
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL REVENUE
SOURCES AVAILABLE TO THE TO THE
UC SO. WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
IN RECENT YEARS. EVEN IN THE-
WITH. SMALLER STATE INVESTMENTS
THAN WERE INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AND
PROPOSED THE TWENTY TWENTY.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET UC HAS BEEN
ABLE TO MAINTAIN TUITION FLAT.
BELIEVE IT'S AND SEVEN OF THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS. AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER THIS
TUITION INCREASES WARRANTED AND
SEE IT AS KIND OF BAD FOR
STUDENTS. TIME AT ALL AND WE
ALSO THEN CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. THE
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PROPOSED AND THEN I JUST ASSUME
AND THEN OF THOSE ARE FUNDED
AND WHETHER THOSE DESERVE. I
GUESS THEY ALL DESERVE PROGRAMS
BUT WHETHER WE CAN FIND SOME OF
THOSE OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND
OR WHETHER SOME OF THOSE. NEED
TO BE SUPPORTED BY THE TUITION
INCREASES. CORRECT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN SOME TARGETED
AREAS IN ADDITION TO THE 5%
GENERAL BASE INCREASE PROVIDED-
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT. WE
WOULD JUST KNOW THAT THIS
YEAR'S APPROACH OF. THAT SENT
FUND IS INCREASE PROVIDES YOU
SEE CONSIDERABLE FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE. SOME
DETERMINATION OF. WHERE THAT
SPENDING IS MOST AREN'T DEAD
RIGHT. QUESTION EXCELLENT
CONVERSATION A LOOK FORWARD TO
THE MORE. NEXT ISSUE ALL RIGHT
MOVING WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
START ON THIS ISSUE FOR RIGHT
ISSUE FOR RESIDENT AND
NONRESIDENT FROM. THAT'S RIGHT-
SO WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ENROLLMENT A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S REQUESTING- THIRTY
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ENROLLMENT OF WHICH
THIRTEEN MILLION WOULD BE FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION IS REQUESTED
TO PRE FUND ENROLLMENT IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SO YEAR.
ONE YEAR OUT OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA STRIVES TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO TOP STUDENTS
THROUGH HOLISTIC REVIEW OF
APPLICATIONS ON A ROBUST
FINANCIAL AID POLICY INTENDED
TO ALLOW QUALIFIED STUDENTS TO
ATTEND REGARDLESS OF INCOME.
OCT CURRENTLY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES SO
WE'RE PROVIDING A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY. SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN YOU SEE HAS INCREASED
UNDERGRADUATES PRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT BY ALL OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS-
THIS GROWTH IN UNDERGRADUATE
RESIDENT STUDENTS HAS BEEN MADE
POSSIBLE WITH STATE SUPPORT. OF
BOTH FOR. EIGHT END OF FULLY
FUNDING NEW ENROLLMENT AT
UNIVERSITY ALLOWS FOR THE
HIRING THE FACULTY AND FOR THE
SUPPORT STUDENTS THAT SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT THE STUDENTS NEED.
AND THEN THERE WERE. BEEN
DIRECTING YOUR ATTENTION TO OF
SLIDE FOURTEEN. WE IN ROLE
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND NEW UNDERGRADUATES
EVERY YEAR OF WHICH NINETEEN
THOUSAND HAVE TRANSFERRED TO
THE UNIVERSITY FROM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. OF THIS YEAR YOU SEE
RECEIVE TRANSFER APPLICATIONS
FORM FROM MORE THAN- THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT'S A FOUR
POINT 6% INCREASE OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND IT CONTINUES ARE YEAR
TO YEAR GROWTH AND TRANSFER
APPLICATIONS. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT SHOWS A TREND
AND HOW MUCH STUDENTS VALUES
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
GROWING TRANSFER ENROLLMENT
THROUGH OUR COMMITMENT TO ADMIT
AT LEAST ONE TRANSFER STUDENT
FOR EVERY TWO FRESHMEN THE WITH
MATH. AND ALSO HERE TO TELL YOU
I WAS IT DID I. READ MY
ANALYSIS PROPERLY THAT FOR FALL
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FRESHMAN
MINUTES. TOTALING THESE
STATISTICS SIXTY NINE POINT 8%
OF THE FRESHMAN IT MEANT SO THE
GPA THREE POINT EIGHT OR OVER.
YES THAT SOUNDS CORRECT SIR-
SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES NOW
BASICALLY IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
FOUR POINT OH IT'S AN BURKE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO GET IN.
TOO MUCH FOR THE MASTER PLAN.
WE WANT MORE STUDENTS AND- IF
WE ARE WE ARE EXPLORING ASSIST
SYSTEM WE ARE EXPLORING
DIFFERENT WAYS TO GROW OUR
ENROLLMENT ONE OF THESE IS TO
INCREASE THROUGHPUT OF STUDENTS
TO GET THEM TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS SO THAT THEY FREE UP THE
SEAT AND THEN WE CAN GET AN
ADDITIONAL STUDENT AND THERE
WERE ALSO DOING PROGRAMS ON
RECRUITMENT THAT ALL ISCUSS IN
A BIT- AND WE ARE LOOKING AT
OUR LONG TERM CAPITAL OUTLAY
PLANS AND HOW WE CAN INCREASE.
PHYSICAL CAPACITY OUR CAMPUSES
AND OUR TEN AREN'T NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES HAVE AT
THIS POINT IDENTIFIED ABOUT TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUTURE
PROJECTS OF WE'D LIKE TO
UNDERTAKE TO CREATE MORE
PHYSICAL- INSTRUCTIONAL
CAPACITY ON OUR CAMPUSES SO WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO WORK WITH
THE STATE TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO
WE ADMIT EVEN MORE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STUDENTS. OF THE
MASTER PLAN OF ONCE THE
UNIVERSITY TO A- ADMIT FROM THE
TOP TWELVE POINT FIVE. THERE
MAY BE A LOT OF ROOM FOR
CONVERSATION OF IS THAT THE
CORRECT NUMBER WE GET SO MANY
QUALIFIED APPLICATIONS. OF THAT
BEHALF. IF IVEN THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR THOSE NEW STUDENTS WE'D
LOVE TO EXPAND. I CERTAINLY
KNOW CRITICISM I JUST I MEAN I
GUESS IT'S OF. NO ON ONCE IN
ONE SENSE IT'S A GOOD PROBLEM
TO HAVE IN THE OTHER SENSE IT'S
A PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE TO
SOLVE. OF WHERE WE ARE FINDING
THAT MORE MORE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOLERS ARE BECOMING A
THROUGH G. PREPARED WHICH IS A
GREAT THING THERE ARE PREPARED
FOR TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION BUT- THAT THAT
DEMAND HAS DEFINITELY STARK
APOSTASY AND IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO INSTRUCT THEM WE
NEED- WE NEED A LOT OF MONEY TO
HIRE INSTRUCTORS. SO MOVING ON
TO SLIDE FIFTEEN AND THIS
ACTUALLY TOUCHES ON SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS IF YOU SEE MAKES
ENROLLMENT DECISIONS IN EARLY
MARCH SO WE'VE NOW SENT OUT
LETTERS. TO HIGH SCHOOLERS
SAYING THAT THEY WILL BE
ADMITTED TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
WHAT THIS IS WELL BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE MAKES A DECISION ON
HE ENROLLMENT LEVEL THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE US TO HAVE. FOR THE
NEXT YEAR SO WE'RE WE'RE AHEAD
OF THESE DECISIONS AND THAT
MAKES IT REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
THE CAMPUSES TO ENROLL THE
NUMBER STUDENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS US TO
SUPPORT. AND SLIDE. ABOUT
FIFTEEN SHOWS THE NUMBER OF
UNFUNDED STUDENTS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
AS AND ROLLED SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHICH WE ARE VERY HAPPY
THAT WE HAD THIS BIG SURGING
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT- BUT
OVER FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED OF THOSE STUDENTS. BOB
HAD NO MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION COMING FROM THE
STATE SO THAT PLACES OF A HUGE
BURDEN ON THE CAMPUSES BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO HIRE
THE INSTRUCTORS FOR THEM SO
THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO HAVE
OTHER MANAGEMENT TOOLS. AND
ALSO WE'RE SEEING SOME EARLY
INDICATORS THAT OCT QUALITY
STUDENTS ARE LESS HAPPY WITH
THE QUALITY WE'RE SEEING MORE
STUDENTS RESPONDING THAT THEY
IF THEY KNEW WHAT THEY KNEW NO
NOW THEY MIGHT NOT A ROLL OF
THE UC. AND WE'VE HAD 13% OF
OUR STUDENTS A REPORT THAT THEY
WERE UNABLE TO GET INTO THE
MAJOR OF THEIR FIRST CHOICE
THAT'S A LARGE NUMBER AND
THAT'S UP FROM ABOUT 3% BACK IN
A TWO THOUSAND THREE. YEAH THIS
THIS UNFUNDED. ENROLLMENT
GROWTH IS THAT THAT'S A
FUNCTION I GATHER OF OUR BUDGET
PROCESS OF WE BELIEVE SO WE-
RECEIVE SIGNALS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FOR TWO OF THOSE
YEARS WE WERE TOLD THAT WE HAD
TO- IN ROLE AT LEAST. FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND AT LEAST
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS. AND BECAUSE OR WE
WOULD NOT RECEIVE ANY MONEY FOR
ANY OF THOSE STUDENTS. AND
BECAUSE WE WERE UNDER THAT
PRESSURE WE WENT AND WE OF MADE
MORE OFFERS. THEN REALLY WE
GAPS NEEDED TO US AND WE- OVER
AND ROLLED. OF AND THEN. OF WE
WERE FACING SOME SOME PRESSURE
ON THE AMOUNT OF STUDENTS WHO
WANT TO COME INTO THE SYSTEM
AND THE WAY THOSE OFFERS ARE
BEING MADE DOESN'T DOESN'T
MATCH THE US STATE PROCESS I
THINK THE STATE PROCESS IS
PROBABLY. A SIGNIFICANT
COMPONENT OF IT MAYBE 80% YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU GIVE US AN
INDICATOR THAT YOU WANT US TO
AND ROLL NEW STUDENTS OR THE
REGION'S TELL US TO GO FORTH
AND ENROLL STUDENTS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO GROW CAPACITY THE
CAMPUS IS THAN COMPLY WITH THAT
REGION TOLL REQUEST BUT THEN
THE LEGISLATURE PERHAPS DOESN'T
GIVE US THE- AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE THOUGHT WE WANTED BUT I
MEAN IF IT'S OUR- ISSUE. IT
SHOULD BE. THE FIVE OR SIX OR
SEVEN YEAR PROBLEMS THAT SHOULD
GO AWAY IF WE UNLESS WE JUST
CONTINUALLY PERPETUATED PROBLEM
ME. WHAT IS A MAIN YOU ENROLL A
CLASS AND- YOU MAY NOT BE
FUNDED FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND
YOU TAKE IN TWO THOUSAND MORE
BUT I ASSUME THEN YOU'RE NOT
FUNDED FOR THE SECOND YEAR THE
THIRD YEAR THE FOURTH YEAR THE
FIFTH I MEAN. DON'T WE FIX THIS
AT SOME POINT OR WE JUST ASSUME.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN FIXING IT-
THAT'S THE WAY IT USED TO WORK
BACK IN LIKE TWO THOUSAND.
WHERE ONCE WE HAD AND ROLLED.
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LOOK THE
NEXT YEAR AND SAY HOW MUCH DID
YOU GO OVER THE AMOUNT AND THEN
THEY WOULD JUST SIR TOP THE
UNIVERSITY OFF. THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN ANYMORE- BUT THE METHOD
OF PRE FUNDING WOULD HELP US.
GET TO A- GET TO A SOLUTION ON
THAT TO A GOOD LONG WAY. WHERE
YOU WOULD GIVE US THE MONEY NOW
AND INDICATE NOW HOW MANY
STUDENTS YOU WANT US TO AND
ROLE. FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND THEN AND WE'RE
REQUESTING TWENTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THAT AND THEN
AS WE'RE MAKING IN ROMAN
DECISIONS AND RECRUITMENT AND
PLANNING ALL THROUGH THE YEAR
WE CAN HIRE THE FACULTY AND
THAT HAVE THE CLASS START. I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES OVER HERE
WANT TO JUMP IN. DID SOMEONE
ADDRESS I MEAN WHY DON'T WE TOP
IT OFF IF WE SAY IF IT'S US AND
WE SAY. THE LACSON YEAH I THINK
THIS GOES BACK TO ITS ON THE
WERE TALKING WHEN THE LAST ITEM
IS JUST HELPFUL PERSPECTIVE
HERE THAT. THAT ERA FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
SEVERAL YEARS IN A ROW THE SAME
APPROACH THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
WITH THIS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
TAKEN. WERE A FLEXIBLE BASED
AUGMENTATION. ON THE GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION WAS OFFERED
BY THE STATE. AND SO THAT MEANT
THAT A LARGE COMPONENT OF WHAT
THE STATE WAS PROVIDING YOU
SEE. DURING SEVERAL THOSE YEARS
WAS A FLEXIBLE INCREASED TO
THEIR- AT. THE CAMPUS LEVEL
APPROPRIATIONS SO AND SO THE
USE THAT SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE A
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION OVER.
DID THE STATE FUNDED THE
STUDENTS ARE NOT ONE
PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE THAT THE
STATE PROVIDED A- A SEVERAL
PERCENT BASE AUGMENTATION THAT
THE UC COULD USE. A HOWEVER
THEY SAW FIT TO ADDRESS COST
PRESSURES. AND TO EXPAND
ENROLLMENT. OR YOU CAN CALL OUT
A MARGINAL COST AS THE UC IS
SAYING AND- SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IT'S IT GOES BACK
TO THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS OF
INTERPRETING THIS YEAR. END OF
THE DISCUSSION IS I SEEM TO
REMEMBER. ACT ME IF I'M WRONG
ABOUT WHETHER WE ACTUALLY FUND
YOU SEE ON A PER STUDENT BASIS.
OR NOT THE WE HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ME MAYBE I'M MAYBE I HAD A
DREAM AND IT WAS A NO THAT'S
DEFINITELY A CONVERSATION THAT
HAS BEEN HAD IN THE PAST AND IS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN SO. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OKAY SIR. YEAH I
THINK YOU'RE RAISING AN
IMPORTANT- ISSUE WITH HAVING
THE SORT OF UNRESTRICTED BASE
INCREASES AND A NOT HAVING-
FUNDING THAT'S ALWAYS TIED ON A
PER STUDENT BASIS THAT CREATES
CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY
THE STATE HAS FUNDED. ALMOND
MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO SORT OF
EVALUATE- STATEMENTS ABOUT WHAT
IS AND ISN'T FUNDED AT THE
UNIVERSITY IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE HEARD THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY COST
HIGH FUNDING THOSE COSTS. WE%
THINK IT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT WITH ENROLLMENT
GROWTH- THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
DOESN'T SAID IN A MOMENT
TARGET. OF THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS SENT OUT SIGNALS IT WOULD
LIKE YOU SEE TWO GROWN ROMAN
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE A PROPOSED
TARGET OR I DON'T OR HI
SPECIFIC FUNDING FOR THAT
PURPOSE- AND WE THINK THAT
SENDS A CONFUSING SIGNAL TO THE
UNIVERSITY AND- COULD SET UP
NEXT. WEEK I GET CONFUSED
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
STATE'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WE THINK ABOUT OUR
APPROACH IN HIS APPROACH THE
STATE'S TAKEN IN PREVIOUS YEARS
THIS IS TO LIVE BY. THE SUDDEN
AND ROMAN TARGET IN THE BUDGET
THE STATEMENT SETTING THAT
TARGET ONE YEAR AFTER THE
BUDGET YOU'RE SO IN IN IN FOR.
INSTEAD OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WOULD SET THE TARGET FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AND THEIR
PURPOSE BEHIND THAT IS- THAT
YOU SEE ADMISSIONS PROP-
DECISIONS OFTEN HAPPEN SOMEONE
BEFORE BUDGET DECISIONS ARE
FINALIZED. FOR YOU SEE THIS
YEAR WILL MAKE- FALL MOMENT
ADMISSION DECISION SOMETIME IN
THE SPRING BEFORE THE BUDGETS
NOW ACTED IN JUNE SO IF YOU
SAID IN ROMAN TARGET FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR YOU SEE WILL OF A
READY MADE FALLEN NATION
DECISIONS WILL BE TOO LATE TO.
SEND A SIGNAL THAT'S WHY THE
STATE'S BEEN SET IT UP TARGET
ONE YEAR LATER. ALL WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE THESE. UNFUNDED
GROWTH ISSUES ON A GO FORWARD
BASIS YOU KNOW THAT I THINK
PART OF THE CHALLENGES THAT-
WHEN THE STATE SET THESE
TARGETS. AT A SAYS THE
UNIVERSITY NOTED IT DIDN'T SET-
IT JUST SORT OF SAID THIS IS
THE LEVEL THAT WE THAT YOU
SHOULD BE ON GROWING- AND IT
DIDN'T- IT ON IN PASS BUDGETS
WERE WAS OFTEN THE CASE IS THAT
THE STATE SET OF MARGIN OF
ERROR. FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
ENROLLMENT MAY AS PART OF PART
IN ART PARTLY SCIENCE. AND SO
IS OFTEN LIKE THEY THERE'S A
10% MARGIN OF ERROR SO THICK.
THEY ADMIT. THAT WORK IN A
VERY- PORTION OF THE FUND IN
MIGHTGO A SOCIO. BUT NOT ALL
THE- WOULD DISAPPEAR. SO GET A
GAVE THE UNIVERSE. SOME TO SIR
OF MAKE THAT AND- SETS IN A PRO.
THE STATE COULD TAKE A IT WAS
CAN. ABOUT THIS TREND. I THINK
ANOTHER AREA OF UNCERTAINTY IS
THE STATE'S. USED TO SET UP A
BASEMENT BASIN ROMAN TARGETS SO
USED TO SAY YOU'RE FUNDED FOR
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE HOW MANY STUDENTS
IT'S SET. IN RECENT YEARS IT
HAS BEEN SETTING A GROWTH
TARGET WITHOUT SPECIFYING WHAT
THAT BASELINE IS UNIVERSITIES
BEEN TRYING TO MAKE AN EFFORT
TO- WORK WITH THE STATE ON THAT
SO THEY'VE BEEN. THEY'VE BEEN
ADMITTING MORE ENROLLING OR
STUDENTS AND USING THAT AS A
NEW BASELINE REGARDLESS IF
THERE IF THEY INVOLVE MORE
THAN. WHAT WAS ACTUALLY SPECTER
BY THE STATE SO THAT'S ANOTHER
VERY RICH CREATED SOME
CONFUSION SO THERE ARE WAYS THE
STATE COULD. ON SET A TARGET
THAT GIVES THE UNIVERSITY A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY. ON
IN A LITTLE MORE CLARITY ABOUT
WHAT IT'S EXPECTING. I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND THE I THINK I
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE BUDGET YEARS AND WE- YOU
KNOW IF IT'S THIS YEAR. THEY
CAN'T. THEY CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE
THEY WERE ALREADY ADMITTED. SO
WE SET NEXT YEAR A TARGET. BUT
VIEW SEE KNOWS WHAT THEIR COST
OF EDUCATION IS ELEVEN OR
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
STUDENT OR WHATEVER IT IS AND
IF WE WANTED TO GROW BY TWO
THOUSAND WE COULD RUN THE MATH
ON THAT AND SAY HERE'S- X.
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR. THE GROWTH
THAT WE EXPECT YOU TO ATTAIN AS
AN INSTITUTION RIGHT. AND THEN
GIVEN THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
BETWEEN YOU SEE AND ALL THE
REST OF US THEY COULD CHOOSE TO
SPEND THAT ARE NOT SPENT AND I
SUPPOSE. AND THEN COME IN WITH
AN UNFUNDED GROSS NUMBER BUT WE
WOULD WE WOULD HAVE SAID WE
EXPECT YOU TO GROW BY TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS YOU TELL US
YOUR COST OF EDUCATION IS THAT
SEX YOU COST OF EDUCATION IS
WHY. HERE'S A CHECK FOR THE
COST TO FUND THE GROWTH ELEMENT
THAT WE'VE PROGRAMMED INTO OUR
BUDGET IN THE TWENTY. TWENTY
ONE. TWENTY TWO BUDGET YEAH
WHAT WE WAS SO WE DO HAVE A PER
STUDENT FUNDING RATE THAT WE
PROVIDE THEM FOR A MOMENT
GROWTH SO WE DO HAVE A BASIS
TO. DETERMINE HOW MUCH FUNDING
TO PROVIDE FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. I THINK THE ISSUE HERE
IS THERE'S- SOME UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT WHAT THE BASELINE TO GROW
ABOUT IS WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
ENROLL MORE STUDENTS THAN
EXPECTED- WHEN YOU PROVIDE THEM
FUNDING THE NEXT YEAR IS THAT
IS THAT TO PAY DOWN THAT
UNFUNDED STUDENTS OR DO YOU
AND- DO YOU EXPECT THEM TO
INCORPORATE THE STUDENTS INTO
THE NEW BASS FINDING GROW OFF
OF THAT. I THINK THAT'S WHERE-
THERE'S THERE COULD BE SOME
UNCERTAINTY THERE. BUT WE DO
HAVE A PERSON FUNDING- RATE
THAT WE PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITY
THAT OUT THAT DOES OFFER A
RATIONALE TO PROVIDE FUNDING
BASED ON LOAN GROWTH WE SHOULD
BE A FIX THAT PROBLEM RIGHT.
THE ONE YOU IDENTIFIES IT IT'S
YOU HAVE OPTIONS TO ADDRESS IT
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN THAT.
UPBEAT COUPLE OF COMMON SIR. OF
MILLION MISSED THE POINT. NO NO
NO YOU AYE. WE HAVE A MARGINAL
COST OF INSTRUCTION RATE THAT
HAS BEEN NEGOTIATED WITH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN. LA THAT WE
AGREE WITH THAT'S THE COST PER
STUDENT THAT WE OFTEN USE. HOW
MUCH DOES IT COST THE
UNIVERSITY TO EDUCATE SINGLE
STUDENT- WHEN WE DO. AT THESE
UNFUNDED. STUDENTS INTO OUR
BASE IT ERODES THAT DOLLAR PER
STUDENT. AS A HOLD THAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS TO SPEND. AND IT
REALLY MEANS THAT WE'RE SERVING
NOREEN THIS PROBLEM. OF NOT
HAVING THE FLATTERING FACULTY.
THAT WE NEED TO- PROVIDE THEM
WITH INSTRUCTION WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO STUFF THE STUDENTS
INTO THE- INTO THE CLASSROOMS.
BUT THE IMPORTANT POINT I WANT
TO MAKE IS THAT WHEN THE
UNIVERSITY HAS. OF INFLATIONARY
COST INCREASES. WITH IN A
REASONABLE. MARGIN OF. TWO
POINT FIVE TO TWO POINT 8%
ACROSS ALL OUR CAMPUS FUNDS
ACROSS ALL THOSE CORE FUNDS.
AND WE GET GIVEN A 2% STATE
GENERAL FUND INCREASES
HAPPENED. TWO OR 3% AS HAPPENED
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN. SKIN AND
THEN AT THE SAME TIME GOT TOLD
NOT TO INCREASE TUITION. OF AND
THEN EXPECTED. TO INK IF WE GET
THEN GET TOLD THAT WE HAVE THE-
OPTION TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT
THAT'S NOT A REAL. OPTION WE
NEED THOSE INFLATIONARY COST
INCREASES. IN KEEPING IT. AT A
MODEST INFLATIONARY INCREASE IS
JUST REALISTIC FOR WHAT IT
COSTS TO DO BUSINESS. FOR OUR
CAMPUSES BUT WHERE'S MY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DELTA
BETWEEN WHATEVER IN. THE DELTA
OF NINETY FIVE WHATEVER HIS
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN.
DOES THAT MAINTAIN THE FLAT
LINE AND THEN ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THESE OTHER PROGRAMS AND
HOW MUCH THEY COST AND WHO'S
GOING TO PAY FOR THEM AND IS IT
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND OR OUT
OF TUITION. AND IF THERE'S SOME
DISAGREEMENT OVER WHAT THE-
COST OF OPERATION IS TO
MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO THEN WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
RESOLVE THAT AND THEN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. DISCIPLINE
SHOULD THIS BE PAID FOR BY
STUDENTS THROUGH STUDENT
TUITION. SHOULD THIS BE PAID
FOR BY THE JEWS BY THE GENERAL
FUND THESE ADDED PROGRAMS SO.
WE PROBABLY CAN FIGURE THIS OUT
I WOULD PROBABLY. SOMETIMES
TALKING AT CROSS PURPOSES I
THINK I THINK WE'RE VERY CLOSE
TO FIGURING IT OUT- TO GET TO
THAT INFLATIONARY COST WE NEED
THAT NINETY FIVE MILLION. OR
ARE PLANNED FOR THE TUITION
DOLLARS IS IF. IS TO HOPEFULLY
USE IT FOR ENHANCED SERVICES UP
AND HIRING FACULTY AND WE DO
HAVE THESE FIVE THOUSAND
UNFUNDED STUDENTS WHO. WOULD
LOVE TO GET MORE FACULTY TORQUE
CAMPUSES TO INSTRUCT THEM
PERFECT. OKAY I DIDN'T MEET SO
PLEASE PROCEED I'VE ALL NIGHTER
UP DID YOU A FEW TIMES TO
THAT'S ALL RIGHT I HAVE SOME
SLIDES THAT I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH VERY QUICKLY JUST FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES I SLIDE
SIXTEEN HERE. OF TO SHOW WHO
ARE STUDENTS AND HOW IS THE
ETHNIC COMPOSITION OF OUR
STUDENT BODY GROWING- AND- AS
SOME NOTEWORTHY ITEMS ARE THAT
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. OF
ARE UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS
STUDENT BODY HAS GROWN FROM
EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE PERCENT. TO
THIRTY ALMOST 35% OF AND WHAT
THAT REALLY REPRESENTS IS. IN
HEAD COUNT IS ALMOST A THREE
TIMES. THE GROWTH IN STUDENTS
BECAUSE WE'VE GROWN SO MUCH OUR
OVERALL STUDENT BODY- SO THE
PERCENTAGE DOESN'T GO UP THREE
TIMES BUT THE HEAD COUNT DOES.
AND WE ARE STILL. CONTINUING TO
LOOK AT FACULTY DIVERSE. CRUDE
PERTAINS ARE HIGHLY QUALIFIED
OF THE U. R. G. OF FACULTY INTO
OUR SYSTEM SO THAT OUR FACULTY
START TO REFLECT OUR STUDENT
BODY AND STUDENTS FEEL. THAT
THEY'RE BEING OBSTRUCTED BY- A
VERY DIVERSE. OF FACULTY. AND
THAT CONCLUDES THE ENROLLMENT
DISCUSSION DO YOU HAVE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS DO YOU WANT
ME TO JUST MOVED TO. THE NEXT
ISSUE WELL HERE'S A QUESTION ON
LC OF LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA PLUS. HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMMER ARE YOU PREPARED TO.
MAYBE YOU ALREADY ADDRESS THAT
BUT MY QUESTION WAS IS THAT
WORKING. UP IT IS IT IS
WORKING- SO WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE FOR GIVING US
AN ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
THAT HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO
OUR CAMPUSES BUT I DON'T AT
THIS POINT HAVE THE HOME A RATE
OF HOW MUCH HAS BEEN EXPENDED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. BUT FROM
THE PRIOR OF. APPROPRIATIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED
TO US WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
CAMPUSES THAT WERE USING LC A
FIVE- PLUS FUNDING FOR. ART
RETENTION EFFORTS SAW BIG JUMPS
IN THE RETENTION OF THOSE
STUDENTS AND THEIR SUCCESS
RATE. OF THAT WERE RECEIVING
INDIVIDUAL ATTENTION UNDER
THOSE PROGRAMS AND WE ALSO SAW
INCREASES IN APPLICATIONS FROM
THOSE CAMP FROM THOSE HIGH
SCHOOLS WHERE THE LCF
COORDINATORS WERE WORKING WITH
THE- OF WITH THE HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO RECRUIT STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW I WAS JUST LOOKING IN
OUR ANALYSIS HERE IN. YOU KNOW
I'M OBVIOUSLY I MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE CONTEXT BUT REPORT NOTED
MISSION RATE FOR ALL SEE IT SEE
IF OF PLUS STUDENTS INCREASE
FROM FIFTY FOUR PERCENT. IN
18258% AND TWENTY NINETEEN IS
TO NOT ADMISSIONS RATES OF NON
LC IF OF POST STUDENTS WHICH
ALSO GREW FROM 61% 64% SO
GROWTH IN BOTH CATEGORIES. OF I
DON'T HAVE THOSE PERCENTAGES IN
FRONT OF ME BUT- WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN LETTING STUDENTS
WHO WOULDN'T OTHERWISE CONSIDER
APPLYING TO UC KNOW ABOUT THEIR
OPTIONS NO ABOUT WHAT OUR
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE TO MEET
IN ORDER TO GET INTO A FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTION AND OF
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE THEM
THROUGH THE APPLICATION PROCESS
AND ALSO ONCE THEY ARE YOU SEE.
THE INDIVIDUAL ACADEMIC
COUNSELING SERVICES THAT THEY
RECEIVE WE HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
INCREASE RETENTION RATES QUITE
A BIT. OKAY WELL WE CAN TALK
OFF LINE ABOUT THAT I HAVEN'T
SEEN THE SPECIFIC REPORT THAT
WAS SUBMITTED NOR WHAT I
NORMALLY SEE THAT BUT WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THAT I'LL TAKE A
LOOK AT THE I'LL MAKE CERTAIN
YOU AND YOUR STAFF GET A COPY
OF. DID TO MY STAFF OKAY THANK
YOU. FINANCE MISTER CHAIR I HAD
ONE CLEAR FINE POINT ON. TO
CLOSE THE ENROLLMENT
DISCUSSION. AT SO BECAUSE WE
HAD TALKED ABOUT THE PREVIOUS.
BUDGETS ENROLLMENT WHICH WE
FROM OUR VIEW IS A MORE OF AN
OPERATIONS COST. ISSUE BUT TO
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK TO THIS
BUDGET YEAR. WE WOULD NOTE
THAT. THAT THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT FUNDED. FOR FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SIXTY. NEW SLOTS. THERE WAS
SPREAD OVER TWO ACADEMIC YEARS
AND THAT INCLUDED THE ACADEMIC
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
SO ESSENTIALLY WE ARE DOING
CATCH UP. OR TOP OFF FOR
WHATEVER THE SENATE BUT
ESSENTIALLY THE TWENTY. TWENTY
ONE- BUDGET ALREADY HAS PRE
BAKED SIXTEEN HUNDRED NEW SLOTS
THAT YOU SEE INTO SPACE AND
ROLLING THIS UPCOMING YEAR. SO
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE ON
ENROLLMENT THAT'S A CRITICAL.
THAT'S CRITICAL TO NOTE AND WE
DO ACKNOWLEDGE- WE APPRECIATE
THIS COMMITTEES CAREFUL
ATTENTION TO OF THE ISSUE IN
THE OVERALL CONVERSATION THAT
IT'LL BE AN ON GOING ONE. WHY%
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME ON THE
CENTER LINE THANK YOU. I ALWAYS
NEED HEALTH THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
OKAY LET'S GO TO THE NEXT TO
ISSUE WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. A DEGREE ATTAINMENT AND
COMPLETION AN EXTENSION PROGRAM
RIGHT YES CORRECT- THANK YOU
SIR. SO THIS IS THE
PROGRAMMATIC AREA IN WHICH YOU
SEE WOULD LIKE TO DO-
IMPROVEMENTS AND PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS WITH IN THE
UNIVERSITY- WE HAVE A UC TWENTY
THIRTY PROGRAM. THAT IS
INTENDED TO PRODUCE MORE
DEGREES FOR CALIFORNIA IT HAS
THREE GOALS WE WANT TO PRODUCE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
DEGREES. OF THEN WE ARE
ALREADY- SCHEDULED TO PRODUCE
SO THIS WOULD BE A TOTAL OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION. OF GRADUATES
OF UC BY TWENTY THIRTY BETWEEN
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY THIRTY- WE ALSO WANT TO
INCREASE IMPORTANTLY OUR
GRADUATION RATE 290% FOR ALL
STUDENT GROUPS. SO CURRENTLY
WHILE WE HAVE A HIGH GRADUATION
RATE FOR OUR NON PAL CAUCASIAN
STUDENTS OF. THE WHOLE STUDENT
FIRST GENERATION AND YOU ARE G.
STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING AT A
SLOWER RATE. BUT WHAT THIS
WOULD LEAVE ME FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT BECAUSE CAL
GRANT NOW TO FOR YOUR- I YOU
SEE PRICES IN FIND AID
INSTITUTIONAL NATIONAL FOR THE
FIFTY YEAR. BUT STUDENTS ARE
RECEIVING LESS A AT THE STATE
AND SO THE INDIVIDUAL DEBT LOAD
OF STUDENTS WHO STATE FIVE FOUR
SIX YEARS IT'S HIGHER. THOSE
WHO GRADUATED FOUR YEARS THEY
ALSO MISS GOING TO THE WORK
FORCE TWO YEARS SOONER. AND
THEIR LIFETIME EARNINGS ARE
ACTUALLY LESS THAN THOSE WHO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS SO IT'LL
BUT SET. UP EQUITY. THE.
STUDENTS TO HAVE A GREAT IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND WE HAVE A
SEAT PROGRAMS WE'D LIKE TO
UNDERTAKE INCLUDING SUMMER
COHORTS TO HELP STUDENTS TAKE
CLASSES DURING THE SUMMER TO
KEEP THEM ON ACADEMIC TRACK.
BECAUSE WE ARE FINDING THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
GRADUATING. IN FIVE YEARS
PARTLY BECAUSE THEY MAY HAVE
MISSED OF COURSE THAT'S ONLY
OFFERED IN THE SPRING TIME. AND
THEN THEY HAVE TO STAY LONGER
IN ORDER TO TAKE THAT COURSE SO
WE WANT TO TRY TO GET THEM-
ESPECIALLY IF THEY MISS A SEAT
COURSE IN A SERIES TO TAKE
THOSE IN A SUMMERTIME SO THAT
THEY CAN GRADUATE ON TIME. OF
WE ALSO WANT TO INVEST IN OUR
FACULTY WE WANT TO HIRE AN
ADDITIONAL ELEVEN HUNDRED
FACULTY FOR OUR CAMPUSES. OF TO
PROVIDE MENTORING AND
INSTRUCTION OF FOR OUR STUDENTS
THAT THE FOUR YEAR PLAN FOR
THOSE ELEVEN HUNDRED FACULTY BY
REQUESTING SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS THESE EFFORTS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY ONE. LET
ME ASK A QUESTION HERE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTIVE OF
PARTICIPATION OBVIOUSLY- OF- WE
DID THIS SUMMER. WE JUST GOT
SUMMER CAL GRANT IT'S A
DIFFERENT SUMMER TUITION
ASSISTANCE SEVEN EIGHT PROGRAM
FINANCIAL AID. THAT WAS IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AND THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUED THAT- IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- HAS UC
DESIGN SOME SORT OF A- SYSTEM
OF TRYING TO. RECOVER DATA AND
APPLY SOME METRICS ANALYSIS TO
THIS PROGRAM TO SEE WHAT THE
ACTUAL RESULT IS AND WHETHER
THERE'S A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
OF THERE'S A COST BENEFIT-
CONNECTION HERE UP I'M GLAD YOU
pBRIDGE AND YOU MENTIONED
SUMMERS SO IT'S A NATURAL
ORIGIN I THINK IT IS ON A
SLIGHT EIGHTEEN I HAVE A GRAPH
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
HOPEFULLY. OF SHOWING THAT IN
THE LAST YEAR NOW THAT SUMMER-
OF FINANCIAL AID IS IN PLACE WE
SAW A JUMP OF THREE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED HEAD COUNT STUDENTS
ATTENDING SUMMER- BUT OVER THE
LAST OF FIVE YEARS WE'VE SEEN A
GROWTH IN TEN THOUSAND HEAD
COUNT STUDENTS ATTENDING SUMMER
THESE ARE STUDENTS WERE TAKING
AT LEAST ONE COURSE DURING THE
SUMMER. SO WE THINK WE ARE
SEEING UP THIS IN THE OF THREE
DOT ONE HUNDRED STUDENTS THINK
IS ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
FINANCIAL AID AND- WE'VE MET
HOW DO WE SEE IF WE CAN CONNECT
THOSE ATTENDING AN EARLY
GRADUATION. SYSTEM BODY WHOSE
TAKING A SUMMER COURSE NOT SO
THEY SHOULDN'T BE HERE THEY
WOULDN'T. YOU KNOW THEY
OBVIOUSLY NEED FINANCIAL AID SO
I WOULD THINK THEY'D BE
JUDICIOUS WITH WHAT THEY TAKE
AND HOW LONG THEY STAY AROUND
BUT- TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT
A FINE ARTS COURSE THAT'S OF.
AN EXTRA SUPPOSED TO OF COURSE
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
TOWARD READ THE GREEK
COMPLETION OUR CAMPUSES ARE
EXAMINING WHERE THE BOTTLE NECK
COURSES ARE. THAT MAY BE
SLOWING STUDENTS DOWN THOSE ARE
THE COURSES THAT HAVE- EITHER
REACH 100% ENROLLMENT OR CLOSE
TO IT DURING THE YEAR- AND
LOOKING OUT HOW THEY COULD MOVE
THAT SOME OF THOSE COURSES
DUPLICATE THEM DURING THE
SUMMER TIME. TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GET INTO A COURSE
DURING THE ACADEMIC YEAR TO
THEN TAKE THAT COURSE DURING
THE SUMMER AND WILL WE BE ABLE
TO TELL WHETHER. WELL THAT.
JANE RECEIVED A SUMMER
FINANCIAL AID AND THAT. JANE
ULTIMATELY GRADUATED. A
SEMESTER EARLY OR WE WILL BE I
WILL BE DOWN TO THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T
NEED THAT BUT WHAT WE WOULD
NEED IS WHAT THE IMPACT OF THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN. WE WILL BE
ABLE TO GET THAT DATA ONCE
STUDENTS START GRADUATING SO WE
USUALLY LOOK AT FROM FRESHMAN.
LOOK THE FOUR YEARS AND THENCE
A FIVE AND SIX AND SO IT TAKES
SEVERAL YEARS FOR THAT DATA TO
COME IN BUT WHAT WE WOULD LOOK
AT IS AVERAGES. WITHIN A
CERTAIN STUDENT TYPE SO WE
MIGHT LOOK AT A PELL GRANT
RECIPIENT WHO IS A U. R. G. WHO
ATTENDED AS A FRESHMAN AND- OF.
THEN WOULD LOOK HOW LONG DID IT
TAKE THAT PERSON DOES THAT
PERSON TO GRADUATE AND- START
LOOKING AT IF THE AVERAGES FOR
SIR. HI OUR- WELL I WOULD
IMAGINE OF GIVEN THE WAY THE
BUDGET WORKS IN THE STATE. FOR
THOSE WHO BETTER A LOT LONGER
THAN I HAVE BEEN- AT SOME POINT
IN TIME WHEN BUDGETS BECOME
EVEN MORE CHALLENGED- HOPEFULLY
WE WILL HAVE SOME DATA BECAUSE
WITH BUDGET PRESSURES. I THINK
IT WILL BE VERY VERY IMPORTANT
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS
PROGRAM ACTUALLY HAS AN IMPACT
AND AFFECT ON GETTING. YOUNG
AND NOT SO YOUNG FOLKS THROUGH
OUR UC SYSTEM YOU KNOW EARLIER.
AND SOMEONE CAN DO A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF THAT MAKE
IT YOU KNOW AND IF IT IS
BENEFICIAL CONTINUE THE
PROGRAMS OF THANK YOU FOR
WORKING THAT YET WAIT WE HAVE A
GREAT INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH
TEAM AT A U. C. O. P. AND I'M
CERTAIN THEY'LL GET RIGHT ON
THAT AND I SEE PART OF YOUR
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST IS
HAS TO DO WITH STUDENT
ADVISING. AND I THINK WE'RE
GONNA GET UP LATER. OF IF I GET
THE RIGHT REQUEST I THINK YOU
DO SO PART OF THE SIXTY MILLION
THIS LOOKING AT. IS GETTING
STUDENTS WHO ARE. FALL INTO
GROUPS WHO DON'T GRADUATE AT
THE SAME OF RADIUS NON PELL
RECIPIENTS AND- MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
ACADEMIC ADVISING LIKE WE'RE
STUDENTS WHO ARE FALLING
BEHIND- IN THEIR- ACADEMIC
PLANS HAVING MID TERMS CHECK
INS WITH AN ADVISER. OR HAVING
EVEN MORE IN DEPTH- HANDS ON
ASSISTANCE LIKE. THE START
MISSING- THEY MISS AND EXAMINED
THEIR COURSE. THE PROFESSOR CAN
LET THE ADVISER NO HOOKED AND
CHECKS IN WITH THE STUDENTS TO
SEE WHAT THEIR IF SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING IN THEIR LIVES AND
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT OTHER.
THINGS AROUND THINGS LIKE INS-
INSECURITY ABOUT HOUSING
INSECURITY ABOUT FOOD STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH MAY BE IMPACTING
WHETHER OR NOT THAT STUDENT HAS
THAT CONTINUITY AND COULD
HAVING AN ADVISER WHO CONNECTS
THEM TO SERVICES ON THE CAMPUS
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE. WE CAN
TO I THINK THERE'S SOME OTHER
DISCUSSION ABOUT- PROBABLY AND
STUDENT FEES SERVICES SECTION
ON ECONOMIC COUNSELING BUT YES.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT- CATCHER TO
STUDENT RATIOS BOTH IN THE
ACADEMIC IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SIDE AND- BECAUSE IT OCCURS TO
ME THAT. ON THE GRADUATION RATE
INITIATIVES WHICH- YOU HAVE ONE
BUT CERTAINLY SEE ISSUE AS THE
MAN. THE ACADEMIC HOUSING MUST
PLAY A PRETTY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THE AVAILABILITY OF CANCERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT STUDENTS GET
THROUGH THE PIPELINE. YOU KNOW
ON TIME ON TARGET WITH THE
DEGREE THAT THEY THINK THEY'RE
WELL I HAVE. YES WE'RE FINDING
IT THAT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT YES
OKAY. AND THEN PUT CAN MAKE
MAYBE TALK ABOUT YOU SEE
EXTENDED EDUCATION OR ARE YOU
GOING TO GET TO THAT- I JUST
HAVE A BRIEF STATMENT ON THAT-
THAT. WE'RE INTENDING TO
LEVERAGE THE ONE TIME FUNDS
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM THE STATE
OF TO EXPAND OUR DEGREE AND
WORK FOR CERTIFICATE ATTAINMENT
GOALS AT THE EXTENSION
PROGRAMS. OF WE RECENTLY-
REQUESTED OUR CAMPUSES TO PUT
TOGETHER PROPOSALS FOR HOW THEY
WOULD UTILIZED THAT FIFTEEN
MILLION THAT WE GOT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WE JUST GOT BACK
SEVEN DIFFERENT PROPOSALS. UP
FROM OUR CAMPUSES AND WE'RE
LOOKING- WE'RE CURRENTLY
LOOKING AT THESE PROPOSALS THE
C. WHICH ONES WE THINK WOULD
INCREASE DEGREE ATTAINMENT THE
MOST OF AND ALSO THE WHIC
PROGRAMS ARE COULD BECOME SELF
SUSTAINING AFTER BIRTH IS FOR
MORE MONEY. YES THANK YOU AND
BEFORE YOU SPENT THE LAST
PLEASE. WE HAVE NOT YET SPENT
THE LAST BEES BUT WE DID JUST
GET BACK THOSE PROPOSALS FROM
OUR CAMPUSES ON HOW HOW THEY
WOULD GO ABOUT SPENDING THEM
WHAT I LOOK FOR I LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING A CONTINUED
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE I MEAN I
REALIZE THIS IS IN YOUR
PROPOSAL BUT- IT. HAS BECOME
YOUR RAM IF IT HAS AND WE MADE
A GOVERNOR YEAH WE PUSHED THE
GOVERNOR'S COMP IN US AND
CREATING MORE PREPAYMENT YOU
KNOW I HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS I
DON'T REMEMBER IF I AS. THE
MOST YOUR- YOU KNOW WAS A
BERNIE BASED. THE DECIDED THAT
WE NEEDED TO DO THIS AND IF SO
WHAT WERE THE RESULTS AND WHO
WERE THE STUDY PARTICIPANTS I'M
AND I'M JUST THESE A RHETORICAL
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU YOU ALL YOU
SEE WAS NOT NECESSARILY
INVOLVED IN. IN THIS TOGETHER
AS YOU MAY KNOW I SPENT A FEW.
CHERISHED HOURS- WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOLKS TALKING ABOUT THE
CAL BRED ONLINE- COLLEGE THAT.
IN SOME RESPECTS APPEARS TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE SAME ISSUE WHICH
IS YOU KNOW WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND- JUST. PERHAPS
DEGREE BUT CERTAINLY NON
DEGREE- PROGRAMS IN THE
WORKPLACE AND- IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WE PROBABLY OUGHT TO
COORDINATE ALL THESE EFFORTS
SOME AL ONCE WE DETERMINE WHO'S
THE BEST WHERE THE BEST PLACES
TO HOUSE THESE PROGRAMS- I
REALIZE EXTENSION IS A SELF. IS
A- I WANT TO SEE A PROFIT
CENTER BUT IT'S A SELF
SUPPORTING OPERATION. YES IT'S
A SELF SUPPORTING OPERATION-
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. MAY BE LATER ANSWERED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED LONGER
TO ROLL DATA SYSTEM THAT WILL
LINK DATA FROM HIGH SCHOOL OF
FROM. HIGH SCHOOLS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CSU AND YOU
SEE TOGETHER TO SEE THE CORPS
STAKING PATTERNS OF STUDENTS
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY END UP
GETTING A DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE. AND ONCE THAT
SYSTEM WHICH IS NOW AND IN ITS
PLANNING FACES ONCE THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED THAT MIGHT YIELD A
LOT MORE INFORMATION TO ANSWER
SOME OF THESE COMPLEX
QUESTIONS. RIGHT I AS I SAID TO
THE CAL RIGHT FOLKS IT'S NOT
YOUR CONCERN BUT I SAID YOU
KNOW THESE THESE ARE PROBABLY
VALUABLE CONCEPTS AND VALUABLE
PROGRAMS A QUESTION IS. HOW WE
DESIGN AND HOW WE IMPLEMENT
THEM WHAT THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES ARE AND HOW WE
MEASURE WHAT WE'VE DONE AND-
WHETHER WHAT WE'VE DONE IS THE
RIGHT THING TO HAVE DONE. WE
SORT OF PUT THE MONEY AHEAD OF
THE ANALYSIS IS AND THE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM ONCE
IT'S UP AND RUNNING WHICH IS AN
WHICH IS AN EXCELLENT. COMMEND
THE ADMINISTRATION AN
EXCELLENT. A PROPOSAL AND AN
EXCELLENT SYSTEM- THAT WILL
PROVIDE I'M SURE SUPERB RESULTS
ONCE IT'S- FULLY FUNCTIONAL-
IT'LL TAKE US AWHILE TO GET
THERE AND IN THE MEANTIME.
WE'RE TRYING A BUNCH OF THINGS
I GUESS WELL ANYWAY ALL OF THE
LABOR THIS SIDE IT JUST TO IT I
JUST HAVE A- I JUST HAVE SOME
CONCERNS. A LOT OF MONEY. OF
ALL THE ALL THE- SELF
SUPPORTING CERTIFICATE GRANTING
PROGRAMS OUT THERE THE UC
EXTENSIONS ARE PROBABLY. THE
MOST ETHICAL ONES THAT CARE THE
MOST ABOUT THIS ACTUAL STUDENT
OUTCOMES SO WIPED ME RIGHT I
MEAN I WOULD I TAUGHT. AT THE
EXTENSION PROGRAM SO I'M A
BELIEVER IN THE EXTENSION
PROGRAM. I JUST QUESTION WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THIS ONE BUT
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT. HOW
YOU ALL IMPLEMENTED IN AND WHAT
THE PLAN IS WHEN YOU COME BACK
WITH THE PLAN WITH RESPECT TO
THE. WITH RESPECT TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FOSTER
USE THAN PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED. NOW WE HAVE SOME
SMALL PER RIFF ON OUR ANALYSIS
AT PAGE THIRTY ONE I DON'T NOW
IF YOU HAVE OUR ANALYSIS- THE
TALKS ABOUT- THE SPENDING YOUR
OF YOU SEE SPENDING PLAN
INCLUDED TWENTY MILLION ON
GOING YEAH BY THESE SERVICES-
NOT. INCLUDED THERE WASN'T NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET THAT WAS SPECIFIED FOR
THESE PURPOSES YES THIS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REGENTS REQUEST. OF COULD I GO
THROUGH OR SAY PEPPER QUEST
REALLY QUICKLY DO ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE THANK YOU SIR THIS
FOR YOU- BUT I DO WANT YOU TO
TELL ME HOW THOSE CURRENTLY
THOSE. STUDENT NEEDS ARE OURS
ADDRESSED NOW WHEN WE GET TO
THAT OKAY THAT'S THAT'S IN A
MOMENT SO ON SLIDE NINETEEN. OF
THE UC REGENTS ARE REQUESTING
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND THE SO CALLED STUDENT
ACADEMIC PREPARATION AN
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS. AND IT WAS OUR
STUDENTS WHO CAME TO THE
REGION'S WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND
REQUESTED MORE SERVICES. TO
HELP RECRUIT STUDENTS INTO THE
UC SYSTEM AND TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH ASSISTANCE WALTER AND
ROLLED. SO THAT THEY CAN-
ATTAIN THOSE UP. POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR SUPER PROGRAMS GO INTO
HIGH SCHOOLS ALL AROUND
CALIFORNIA- IN. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OF WE REACHED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. OF AND
WITH THESE ADDITIONAL FUNDS WE
COULD SHEPHERD EVEN MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE INTO OPPORTUNITIES TO
ALLOW THEM TO GROW INTELLECTUAL
AND ACHIEVE GREATER ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES. IN THE LONG RUN OF
THERE'S THIRTEEN SAY BY
PROGRAMS IN TOTAL THEY GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE EDUCATIONAL
PIPELINE FROM THE PRE SCHOOL TO
GRADUATE EDUCATION. AND THEY
PRIMARILY SERVED THE STATE'S
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME AND
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS WHERE THEY ATTEND. AND
WE HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT- OF.
OUTCOMES FOR THESE PROGRAMS
WHERE STUDENTS WHO UP
PARTICIPATE IN SAY PAP AND UP
COMPLETING A THROUGH G. AT MUCH
HIGHER RATES THAN STUDENTS- IT
DOES DISTRICTS WHO DO NOT.
PARTICIPATE IN THE SUPER
PROGRAM. SO WE ARE REQUESTING
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM IS
BUDGETED TO RECEIVE TWENTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION SO THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE FOR THEIR
BUDGET. BUT IF ALLOW US TO DO A
LOT OF GOOD SO YOU'RE ASKING
TWENTY THREE MILLION ON TOP OF
THE TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
THAT'S CORRECT. AND THEN. GO
INTO OUR SERVICES FOR THE
VULNERABLE STUDENT GROUPS-
THAT'S ON SLIDE TWENTY. SO WE
ARE REQUESTING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH WOULD BE
DIVIDED INTO THREE. OF POOLS
TEN MILLION FOR SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. AND FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUENTS. AND
CURRENTLY- THE ON DOCUMENTS
STUDENTS CENTERS ON THE
CAMPUSES WERE STARTED WITH
PRESIDENTIAL INITIATIVE FUNDING
FROM UC OP. THEY WERE APPROVED
ON A THREE YEAR PLAN TO GET THE
GET THE CENTER STARED WITH THE
INTENT THAT THEY WOULD THEN.
MOVE ON TO OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES. AND AS YOU MAY BE
AWARE. A UC OP BUDGET HAS BEEN
FELL HELD FLAT NOW IS PROPOSED
FOR THE FOURTH YEAR AS ACTUALLY
GONE DOWN A LITTLE BIT. OF WE
HAVE BEEN UTILIZING RESERVES
AND HAVE BEEN TRANSFERRING TO
UC OP RESERVES TO THE CAMPUSES.
SO USE YOUR P. NO LONGER HAS
THE CAPACITY TO CONTINUE THESE-
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE. OF
FUNDING TRANSFERS TO THE
CAMPUSES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
DâN DOCUMENTS STUDENT CENTER
BECAUSE THIS IS A REALLY
WONDERFUL POPULATION WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT- YOU PROVIDE US
WITH TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING THEM. THE
CENTERS PURPOSE IS TO PROVIDE
ACADEMIC ADVISING CRITICS
STUDENTS TO LOOK UP SOCIAL
SERVICES AND CONNECT THEM TO
LEGAL SERVICES. OF IT IS A
DIFFERENT OF FUNCTION THAN THE
LEGAL CENTER THAT IS A HOUSE
THAT UC DAVIS WHERE WE HAVE THE
LAWYERS WHO SPECIFICALLY HELP
STUDENTS WITH THEIR IMMIGRATION
PAPERWORK. THIS IS MORE OF THE-
CONNECTING TO CAMPUS SERVICES
AND GIVING STUDENTS A HOME BASE
WHERE THEY CAN FEEL LIKE THEY
BELONG SO THESE PROGRAM BUT ALL
OF THEM ALL THESE THREE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN ENOUGH. HAVE
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR THREE
YEARS. ONLY THE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT OF CENTERS HAVE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR THREE YEARS THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE CENTER IT'S
LOCATED BERKELEY- AND THE OTHER
CAMPUSES HAVE MORE SOCIAL CLUBS
THEY ARE NOT FUNDED. AND THEY
DON'T HAVE A HOME BASE SO THEY
DON'T HAVE A PHYSICAL SPACE ON
THE OTHER CAMPUSES. OF THE
BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND IN THE SHORT
TIME THAT THEY'VE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE THEY HAVE ACHIEVED A
100% RETENTION RATE. AND FOR
THE COHORT THAT THEY STARTED
WITH IN TWENTY SIXTEEN FOR
THOSE TRANSFER STUDENTS THEY'VE
HAD A 1100% GRADUATION RATE. AS
WELL SO THEY ARE SHOWING
REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENT IN
GETTING THE STUDENTS THROUGH I
WILL SAY OF COURSE ARE. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED WHO DO GET INTO
BERKELEY THEY HAVE TO BE
IMMENSELY MOTIVATED. AND
PROBABLY. WAY BETTER THAN I
COULD EVER BE OF SO FOR THEM TO
GRADUATE IN A 100% RATE THEY'RE
PROBABLY EXCELLENT TOP STUDENTS
TO BEGIN WITH. I'M IN THE FACT
THAT 69% OF THE- FRESHMAN
ADMITS HAVE GPAS OF THREE POINT
EIGHT OR ABOVE SOMEBODY'S
OBVIOUSLY VERY BRIGHT WHAT
ABOUT. SO THOSE ARE METRICS AND
THOSE ARE VALUABLE AND TO US IN
TRYING TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT.
YOU KNOW THE STATE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TO THE PROGRAM WAT
ABOUT THE FOSTER USE AND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR THE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR SERVING MORE
THAN A YEAR HAVE HAVE AS YOU
SEE BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP SOME
METRICS TO DETERMINE. SUCCESS
OR FAILURE WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF PROGRAM
FORGET THE LEGAL PIECE FOR
RIGHT NOW I DON'T HAVE- ANY
DATA. IF ON THE RETENTION AND
GRADUATION RATE OF THE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT POPULATION
AT THIS TIME- A THAT'S SIMILAR.
THREE YEARS SO YOU'VE DEPENDING
ON WE DEMAND THE PROGRAM IT MAY
NOT BE. LONG ENOUGH BUT I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE. PUTTING
TOGETHER SOME. REPORT CARDS SO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO TRIAGE
AND MAKE DECISIONS ON SCARES
RELATIVELY SCARCE RESOURCES MAY
BE GETTING MORE SCARCE WHETHER
IT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR THE LA- TO COMMENT TO
PEOPLE LIKE US WHO HAVE TO VOTE
WE CAN ASSESS WHICH PROGRAMS.
TO CONTINUE. MAKING DIFFICULT
CHOICES AMONG. ALL EXTRA EARLY
WORTHWHILE PROGRAMS. OF THAT'S
CORRECT SIR- I WILL SEE WHAT
KIND OF DATA WEEK WE HAVE AND
WHAT MAY BE AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS COMMITTEE. PERFECT
AND I WOULD JUST SY ON THE
FORMER FOSTER USE OF THIS OF
POPULATION THAT IS EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE-
WITHOUT ANY PARENTAL SUPPORT
THEIR PARENTS ARE EITHER DEAD
OR INCARCERATED- WE CURRENTLY
DO HAVE SMALL SERVICES OF FOR
THESE FOR FOSTER YOUTH ON OUR
CAMPUSES AND THIS WOULD BE
ABOUT A DOUBLING OF THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE WE SPENT A
FAIR. SINCE THE AGE OF AND WHEN
THEY AGE OUT THERE STILL VERY
VERY YOUNG. RELATIVELY SPEAKING
AND WITHOUT SUPPORT STRUCTURE
AND- A MEAL. A DEADLY GET A
SYMPATHETIC EAR HERE AMONG MY
COLLEAGUES FOR PROVIDING
SERVICES IN ASSISTANCE TO THIS
YOU KNOW COMMUNITY. I JUST
THINK WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO. HOW TO QUANTIFY WHAT YOU DO
AND HOW TO ASSESS. UNDOUBTEDLY
THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU WERE
DOING AND DOCUMENT IT SO. WHEN
WE'RE FACED WITH CUTS IN. WHAT
THE FUND WHAT NOT TO FUND
WHETHER IT'S INSIDE YOU SEE OR
ELSEWHERE WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS AND- PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF ATTENTION.
TO THE PROGRAM SO I'M SURE
YOU'LL HELP ME. YES I WILL. IS
THAT IT THAT'S IT FOR- FOR OUR
X. DEGREE ATTAINMENT REQUEST
WELL LET'S SOME OKAY LET'S HAVE
WE WERE ON EXTENSION AND MY
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT WERE
KIND ENOUGH TO LISTEN TO ME FEB
SO LET ME LET YOU WALL COMMENT
ON THE EXTENSION PROGRAM FRONT
OF FINANCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR THING FOR THE INTEREST IN
THE EXTENSION WILL JUST
BRIEFLY. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES INCLUDE FOUR MILLION ONE
TIME. FOR EXPANDING-
DEVELOPING- YOU SEE EXTENSION
PROGRAMS JUST TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE HELPFUL QUESTIONS
YOU RAISE YOUR ONE IS NINE ONE
IS DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN. IT
YOU KNOW THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND YOU SEE EXTENSION
AND IN OUR VIEW THE ROOT.
POPULATIONS WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE
WAY. THAT THE SYSTEMS WORK OUR
FRIEND THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT'S A MUCH BROADER
AUDIENCE. AND FOR THE UC
EXTENSION WERE SPECIFICALLY
AIMING IT AT ADULT STUDENTS WHO
HAVE SOME UNITS. AND TRY TO GET
THOSE STUDENTS RE ENROLLED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION SO THEY CAN
PURSUE A BACHELOR'S LEVEL
DEGREE. WERE ALSO ENCOURAGING
OPEN TO. CERTIFICATE LEVEL
DEGREE BUT THE BAT THIS IS A
BIG FOCUS AT THE UC EXTENSION.
IN WHAT WE INVESTED THE
MILLIONS TIME LAST YEAR AND WHY
WERE PROPOSED FOR MILLION THIS
YEAR. A TO DISTINGUISH FROM
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR THIS IS
POST FOCUSED ON LINE. PRO
THAT'S BECAUSE THE ADULT
POPULATION HAS A HIGHER LEVELS
OF CONSTRUED IT'S THEIR DAILY
LIVES SO ONLINE IS A GOOD WAY
TO. TO REACH THEM. SO THAT'S
EIGHTY. HIGH LEVEL LET IT
OVERLAPS ULTIMATELY BE VIEWED
AS- THE COMMUNITY HELPS YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE TO
THAT. LEVEL OF ASSIST IN THE
WAY THAT YOU SIX WHAT. AND FOR
I THINK OF. WE'RE GOING TO
FIGURE OUT THIS P. RATHER. BUT
LET ME ASK ME ASK A QUESTION
AND I DIDN'T ASK IT SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WHO. HAVE
ATTENDED A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION PRESUMABLY AND BUT
DIDN'T QUITE COMPLETED AGREE I
THINK THAT'S WHAT AND I
REMEMBER THAT FROM LAST YEAR
HOW DIFFICULT IS IT TO A RE
INTEGRATE INTO TO TRADITIONAL.
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
PROGRAMMING STREAM TO COMPLETE
THE COURSE OF TWO OR FOR THAT A
PERSON NEEDS IN ORDER TO GET
THAT DEGREE. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
ISSUES APPARENTLY AND- FIRING
UP THIS EXTENSION PROGRAM I
GUESS IS TO ALLOW SOMEONE TO
COME BACK AFTER FOR FIVE YEARS
AND PICK UP YOU KNOW THE UPPER
DIVISION ENGLISH COURSE FOR.
HISTORY COURSE YOUR MATH COURSE
WERE FOUR FIVE OF THEM
NECESSARY TO. ACHIEVE A DEGREE
FROM SOMEWHERE. IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION WHAT IS WHAT IS THE
PROCESS AND HOW DIFFICULT IS IT
AND WHAT OBSTACLES WILL THE
EXTENSION PROGRAM OVERCOME THAT
EXIST IN THE CURRENT. SAID A
PROGRAM I'M NOT CERTAIN ARE
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN THE
PROPOSALS FOR MY EXTENSION HOW
THEY INTEND TO OVERCOME THE
PROBLEMS THAT THE OR THE
OBSTACLES THAT THE STUDENTS
FACE WE DO KNOW THAT TUDENTS
WHO ARE RETURNING ARE OLDER
THEY OFTEN HAVE FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN THEY MAY HAVE SOME
CHILD CARE ISSUES GOING ON AND
THEN- THEY DO NEED TO FIND A
TIME FOR COURSE WORK IN BETWEEN
HAVING AN ACTUAL. OF
POTENTIALLY A FULL TIME JOB SO
OF COURSE NOT THAT MY- ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE UNITS
AT- AT. UC MERCED. AGE OUT FIVE
YEARS LATER. THEIR YOUR UNITS
WOULD STILL BE GOOD IT'S JUST
GETTING THAT STUDENT TO COME
BACK AND COMPLETE AND WE DO
THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY WE DID AN ANALYSIS.
OF STUDENTS WHO LEAVE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT OF COMPLETING A DEGREE
WE FOUND OUT THAT ABOUT 36% OF
THEM HAVE OVER ONE HUNDRED
UNITS COMPLETED. SOME MAJORS
ONLY NEED HUNDRED TWENTY UNITS
SO THEY'RE VERY VERY CLOSE AND
IF WE COULD CAPTURE DOT
POPULATION BRING THEM BACK AND
HAVE THEM COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREES. THEY WOULD HAVE MUCH
GREATER ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES.
WHETHER A LOT OF ISSUES
FINANCIAL AID COST ME IN THE WE
NEED AT SOME POINT IF THIS.
PROGRAM. DEVELOP SWINGS AND
EXPANDS WILL HAVE TO ADDRESS
BUT IT'S I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR IT IT'S A FAIRLY MINOR
INVESTMENT IN A- AND- IN AN
EXPERIMENT IS OF CALL IT AND-
WILL MOVE FORWARD LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING WHICH PLAN LOOKS LIKE
LA- YOU MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING TO
SAY. SIR I JUST IN OUR ANALYSIS
WE RAISED EXACTLY THE SAME
CONCERN SO YOU'RE RAISING NOW
IN ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT NOW
TRYING TO INVESTIGATE MORE. WE
THE PROBLEM STATEMENT STILL
REMAINS UNCLEAR TO LAST WEEK
THERE ARE MANY MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS WITH IN CALIFORNIA OF
SOME CALLS BUT NO DEGREE BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF ANALYSIS
LACKING AS TO HOW MANY OF THE
STUDENTS. WANT TO COME BACK TO
SCHOOL AND GET ABOUT HIS DEGREE
MIGHT BARRIERS THEY- FACE. ON
THAT WOULD PRESUMABLY BE THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION- THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD WOULD SEEK
TO ANSWER BEFORE- DE
IDENTIFYING A SOLUTION TO IT-
EVEN TO THE EXTENT THAT- THE
PROBLEM IS IDENTIFIED- WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE A LOT OF.
OPTIONS REENTRY OPTIONS
CURRENTLY INCLUDING- EXISTING
PROGRAMS AT CSU EXTENSION THAT
OUR BACHELOR'S DEGREE
COMPLETION PROGRAMS. IT BEYOND
ALL THAT TO ADD EXTENSION
PROGRAMS BOTH THE UC AND CSU
ARE SELF SUPPORTING AS YOU
NOTED- THROUGH STUDENT FEES WAS
IT IS UNCLEAR TO US WHY STATE
FUNDING IS NEEDED. PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE ONE OF THE OF. A JOBS
OF AN EXTENSION PROGRAM IS TO
MAINTAIN RESERVES THAT IT CAN
THEN USE TO PLAN FOR FUTURE
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT. AND THEN
FINALLY WE THINK IT'S
PREMATURE- TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM PROGRAM GIVEN
THAT. A SIMILAR PROGRAM
INITIATIVES FUNDED LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET LEGISLATURE AS LITTLE
INFORMATION AS TO HOW THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE SPENT IN. OTHER
RELATIVE SUCCESS SO IT'S A
LITTLE PREMATURE TO RENT THEM
UP AT THIS TIME RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL IN THIS
YEAR. WELL HELLO I WAS TRAINED
AS A LAWYER WHICH MEANS I WAS
TRAINED TO BE AN OBSTRUCTIONIST
ANNA. AND MISTER NO I THAT'S
NOT MY CURRENT JOB AND SO I'D
LIKE TO TRY TO. IF THIS IS OF
INTEREST TO THE ADMINISTRATION
pSECOND YEAR. I'D LIKE TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE.
MAKE WHATEVER IT IS WE'RE
DOING- SUCCESSFUL SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE UC REPORT WORK
WITH APPRECIATE YOUR-
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS- LA- AND-
YOUR COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE'LL
SEE HOW TO MAKE THIS- MAKE THIS
AGO ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS. ITEM
ONE ONE AREA THAT MIGHT- THE
HELP IS- IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT WHERE WHERE
COULD WE WERE THE INFORMATION
GAS PROBABLY GETTING MORE
INFORMATION ON THE OTHER. ON
THE UNDERLYING CAUSES FURTHER
STUDYING THE ISSUE. THAT COULD
BE ONE POTENTIAL AREA.
LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS ATTENTION
ONOUR- AS IT'S THINKING ABOUT-
IMPROVING WAY STUDENTS CAN
ACCESS COLLEGE. WELL AS YOU
KNOW THERE'S OF. A CONTINUED.
THERE IS A AN ENHANCED. AND
FORCED MOVE NOW TO EXPLORE. AND
FIELD ONLINE EDUCATIO EFFORTS
THAT ARE OCCASIONED BY THIS
CURRENT THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH. AND THE
PRODUCT ONE PRODUCT OF THAT MAY
BE INCREASED ONLINE OFFERINGS
IN AREAS WHERE THERE WAS
RESISTANCE TO OFFER THEM BEFORE
AND SO WE COULD SEE ONLINE
OPPORTUNITIES. IN THE FUTURE
EXPAND- IN AREAS WHERE THEY
CURRENTLY DO NOT EXIST AND THAT
MAY CHANGE THE CALCULUS HERE AS
TO WHETHER WE USED THE
EXTENSION PROGRAMS FOR THIS
PURPOSE OR WHETHER ON ENHANCED
ONLINE OPPORTUNITIES ON THE
TRADITIONAL. BRICK AND MORTAR
CAMPUSES OPEN UP. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE DEGREES
FOR PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE TEN
YEARS AGO OR FIVE YEARS AGO.
WHO DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE BRICK AND MORTAR CAMPUS BUT
WOULD LIKE TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE SO I GUESS THIS IS A
MOVING TARGET I APPLAUD THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S INITIATIVE TO
TRY NEW THINGS AND I DON'T WANT
TO THROW. WATER ON THAT EFFORT
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING. TO
IMPROVE THE LOT OF FOLKS WHO
WERE JUST TRYING TO MAKE IT SO.
THANK YOU FOR DOING IT. NEXT
ISSUE SIX ADDRESSING STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS THIS- WE'RE
HOLDING ALL THESE- ITEMS OPEN
IN CASE OF THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE SEVEN NOTED BUT THIS
ONE IS AN INFORMATIONAL ONE.
TICKET YES SO- IN THE CURRENT
YEAR IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR PROVIDED YOU
SEE. WITH FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO START ADDRESSING-
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS. THIS WOULD
BE DEFINED AS- ISSUES AROUND
HUNGER. OF HOMELESSNESS. OF END
OF THESE FUNDS WERE IN RESPONSE
TO A STUDENT SURVEY THAT UC
CONDUCTED BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHICH FOUND THAT 44% OF
OUR UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION
AND 25% OF GRADUATE STUDENTS
REPORTED HAVING FOOD AND
SECURITY. UP AND UP 25% OF
UNDERGRADUATE AND 4% OF
GRADUATE STUDENTS REPORTED
BEING HOMELESS AT SOME POINT
DURING THEIR TIME WITH YOU SEE.
UP AND FOOD AND SECURITY IS
DEFINED AS NOT HAVING ENOUGH
MONEY TO PURCHASE. THE FOOD
THEY NEED TO EAT FOR THE ENTIRE
MONTH SO HAVING TO SKIP MEALS
AT SOME POINT BECAUSE OF LACK
OF FINANCING. IN THE CURRENT
YEAR THE CAMPUSES ARE FOCUSING
ON BUILDING UP INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ALLOWS STUDENTS TO MORE
EASILY APPLY FOR DOES CAL FRESH
BENEFITS. OF THEY'RE LOOKING AT
CONNECTING TO CAMPUSES WITH A
COUNTY SERVICES. THEY'RE
PROVIDING MORE FOOD THROUGH
THEIR CAMPUS FOOD BANKS WE NOW
HAVE A FOOD BANK. AT OR VERY
NEAR EVERY SINGLE OF OUR
CAMPUSES. OF AND THEY'RE ALSO
HIRING PERMANENT CAMPUS
COORDINATORS TO LIVE- MANAGE
THE BASIC NEEDS FOR THE CAMPUS.
OF WE'VE MANAGED TO END OF
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHICH IS WHEN
WE HAVE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE SO IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YOU GIVE US
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION THEN YOU
INCREASE THAT SIGNIFICANTLY TO
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
SYSTEM. BUT WITH A ONE POINT
FIVE WE MANAGED TO PROVIDE
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS. UP
WITH SERVICES THROUGH FOOD
PANTRIES I END UP WE ALSO
ASSISTED UP ALMOST THIRTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS WITH
SUBMITTING CAL FOR SHOP
LOCATIONS. UP WHICH GIVES THEM
A- GOOD GOOD WAY TO PURCHASE
FOOD FOR THEMSELVES. SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING. THERE'S A LOT OF
PARTNERSHIPS BEING DEVELOPED
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND-
WITH NONPROFIT ENTITIES IN THE
COMMUNITIES TO HELP STUDENTS
CONNECT TO BASIC- NEED
SERVICES- IN REGARDS THE RAPID
RE HOUSING FUNDING YOU SEE THAT
ON SLIDE TWENTY TWO. OF WE
RECEIVED THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS JUST FOR
HOUSING SERVICES. THE WAY WE
THE CAMPUSES RECEIVED THESE
FUNDS EVER CAMPUS RECEIVED A
BASE ALLOCATION AND THEN THE
REMAINDER OF THE FUNDS WERE
DIVIDED BASED ON THE NUMBER
STUDENTS WHO ON THAT CAMPUS
REPORTED BEING HOMELESS AT SOME
POINT DURING THAT TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURVEY THAT WAS
CONDUCTED. OF THIS IS THE
PERCENTAGE THAT WILL BE RE
EXAMINED US YEARS GO ON BECAUSE
WE'RE NOW DOING THE SURVEY
EVERY TWO YEARS. SO WE WILL
HAVE MORE. RESPONDENTS IN THE
IN THE FUTURE ON HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON DUPLICATED
HOMELESS MEANS MEANS THAT- SOME
STUDENTS REPORTED BEING
HOMELESS DURING THE WINTER
BREAK AND ALSO DURING THE
SUMMER BUT WE'RE ONLY COUNTY
THAT WAS ONE. WILL WE WILL WE
ULTIMATELY- RECEIVE A REPORT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE ON. BOTH
BOTH OBVIOUSLY THE- ALLEVIATION
OF HUNGER AND THE RAPID RE
HOUSING EFFORTS YES FROM WILL
SEE YES YOU WORLD THERE ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORTS I
BELIEVE ONE OF THEM UP IS TO
VERY SOON WHERE THEY GET DOES
IS IT THIS OF ONE OF THE
REPORTS GO TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE A
YES I THINK THAT'S HOW THE
STATUTE IS WRITTEN THAT THE
REPORTS ALL GO TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE WE
DO ALSO SEND- THE- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE LA- AND- EVERY
MEMBER OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
I BELIEVE GETS A- GOT A COPY.
OF THOSE REPORTS BUT- WE WILL
MAKE CERTAIN THAT YOU GOT ONE
ONCE IT'S RELEASED AND THE
REASON I ASK OF COURSE IS I'M
LOOKING DOWN HERE AND OF COURSE
SOME. CAMPUSES WERE THE USE
WORDS LIKE ESTABLISHING A FUND
WILL THAT WORK THAT'S GOOD AND
WE CAN THE REPORT SHOULD
INDICATE. THAT THE FUND WAS
ESTABLISHED IN WHAT IN THE HOW
IT USED ANOTHER ONE SAYS
FORMING A PARTNERSHIP WITH A
PARTICULAR COUNTY. TO ENSURE
AVAILABILITY SO THE REPORT
WOULD INDICATE SHOULD INDICATE
THAT THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
INFORMED AND WHAT IT'S DOING.
AND HOW THE MONEY SPENT OR-
PARTNERSHIP WAS NOT FORMED. AND
THEN THOSE OF US WHO WERE
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING GREASE
TO THAT WE'LL COULD APPLY A
LITTLE GREASE AND MAKE SURE
THAT SOMETHING HAPPENS SO THAT
WE TAKE CARE OF. HIM TO TAKE
CARE OF THE HOUSING NEEDS OF.
OF STUDENTS AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN EXACTLY THE INTENT HERE IS
TO REALLY ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS. UP ARE SAFE. AND THAT
THEY HAVE THEIR OF BASIC HUMAN
NEEDS TAKEN CARE OF SO THAT
THEY CAN FOCUS ON THEIR STUDIES.
I WILL- CHECK IN ON THOSE
REPORTS AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THEY CONTAIN INFORMATION. ABOUT
THE ACTUAL STEPS TAKEN AND WHAT
THE OUTCOMES WERE. OF THOSE
STEPS OF MUCH AS WE CAN REPORT
ON A HELPFUL I MEAN I'M YES I
DON'T SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUES
BUT I THINK I COULD SAY THE
MIKE. MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE I'M SURE THAT
REPRESENT THESE AREAS- WOULD BE
VERY INTERESTED IF. RAPID RE
HOUSING EFFORT TO NOT MOVING
ALONG QUITE AS SWIFTLY AS THEY
SHOULD. NOT BECAUSE OF FUNDING
BUT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
PARTICIPATION OR COOPERATION AT
SOME LEVEL BELOW US IN EXACTLY-
YES I WILL CHECK ON THAT. IN
THIS FIRST YEAR HESE RAPID RE
HOUSING FUNDS ALLOWED CAMPUSES
TO CONDUCT FOCUS GROUPS ON WHY
STUDENTS WERE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OF THE KIND OF
LIVING CONDITIONS THAT THEY
HAD. OF THE FOCUS GROUPS FOUND
THAT STUDENTS WERE CHOOSING TO
LIVE IN VERY OVERCROWDED
SITUATIONS WITH MULTIPLE PEOPLE
IN THE SINGLE BEDROOM. OF IN
ORDER TO MAKE THEIR MONEY LASTS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND THEY
WERE ALSO PRIORITIZING HOUSING
OVER FOOD. SO THE HOUSING AND
SECURITY IS ALSO IMPACTING THE
FOODS IN SECURITY FOR THE
STUDENTS. OF IN IN THIS BURST
YEAR TO CAMPUS ARE FOCUSING ON
TWO PRIMARY ACTIVITIES THEY'RE
HIRING STAFF WHO ARE BUILDING
THESE NETWORKS WITH COMMUNITY
HOUSING PROVIDERS. OF AND
ADDRESSING THE STUDENT CRISIS
SITUATIONS AND THEY'RE ALSO
OFFERING TO STUDENTS SMALL
EMERGENCY HOUSING GRANTS. BUT
THESE ARE JUST A FEW HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENT DOESN'T LOSE THEIR
APARTMENT BECAUSE IT'S A LOT
MORE EXPENSIVE ALSO TO GET THE
STUDENT INTO HOUSING AGAIN.
ONCE THEY HAVE BECOME HOMELESS
PARTLY BECAUSE IN A LOT OF THE
CITIES NEAR OUR CAMPUSES.
THERE'S ONLY A FEW APARTMENT
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES AND IF
SOMEBODY HASN'T BEEN PAYING
THEIR RENT WITH THAT COMPANY
AND ONE COMPLEX THEY MIGHT NOT.
WANNA RENTED THEM IN ANY F THE
COMPLEXES THAT THERE ARE
MANAGING SO THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM FOR THE STUDENT. AND
THEN ON SLIDE TWENTY THREE I
JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
REALLY QUICK- VISUAL OF THE
EFFORTS UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S TAKING TO INCREASE
STUDENT HOUSING. OF WE HAVE OUR
STUDENT HOUSING INITIATIVE THAT
HAS ALREADY SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
WE'VE CONSTRUCTED OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. OF DORMITORY BEDS AND
WE NOW HAVE A PLAN TO CONSTRUCT
AND THIS IS. THIS IS THE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
BED TO SEE PLANNED BETWEEN FALL
TWO TWENTY ONE AND FALL TWENTY
FIVE. THOSE ARE ONES FOR WHICH
WE HAVE WE BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
UP. FINANCING IN PLACE. THERE'S
YET EVEN MORE DORMITORY SO
WHERE PLANNING FOR WHICH THE
FINANCING HASN'T YET BEEN
SECURED THESE ARE PRIMARILY P.
WHAT ARE CALLED EACE THREE. OF
PARTNERSHIPS THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WHERE WE HAVE THE
DEVELOPER ALREADY. SELECTED AND
WE HAVE THE PROJECT PRETTY MUCH
READY TO GO. SO THIS WILL HELP
ALSO ALLEVIATE THE SITUATION
FOR OUR STUDENTS. OF ANY
QUESTIONS ON BASIC NEEDS NO.
THANK YOU AND THEN JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF INFORMATION- TO
UPDATE YOU ON SOME STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ISSUES-
IS ISSUE SEVEN FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOLLOWING ALONG YES ISSUE
SEVEN- INFORMATIONAL ITEMS SO
YOU SEE DOES HAVE A REQUEST OF
FOR FUNDING AROUND STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH WE ARE REQUESTING
IT'S A TOTAL OF TEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DONE BUT THAT INCLUDES.
IS FIVE POINT THREE MILLION NEW
MONEY AND THEN IF YOU'LL RECALL
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE RECEIVED SOME
FUNDING FROM THE LEGISLATURE
BUT IT WAS ONE TIME WHEN AWAY
PORTION OF THE FUNDING WOULD
HAVE BEEN FOR MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS AND WE'RE REQUESTING
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION FOR THAT.
I YOU'LL SEE THAT SUMMARIZED AT
THE BOTTOM OF SLIDE TWENTY FOUR.
SO. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE ANALYSIS THAT COMMITTEE
STAFF PREPARED FOR US. THIS IS
ON PAGE THIRTY NINE I WAS
LOOKING AT. SOME OF THE
STATISTICS 96% OF STUDENTS
RECEIVED WITHIN TWO DAYS FOR
URGENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AT
THE UC COUNSELING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES FOR CAPS
CENTERS. 99% SAYING WITHIN
SEVEN DAYS THAT'S IN THE-
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REPORT. AND THEN THERE WERE
SOME. OTHER STATISTICS. FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHAT'S THE
OPTIMUM IS THERE IS THERE SOME
STANDARD TO IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION WORLD PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS ARE SORT OF
MEASURED BY IN TERMS OF. HOW
LONG IT TAKES TO ADDRESS-
STUDENTS URGENT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AS OF CLOSE TO ONES THAT
ARE. MORE ROUTINE IF THE IF YOU
EVEN HAVE ROUTINE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. OF WHAT THE RATIO WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO IS ONE
COUNSELOR FOR EVERY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND ONE
PSYCHIATRIST FOR EVERY SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
DAYS OF TO SEE A STUDENT I'M
NOT CERTAIN WHAT THAT IS IN THE
URGENT CASES WE WANT THEM TO
GET IMMEDIATE HELP. BUT THE
EXTREME CASES MAY ACTUALLY BE
TRANSFERRED AWAY TO A MENTAL
HEALTH HOSPITAL AWAY FROM
CAMPUS- ON A PREPAY I NOTICE
THAT CAPS. CENTERS DO NOT
PERFORM. DO NOT PROVIDE LONG
TERM COUNSELLING AND
PSYCHOTHERAPY SERVICES INSTEAD
STUDENTS SEARCH REFERRED TO
OFFSITE COMMUNITY PSYCHIATRISTS
WHEN THIS CARE IS NEEDED IN. MY
MARGIN NOTE TO MYSELF WAS WHO
PAYS. OF THAT WOULD THE FOUR
FORTY OFF SITE CARE IT WOULD BE
INSURANCE AND WITH OUR- STUDENT
COUNSELING SERVICES IT'S
STUDENT FEES TUITION AND STATE
GENERAL FUND SO YOUR SHIP
STUDENT HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN
COVERS THE OFFSIDES. UP I WILL
HAVE TO CHECK ON THAT FOR YOU
WHAT'S COVERED AND WHAT'S NOT
COVERED WITH AND SHIP WELL I
WANT TO COMMEND YOU SEE ON A
COUPLE FRONTS ONE YOUR- I THE
REQUIRE INSURANCE ARE PROVIDED.
AT COST INTO YOUR INSURANCE
PLAN INCLUDES MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WOOTEN OTHER.
DIVISIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AND WE'VE NOT CORRECT THAT NOT
YET AND THE TRANSFER WAS
DESCRIBED THE OTHER DAY TO ME
AS A WARM HAND OFF BETWEEN
CAMPUS SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH AND WHEN
I ASK. WHO PAYS I WAS TOLD.
WELL YOU KNOW. EITHER I DON'T
KNOW OR SOMEONE HAS TO ELSE'S
TO FIGURE IT OUT AND I COMMEND
YOU SEE FOR. ADDRESSING THIS
FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE END
WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHETHER. TWO
DAYS FOR URGENT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES IS A PROPER TIME FRAME
FOR TREATING. STUDENTS BUT SHE
ALSO TOLD ME IF IT'S THAT
URGENT THEY REFERRED OFF CAMPUS
YES THERE IS THEM YEAH IF
THEY'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
IMMEDIATE MENTAL HEALTH
BREAKDOWN THEY ARE REFERRED OFF
CAMPUS AND- PRESUMABLY WERE
APPARENTLY THE STUDENT- HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN OR THE STUDENTS.
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICY YOUR PLAN COVERS ALL OR
A PORTION OF THAT TREATMENT
WHICH IS GOOD AND YOU'LL GET
BACK TO ME ON THAT. YES SO ARE
THE IMPEDIMENTS YOU'RE FACING
WITH RESPECT TO. DRIVING DOWN
THE CASTLE TO STUDENT RATIO OR
THE PSYCHIATRIST TO STUDENT
RATIO OR BOTH LOOKS LIKE YOUR
CATS OF THE STUDENT RATIOS
PRETTY GOOD OF WE HAVE MADE
REALLY GOOD PROGRESS ON OUR
COUNSELORS TO STUDENT RATIO OF
AND THAT'S BEEN BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE STATE OF
HAS BEEN MAKING A BECAUSE WITH
THE REGION'S START SETTING
ASIDE A PORTION OF OUR STUDENT
SERVICES FEE TOWARD HIRING NEW
COUNSELORS. OF SOME OF THE
ISSUES WE HAVE ARE THE VACANCY
RATE. THE OF THE CHARTS ON
SLIDE TWENTY FIVE REFLECT. OF
THE STUDENTS TO COUNSELOR RATIO
IF ALL THE CALLS FOR POSITIONS
ARE FILLED BUT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A 10% VACANCY RATE. ON
AVERAGE ACROSS THE CAMPUSES SO.
THESE ARE THESE. CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGISTS FAMILY. CARE
CANCERS WHAT WHAT CATEGORY FOOT
WHAT TYPE OF OCCUPATION FITS
WITHIN THE COUNSELOR THE
COUNSELORS ARE MORE THE OF
FAMILY THERAPIST OF. SIR TALK
THERAPY OF TO HELP STUDENTS
COPE WITH US ISSUES THAT ARE
COMING UP WITH THEM IN TERMS OF
ISSUES OF LONELINESS ISSUES OF
STRESS WITH THE WITH SCHOOL BY
ISSUES OF FEAR AROUND HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY TO MAKE IT THROUGH
THE SCHOOL YEAR. THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS THAT- TYPICAL COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE DEALING WITH AND
THEN THE PSYCHIATRISTS ARE
DEALING MORE WITH THE STUDENTS
WHO NEED MEDICATION IN ORDER TO
FUNCTION. AND GET THROUGH DAILY
DAILY TASKS OUR INTENT OF IN
OFFERING THESE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON OUR CAMPUSES IS TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE ESTABLISH
A SUPPORTIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL OUR
STUDENTS. THAT THEY CAN FOCUS
ON THEIR STUDIES AND THE
VACANCY RATE IS THAT. IN PART A
GEOGRAPHIC ISSUE. OF I'M NOT
CERTAIN WHAT'S DRIVING OUR
VACANCY RATE WHY IT CONTINUES
TO BE SO HIGH BECAUSE THIS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS THAT IT'S BEEN IN
THE 10% RANGE. YEAH BUT IF WE
RECEIVE NEW FUNDING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK ON MENTAL
HEALTH IT WOULD ALLOW US TO-
CONTINUE HIRING NEW F. T.
EITHER IN THE STUDENT COUNSELOR
TO STUDENTS PSYCHIATRIST OF
CATEGORIES TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE DON'T. WE DON'T THAN OF.
THIRD LOSING SOME OF THE GOOD
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE AND
REDUCING THOSE RATES UP ON OUR
CAMPUSES BECAUSE WE ARE
CONTINUING TO ADMIT MORE MORE
STUDENTS AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE FINDING AS WE ARE
FINDING THAT MORE OF OUR
STUDENT BODY AS A PERCENTAGE IS
REQUESTING MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING SERVICES SO BACK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD 9% OF
STUDENTS. AT SOME POINT CAME TO
SEE A MENTAL HEALTH. A CAME TO
MENTAL HEALTH APPOINTMENT. AND
NOW- IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
OCCUR ON THE 13% OF OUR
STUDENTS. SO NOT ONLY ARE WE
INCREASING OUR STUDENTS MORE OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE REQUESTING
MENTAL HEALTH ASSISTANCE. NO
I'M TRYING TO. GET A HANDLE ON
WHAT WAS NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
BUDGET SO. IT APPEARS AS THOUGH
IN ORDER TO. FOR FILL UC'S FIVE
YEAR PLAN FOR MENTAL STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WHAT YOU
NEED IS THIRTY FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION. IS THAT THAT'S
ANNUALLY. SO THAT'S NOT THE
NUMBER THAT WAS APPROVED BY OUR
RIGHT TO ONE OKAY WITHIN THAT
THAT THAT TELL ME WHAT NUMBER
THAT IS THE NUMBER THAT ARE-
DIRECTOR STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- HAS CALCULATED IF WE
WERE TO PROVIDE. OF STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN AN
OPTIMAL MANNER OUR REQUEST YOU
TODAY'S TEN POINT FOUR MILLION
THAT'S THAT'S THE DELTA BETWEEN
WHAT YOU GET IN THE BUDGET
WHICH IS EITHER ZERO OR
SOMETHING AND WHAT YOU NEED.
THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED. THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO HIGHER UP ABOUT
TWENTY SIX NEW COUNSELORS AND
PSYCHIATRIST TEN POINT TEN
POINT FOUR MILLION TEN POINT
FOUR MILLION. AND THAT'S ON
GOING ON GOING PLEASE YES. AND
HOW MANY WITH THAT. ALLOW YOU
TO HIRE FTP AT TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY. CANCERS AND
PSYCHIATRISTS YES THAT'S
CORRECT. IN AND THE REGION'S
HAVE A PLAN AS TO WHERE YOU
WOULD PUT THESE FOLKS. OF WE
WOULD WE WOULD DIVIDE THEM.
WITHOUT IN BETWEEN OUR CAMPUSES
I'M NOT CERTAIN HOW MANY
POSITIONS WOULD GO TO EACH
CAMPUS BUT I'M CERTAIN THAT
WOULD LOOK AT THE NUMBER AMOUNT
OF NEED AND THE TYPES OF CASES
THAT THE CAMPUSES ARE
EXPERIENCING AND GIVEN THE VET
GIVEN THE VACANCY RATE THAT
YOU'VE- BEEN EXPERIENCING AT
LEAST IN WITHIN SOME OF YOUR-
POSITIONS YOU YOU ANTICIPATE
THE ABILITY TO FILL THESE SLOTS
IF YOU. GET THE MONEY I THINK
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO A LOT OF
GOOD WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO FILL
ALL OF THOSE SLOTS BUT IF WE
CAN FILLED THEM- THERE ARE
OTHER PURPOSES. AS WELL THAT WE
THINK WOULD HELP OUR STUDENTS
THINGS LIKE. OF GREATER-
ENHANCED OF. TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICAL TOOLS- THAT
STUDENTS COULD ACCESS TO THEIR
PHONES TO FIND OUT SOME
IMMEDIATE MENTAL HEALTH. HELP
OF WE COULD PRINT OF PREVENTIVE
MATERIALS. AND HOLD DIFFERENT
KINDS OF CLASSES FOR STUDENTS
TO- GIVE THEM SOME TOOLS ON HOW
TO COPE WITH STRESS. OUR
ANALYSIS REFERS TO A-
DISCUSSION ITEM AT A AT A
REGENTS MEETING HAVING TO DO
WITH YOU SEE COLLABORATION WITH
COUNTIES TO ENHANCE STUDENT AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH I ASSUME. THIS
ALL THIS IN PART RELATES TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT PROP
SIXTY THREE AND THE MONEY THAT
COUNTIES- RECEIVED TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO THOSE
WITHIN THE COUNTY. DO YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANY STATUS REPORT OR
ANY PROGRESS REPORT ON THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- I'M SORRY I DO NOT
I DON'T. I DON'T HAVE A STATUS
REPORT ON THAT I DO KNOW THAT.
THE UNIVERSITY HAS IN THE PAST
RECEIVED SOME OF PROP SIXTY
THREE FUNDS- WE RECEIVED AN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR GRANT. OF
THAT ENDED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
SO WE SPENT OVER SEVERAL YEARS
AND THEN WE STARTED OUR OWN-
PROGRAM TO- PUT ADDITIONAL
STUDENT SERVICES PLEASE. TOWARD
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH EFFORTS.
OKAY. OKAY I DID NOT- I
NEGLECTED TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. AVOID COMMENTS
IF YOU IF YOU HAVE ANY TO
PROVIDE ON. RAPID RE HOUSING
FOOD AND SECURITY THAT ISSUE
WHICH WAS NUMBER SIX AND OF
COURSE THIS ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
HAVING TO DO WITH STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. NO SPECIFIC
COMMENTS HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS IT LOOKS OF THESE
ISSUES MORE. ISSUE A PROCEDURE
HELP ON THIS. I HAVE NO WERE
OTHER QUESTIONS MA'AM OKAY CAN
I JUST MAKE A CLOSING COMMENT
AFTER I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT-
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE HAS A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS OF
AN INVESTMENT IN THE UC RATE IS
VERY. A NEW INVESTMENT IN UC
WITH THIS VERY TIMELY AND
WARRANTED AND WE ARE REQUESTING
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOT
THAT WILL WORK ON THAT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
EXCELLENT JOB. OKAY ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT ANIMAL SHELTER OUT
REACH GRANT. A NEW AREA FOR
BUDGETS OF ONE. SOMEONE WANTS
TO EXPAND MY HORIZONS. THANK
YOU SELL JUST OUTLINED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS FOR
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME. FUNDS
GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT OVER A
PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS FOR. A
GRANT PROGRAM AND OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES THAT THE UC DAVIS
CORPS AT SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM- WOULD MINISTER AND SO
TODAY WE HAVE DOCTOR KATE
HURLEY HERE HIS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE COURT MEDICINE PROGRAM. ARE
THE COURT SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM WHICH IT SHOULD BE
NOTED WAS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
IN THE WORLD- WHEN IT WAS
FOUNDED IN IT STILLS LEADING
THE WAY IN THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO MANAGE ELMO SHELTERS. LET ME
AS ONE JUST OVER ARCHING
QUESTION THAT DOESN'T NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED RIGHT NOW. IT JUST
OCCURRED TO ME AS I WAS READING
THE MATERIAL- WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. THAT WAS
PROPOSED OR ASSESSMENTS AND
PROSPEROUS SPECIFIC PROJECTS
WITH FILTERS- EDUCATIONAL AND
OTHERWISE OUT REACH. AND I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS. MS LOGAN
DO WITH THE AMOUNT OF THE
APPROPRIATION BUT WHY NOT
ALLOCATE THE MONEY ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS WHEN THE MONEY IS
PROPOSED TO BE USED FOR
ASSESSMENTS AND PROJECTS AN OUT
REACH RATHER THAN YOU KNOW
HIRING PERSONNEL AND DOING THE
KIND OF THINGS WERE YOU WOULD
NEED TO. A AN APPROPRIATION
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME IN ORDER
TO MAKE THE WHOLE. ASSESS WORK
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION. IT'S A
FAIR QUESTION WE CAN JUST SAY
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THE
RESOURCES THIS YEAR. ARE SUCH
THAT FIFTY MILLION IS A GOOD
AMOUNT TO MAKE A SERIOUS
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING I'VE
DID FAIL TO NOTE THAT THE
POLICY GOAL HERE IS. ON THE
BOOKS THE STATE HAS A POLICY
GOAL OF NOTE TREATABLE OR
ADOPTABLE DOGS OR CATS BEING
EUTHANIZED. AND PROVIDING FIFTY
MILLION. IS GOING TO. BE A
GIANT LEAP FORWARD IN TRYING TO
ACHIEVE THAT EXISTING POLICY
GOAL. IN TERMS OF HOW THE MONEY
WOULD BE SPENT OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME AND WHY- IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO HAVE ON GOING
IMPLICATIONS EVEN THOUGH IT'S-
A SHORT TERM I THINK. DR HURLEY
HAS A COUPLE MINUTES HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF. THE PROGRAM THAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL AND THEN SHE-
THAT SHE COULD ANSWER MORE
DETAIL LEVEL QUESTIONS BUT I
GUESS THE OTHER THING IS THE
RESPONSE TO MY QUESTION IS WE
CAN DEAL WITH THAT THROUGH AN
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
SO WE KEEP. TABS ON HOW THE
MONEY IS USED TO. ON ANNUAL
BASIS AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
PEOPLE COME BACK IN AND- IN A
WITH THEIR HAND OUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT. WILL LOVE TO
TALK ABOUT IF A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT MAKES SENSE AND-
WITH BUDGET STAFF ON THIS
PARTICULAR ONE DR. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR- I AM CAIT HURLEY I AM
PROUD TO LEAD THE CORRECTIONAL
TO MEDICINE PROGRAM AT THE UC
DAVIS SCHOOL. OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE. AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR PUTTING
FOR THIS COMPASSIONATE
PROPOSAL. TO REALIZE OUR
STATE'S GOAL FROM NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THAT NO HEALTHIER
TREATABLE AND WILL BE IS THE
NIGHT IN A SHELTER. AND FOR
ENTRUSTING OUR PROGRAM WITH THE
TASK OF MAKING IT A REALITY AS
MENTIONED WE WERE THE FIRST
PROGRAM IN THE WORLD OF OUR
KIND. AND WE'RE AT THE LEADING
VETERINARY SKIP SCHOOL IN THE
WORLD AND SO I THOUGHT. PERCENT
CONFIDENT WE CAN DELIVER ON
THAT TRUST. AS A STATE. MADE UP
OF PROGRESS SINCE POLICY GO.
WAS STAB. HOWEVER OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED. DOGS AND CATS STILL
ENTER OUR STATE SHELTERS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. AND ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED OF THOSE ANIMALS STILL
LOSE THEIR LIVES AND OUR
SHELTERS EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF THAT
BURDEN ON ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGED COMMUNITIES. UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA. AND GIVENWHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE RELATIONSHIP OF HUMAN
BEINGS AND ANIMALS. FOR HUMAN
PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH WELL AS
FOR THE ANIMALS CELLS THIS
SHOULD BE SEEN AS A HUMAN
HEALTH CONCERN. WELL AND- WE
HAVE A SOLUTION. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE ONGOING USE AN EXTRA
OF HEALTHY UNTREATABLE ANIMALS
IN SHELTERS REFLECTS A LACK OF
ACCESS TO KNOWLEDGE AND
TRAINING. AS MUCH AS A LACK OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. IN SOLVING
THE FINANCIAL GAP WITHOUT
SOLVING THE KNOWLEDGE GAP WOULD
BE INEFFICIENT AT BEST. AN
UNSUSTAINABLE IN THE LONG TERM
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF FOR
SHELTERS IN OUR COMMUNITY DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDS TO EVEN SEND
SOMEBODY TO A TRAINING PROGRAM.
LET ALONE ACCESS AN EXPERT
CONSULTANT TO COME IN AND
ASSESS THEIR OPERATIONS. AND SO
THIS IS CONCEIVED AS A TWO PART
PROGRAM REALLY TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE. ABOUT 25% OF THE FUNDING
WOULD GO TO THE SHELTER
MEDICINES PROGRAM OUT REGION
TRAINING SERVICES. AND WE WOULD
PROVIDE ONLINE COURSES THAT
WOULD BE EASILY ACCESSIBLE AND
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE
CONFERENCES MAYBE VIRTUAL-
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIA SHELTER. WE WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE TARGETED IN DEPTH
ASSESSMENT FOR AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SHELTERS OF ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE GREATEST
IDENTIFIED NEED. AND THEN THE
REMAINING 75% OF THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD GO
DIRECTLY TO GRANTS TO THE
SHELTERS. SO THE WAY WE
ANTICIPATE WOULD THIS WOULD
WORK IS THAT THE GRANT PROGRAM
WOULD BE LINKED. TO THE OUTRAGE
AND TRAIN SERVICES CLOSELY
SOCIAL JUST COULD APPLY
INITIALLY. FOR THE ASSESSMENT
PROCESS. AND THEN IN THAT
PROCESS WE WOULD WORK TOGETHER
TO IDENTIFYING THE AREAS OF
GREATEST IMPACT. AND WE WOULD
INVITE GRANT APPLICATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. RATHER THAN
LEAVING IT TO CASH STRAPPED
SHELTERS WITH SMALL STAFF STAFF
TO FIGURE OUT FOR THEMSELVES
WHAT ARE THE MOST LEVERAGE
CHANGES THAT THEY COULD MAKE.
SO ESSENTIALLY THE ASSESSMENT
PROCESS WE DEVELOPED AS WE
ENVISION IT WOULD PARALLEL THE
PHYSICAL EXAM THAT WE PERFORM
ON INDIVIDUAL PASS. THAT'S AND
THEN THE GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
ALLOW US TO PULL OUT OUR
VIRTUAL PRESCRIPTION PAD TO
ALLOW THE SHELTER TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT WE ANTICIPATE WOULD
DELIVER LONG TERM LIFESAVING
IMPACT FOR A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT AND I'M HAPPY TO
IMAGINE THAT A ONE TIME
INFUSION OF FUNDS COULD DELIVER
LONG TERM CHANGES. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW YOU ROLL
THIS OUT AND WILL PROBABLY
FIGURE OUT SOME SORT OF
REPORTING. NINE OWNERS
REPORTING ACTUATION SO THAT
NOTHING LESS THAN OF COURSE WE
WOULD ANTICIPATE WILL MOST WANT
TO TRASH THE IMPACT. OF OUR
WORK CLOSELY AS WELL MOST OF
THE STUFF WE DO IS ON BUT WILL
GOING TO MAKE WHEN. I REALLY
FOR THAT. FINANCE EXCUSE ME
JUST HERE POINT ABOUT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON THE PROGRAM I'D
MENTION OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROPOSAL
CURRENTLY PROPOSES THAT TWO
YEAR BI ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENT- THAT GOES THROUGH
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT AND AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
SHELTER MEDICINE PROGRAMMING
YOU SEE TO REPORT THE
PROGRAMMATIC AND FINANCIAL
INFORMATION RESULTING FROM THE
PROGRAM OVER THE PRECEDING TWO
YEARS. AND THAT'S PROBABLY THE
RIGHT. TIMING AS WELL GIVEN THE
FACT YOU NEED TO ROLL THE MONEY
OUT AND YOU NEED TO FIGURE
REPORT YOU WANT US. HAVE SOME
RESULTS TO REPORT SO THAT MAKES
SENSE. I DID NOTE THAT BUT I'D
FORGOTTEN IT'S THANKS FOR
THANKS FOR REMINDING ME. LA ANY
COMMENT. JUST EMISSIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION WE THINK THERE'S
KIND OF A BROADER ISSUE TO
CONSIDER AND THEN WE HAVE SOME
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON THE
PROGRAM TO ON THE PROPOSAL I'M
SORRY LEVEL COMMENT IS- JUST
RATE FOR SKINNER CONSIDERATION
OF THE VARIOUS ONE TIME
PRIORITIES- YOU MIGHT BE FACING
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PREVIOUS
BUDGETS HAVE PROVIDED A NOTABLE
OUT ARE FOCUSED AT LEAST A LOT
OF ONE TIME FUNDING ON
ADDRESSING. EXISTING
LIABILITIES AT HE STATE'S
EDUCATION SEGMENTS FOCUSED ON
THINGS LIKE PAYING DOWN
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES DRESSING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WITH WITH
THESE KINDS OF ONE TIME-
SPENDING YOU HAVE A LOT OF YOU
HAVE A GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE ACCOMPLISHING
ON THE IS EITHER A RESULTING
MORE STATE SAVINGS OR PROVIDING
FISCAL RELIEF TO EDUCATION
AGENCIES FOR EXAMPLE. ON BY
CONTRAST FOR THE PROPOSAL
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT'S BECAUSE
THE MILESTONES PLACE ON
ALTHOUGH. THE ONE TIME THERE'S
A LOT MORE CERTAIN KEY WITH
PROPOSAL SOMETHING YOU WANT
WHICH YOU CAN WEARING AS- WAY
OLIVER ONE TIME PRIORITY. I'M I
ALSO THAT THAT MESSAGE IS.
YOU'LL BE HEARING A BIT FROM US
THIS YEAR THE GOVERNOR HAS
NUMEROUS ONE TIME PROPOSAL
EDUCATION. BY THE WATER
PRIORITIES BUT SPENT SPREAD
ARGUABLY SPREADS RESOURCES MORE
THINLY NOT TURNED OF APPROACH
IS TO IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND DIRECT
ONE TIME FUNDING TOWARDS IS
REALLY HIGH PRIORITIES MIGHT
HAVE A BIGGER IMPACT. I'M IN
TERMS O A SOME SPECIFIC
COMMENTS WE HAVE ON THIS
PROPOSAL A LOT OF THE ISSUES-
THAT YOU JUST RAISED- WE THINK
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO HAVE A MORE
DETAILED IN. A MOVE BUDGET PLAN
NOT PRIOR APPROPRIATING FUNDS-
ON THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
PROGRAM HAVE PROVIDED A LITTLE
BIT MORE CLARITY AS TO THE
BREAK OUT OF WHAT PORTION WOULD
BE FOR ADMINISTRATION PORTION
BE FOR GRANTS. IT'S A LITTLE
MORE FINANCIAL INFORMATION LIKE
COME STAFFING WOULD BE HIRED
THE- SLARY COST THINGS LIKE
THAT WOULD BE A WE THINK WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE PROTECT.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THIS.
APPROPRIATION IS A SO
SIGNIFICANT- RELATIVE TO THE
PROGRAMS EXISTING BUDGET- WE
ALSO NOTE THAT THERE THERE
COULD BE SOME RISKS- A FROWN
DEEPENED COST PRESSURES
DEPENDING ON HOW THE PROGRAM
SPENDS THE FUN. OF A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY OF MEANT- ON SKIP.
THAT IN MY IF YOU'RE WAITING
PROPOSED. I'M IN FINALLY HAD
CONCERNS WITH THE REPORTING
LANGUAGE WITH COULD BE. HAPPY
TO WORK WITH STAFF
ADMINISTRATION OFTEN. UP AND
STRENGTHENS WERE PART IN SOME
THAT THE WHAT. IN SESSION IT
NEEDS. TO WHETHER THE PROGRAM-
BUT ACHIEVES THE OBJECTIVES OF
REDUCING ANIMAL- IS INNOVATION.
WELL ABSOLUTE. AND ACTUALLY.
WE'RE GONNA STICK TO BY IT ALL
A REPORT QUORUM. SHOULD AND SO
YOU HAVE TWO YEARS THIS ULTRA.
I WOULD HOPE THAT AT THE END
THERE'S SOMEONE OUT OF THE PRO
WAS THE TO DO WITH THE RESULTS
ARE AND THEN TAKE A LOOK AT
WHETHER THE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
RE DIRECTED IN ANY WAY TO HAVE
MORE IMPACT TO BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT AND
THAT SHOULD BE DOCUMENTED IN
THE REPORT THAT WE GET.
HOPEFULLY IN ADVANCE SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION- IN
WHATEVER BUDGET YEAR THAT
HAPPENS TO BE IN. A MONIES
ALREADY APPROPRIATED BUT WE CAN
STILL HAVE A CONVERSATION. AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE. SIR YOUR
YOUR INVOLVEMENT IN THAT
PROCESS. IT CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE INTEREST IN AND-
LOOK FOR THE ONGOING COVERS IT
IS A UNIQUE ISSUE FOR BUDGETS
OF ONE I'M EXCITED TO
PARTICIPATE. ANYTHING ELSE.
THANKS FOR YOUR INTO HOLD OPEN
ITEM SO AS WITH ALL OF THESE
THINGS AT SOME POINT. AS I
RECALL AFTER THE MAY REVISE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CAST A BUNCH OF VOTES SO LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
COME TO THE END OF OUR- AGENDAS
SO NOW IS THE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT BY THE WAY- I JUST
WANNA NOTE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE- THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS INCOME
AND BY BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND ALL OF
THESE ITEMS SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. COME ON DOWN. YES
SIR- MY NAME IS DOCTOR BARMAN
TORIA WORK WITH US RATE FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND STARTED AND-
BROWN- DIVERSE HEALTH OFFICIAL
DIVERSITY PROGRAMS AND I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB-
BUDGET I REQUEST THAT WOULD BY
SELF INCREASE. UNDER REVISION
MINORITY DISADVANTAGED-
ADMISSIONS TO MEDICAL SCHOOLS
BY 11% OF THE REQUESTED BE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND- EXISTING UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. MEDICAL SCHOOL
BASED- FREMAD POST
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS- THESE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT- TAKEN
STUDENTS WHO WENT THROUGH THE
WHOLE FOUR FIVE SIX YEAR HARD
OUR DEAREST TREATMENT PROCESS.
APPLIED TO MED SCHOOL MAYBE
EVEN GOT INTERVIEWS BUT
ULTIMATELY DID NOT GET ACCEPTED.
ARE THE PROGRAM'S SPONSOR A ONE
YEAR PROGRAM- AT THE END OF
THAT THE PROGRAM US 82% OF
STUDENTS. THE PROJECT INSTANCE
PARKS AFTER. OUR IN 97%
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL. ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF INCREASING.
MINORITY ARE AND DISADVANTAGED
CONSTRAINED. AS POSITIONS AS
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF THEM HAVE
BEEN NOW SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY SHOWED THAT. AYE
PROPORTIONS UP 25080% OF LATINO
BLACK AND AMERICAN INDIAN. A
DOCTOR DO IN FACT PRACTICE
UNDERSERVED AREAS WITH
INITIATIVE COMMUNITIES. AND
WITH THESE OPPOSE BACK ALUMNI-
HIGH PROPORTION GOING TO PRIME
MINISTER 60% ON A PRIMARY CARE
37% GO SPRINKLING OF FAMILY
MEDICINE WHICH IS. FOUR TIMES
THE GENERAL CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
RATE POST BACK EXPANSION WAS A
ON RECOMMENDATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE. ARE COMMISSION. AND
CHAIRED BY JOHN AND PAUL TANA.
OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
VERY COST EFFECTIVE IN IN IN ON
CREASING- THE NUMBER DOCS
INSURING JURORS LAST SENTENCE
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX. AND ELEVEN HUNDRED.
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED TO
MED SCHOOL AND THEN ARE YOU THE
FRACKING DOC STORE- MEDICAL
STUDENTS SO WE HOPE THAT THEY
CAN BE EXPANDED TO INCREASE
ACCESS. AND NAM UNDERSERVED
AREAS CALIFORNIA SERVE A PREP
SCHOOL. WELL IT SAYS SERVER WE
CAN SAY RETRAIN. SO IS THIS
PROPOSAL IS THIS INITIATIVE
BEEN PUT FORWARD BY ANY MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE OR- NOT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NOW. WE HAD
IT IN THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
YEARS AGO- AND THEN THAT
GOVERNOR- DID NOT WANT TO
INCREASE ANY FUNDING FOR THE UC
AND WE WERE IN THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR SOME OUT AT THAT THIS IS A
LOUDER GOT KNOCKED OUT OKAY
WELL WE- APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND- SEE OTHER WORKS.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
THANKS FOR GOING OUT. YES SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS DON GIBSON I'M
A RECENT UC DAVIS PHD GRADUATE
IN GENOMICS- AND- ACTUALLY
COMING HERE TODAY IN MY ROLE AS
A FORMER CHAIR OF A HOUSING
TASK FORCE IN COMMUNITY LET-
AND I WANT TO SHARE THE RESULTS
OF A MAJOR STUDY ON HOUSING THE
SECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS- THIS
STUDY WENT OUT IN MAY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND WAS
FINALLY PUBLISHED- THIS PAST
SUMMER AND WE ACTUALLY YOU HAD
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
SCIENTIFIC SURVEY OF HOUSING
ISSUES FOR THE UC DAVIS STUDENT
COMMUNITY HAS A STUDY BEEN SENT
TO THE BUDGET STEP. I HAVE A
LINK TO THE SOURCE I'LL BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND
ASK THEM FIRST BUT BROWN TO
STUDY PROBABLY GIVEN THE TIME
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'RE
CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THE COPY OF THE STUDY.
OF COURSE I MARIE OF MAJOR
RESULT FROM BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH GAME THE BEST. OF US
JUST KEY FINDINGS APPROXIMATELY
PERCENT OF UC DAVIS
UNDERGRADUATES AND GRADUATES IN
SPACE I'M FORM OF HOUSING A
SECURE. WASN'T A BROADER
DEFINITE IN THEM GOING UP
SURVEYS IT USED. TO DO SO BEING
ADDED SEEN RIGHT INSOFAR NOT
KNOWING WHERE I SLEEP NIGHT
THEN WE THE PARKS PERCENT
REPORTER SLEEPING IN A CAR FOR
AT LEAST ONE NIGHT WE IS A
SEVEN HUNDRED YOU DAVIS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE SURVEY ON K.
HOUSE WAS AT FAR EXPENSE THAN
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING- UC DAVIS IS
AFFORDABILITY METRIC- ONLY 15%
OF ON CAMPUS HOUSING MAC UC
DAVIS IS ON AFFORDABILITY
METRIC. 20% OF OFF CAMPUS AT.
RENTS ARE ACTUALLY RISING AS
YOU ALL KNOW IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND I. T. A.'S WASTE PAPER
APPROXIMATELY 55% OF A TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENTS- WHEN WE DID
THE STUDY AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. IT SHOWED THAT THE
TIAS WAGES PAID FOR ONLY A 73%
AND WITH FRIENDS GOING UP ABOUT
5% A YEAR ON AVERAGE WE KNOW
THAT NUMBER SHRINKING AND UC
DAVIS UNDERGRADS ARE INCREDIBLY
CROWDED. AND THEIR APARTMENTS
THEY LIVE ACROSS A ONE POINT
SIX PEOPLE HER BEDROOM. IN THE
PRIVATE MARKET DAVIS SO FOR
YOUR AVERAGE THREE BEDROOM
APARTMENT. FIVE STUDENTS LIVE
IN THAT RIGHT NOW SO WAS THINGS
THAT WOULD LOVE TO SEE IN THE
FUTURE IS- A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
SURVEY ABOUT STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
SECURITY. BECAUSE ALL THESE
THINGS ALL UP PRODUCT A LOT
MORE PEOPLE ON THE FRENCH FOR
ME COMING HOMELESSNESS- AND
ALSO LOOK AT RATES OF PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY PAYING FOR RENT.
AND SEEING A WAY WE CAN HAVE A
CURVE SO WE CAN BRING THOSE
NUMBERS DOWN. THEY GOT I'VE A
SUMMARY RESULTS I'LL BE HALF
THIS SURVEYS TO PLEASE. IS TO
THANK YOU FOR COMING. YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES AND THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO YOU SEE MEDICAL EDUCATION
AND APPRECIATED THE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY AS
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE PUT
FORWARD- I A NUMBER OF WORK
FORCE REQUESTS RELATED TO THE A
SHORTAGE OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE IN THE STATE- WE DO
HAVE SPONSORED ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE AND ONE WELCOME SPONSORS
ON THE SENATE SIDE HERE. A
BRIEF TALK ABOUT THEM BECAUSE I
KNOW YOUR STAFF HAS A PRETTY
DETAILED LETTER ONE WOULD BE TO
FULLY FUND OR SUSTAIN THE UC
PRIME PROGRAM AND EXPAND THE
PRIME PROGRAM AND THE SECOND
WOULD BE- DOLLARS PUT TOWARDS
THE FOR PC OR ENDORSED
APPLICANT PROGRAM BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
RECOMMENDED BY THE- FUTURE
HEALTH OF COURSE THE MACHINE.
WE HAVE A GREATER ON THE FUTURE.
HELLO MY NAME IS CODER AND
PARALYZED. OF THE OF CALIFORNIA
DAY GRADUATE STUDENTS AS I WANT
TO START OFF BY EXPRESSING MY
GRATITUDE FOR THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING- IT FOR
BASIC NEEDS ACROSS THE TEN UC
CAMPUSES- I PERSONALLY REFERRED
STUDENTS WHO I TEACH. AND
FRIENDS WHO I WORK WITH- TO
AGGIE COMPASS WHICH IS OUR
BASIC NEEDS CENTER. AND I AM
ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
FUNDING HAS GIVEN US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN A GRADUATE
STUDENT SPECIFIC ENTRY. I'M
WITH ENERGY AS A OFFICE. I'M
ALSO HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY'S
BUDGET REQUEST OF TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET. AND SPECIFICALLY WANT
TO CALL ATTENTION TO THE TEN
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WELL THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES THESE FUNDS ARE
URGENTLY NEEDED ON OUR
CAMPUSES. 39% OF GRADUATE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE MODERATE TO
SEVERE ANXIETY. OR DEPRESSION
AND THIS IS THE RATE SIX TIMES
HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
LEE IN SPEAKING WITH MY
COUNTERPART AT UC RIVERSIDE THE
FIRST AVAILABLE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES APPOINTMENT IS ON
APRIL SIX WHICH IS TWENTY FIVE
DAYS FROM TODAY. SO WHILE
INTAKE WILL TAKE PLACE VERY
QUICKLY- THE TIME TO ACTUALLY
SEE A COUNSELOR IS. IS A GREAT
BURDEN. THIS IMPACTS OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
TEACHING A MENTORSHIP TORE
UNDERGRADS IN ADDITION TO
CONCERNS ABOUT OUR QUALITY OF
LIFE. AND WHERE WE ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY RENT BIRD AND- AS
MY COLLEAGUE I'M JUST
DESCRIBED. THIS IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE THIS IS THE RETENTION
ISSUE AND WE ARE. GREATLY
HOPING FOR THE SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS YES SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR- MY NAME
IS TOM HìNH SEE- A PHD STUDENT
UC DAVIS AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF YOUR W. TWENTY SIXTY
FIVE. ARE YOU REPRESENTS
NINETEEN THOUSAND ACADEMIC
STUDENT EMPLOYEES ACROSS YOU
SEE INCLUDING GRADUATE STUDENTS
AND UNDERGRADUATE TUTORS- WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF UC'S BUDGET
REQUESTS IN PARTICULAR AT C.
PAP- AND FUNDING FOR A DOCUMENT
STUDENTS AT UC. WITH THE
SUPREME COURT IS. LIKELY TO
OVERTURN DHAKA- AND GRADUATE
STUDENT WORKERS AT LIKELY TO
LOSE THEIR WORK AUTHORIZATIONS.
FUNDING FOR ON UNDOCUMENTED
GRAD STUDENTS- WILL BE CRITICAL
TO THE BUT IF THOUSANDS.
STUDENTS FINISH THEIR DEGREES
OUT WE ALSO SUPPORT EXPAND
MOMENT OF I READ SPREAD
STUDENTS- BUT CURRENT PROPOSALS
BY THE UC AND THE STATE. DON'T
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT COST OF
LIVING ISSUE. FOR ACADEMIC
STUDENT PLATE. NOW THE SPREAD
OF IN. MANY YOU SEE. HAVE MOVED.
ONLINE FOR THE SPRING AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED HERE- AS GRADUATE
STUDENTS WE DO NOT MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY TO SUPPORT TO LIVE. WHERE
WE WORK LET ALONE TEACH CLASSES
FROM OUR APARTMENTS- AND
ALTHOUGH PROP THIRTEEN FAILED
WE STILL HAVE YOU SEE WILL
DEVELOP CAMPUS PLANS TO
CONSTRUCT NEW AFFORDABLE ON
CAMPUS HOUSING. AND BRING IT
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE- ONE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM IS TO
EXPAND SUMMER INSTRUCTION AS
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING- WHICH
WOULD EXTEND HE TEACHING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A SEASON TO
THE SUMMER. PROVIDING UP TO A
THIRD MORE PAY- BUT BEYOND
FUNDING BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVES
**** NEED CONTRACTUAL
SOLUTIONS. ARE UNION EXPRESSED
THE NEED TO YOU SEE UP FOR
HOUSING STATE TO RELIEVE.
STUDENTS WHO ARE RENT BURDENED
WE'VE ALSO EXPRESSED THE NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE ON CAMPUS
HOUSING AND RENT FREEZES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT THE
MORNING MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER
APPEARING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF-OF BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA AND SAN
DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY. SO YOU
GUESSED IT I'M HERE ON ON ISSUE
EIGHT IN SUPPORT OF THE ANIMAL
SHELTER GRANTS PROGRAM. AND
THERE ARE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND AN ANIMAL SHELTERS THAT ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS AND
I'LL JUST QUOTE FROM A VERY
NICE LETTER. THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
REGENTS MISTER PERES LAST
MONTH. LAST MONTH IDENTIFYING
THE CRACK CHILDREN MEDICINE
PROGRAM AS A SOURCE OF CUTTING
EDGE APPROACHES TO ANIMAL
WELFARE AT THE UNIVERSITY PROUD
TO HAVE A PROGRAM IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT AND POWERFUL MISSION
AND- IF IT. THE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US YES MA'AM. HI THERE
MY NAME IS JILL TUCKER AND THE
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION SO WE ARE
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF THE
SHELTERS WERE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL AND WHAT IT WILL MEAN
TO THE STATES- THERE IS
DEFINITELY A DISPARITY OF
RESOURCES AND THE SHELTERS THAT
ARE STRUGGLING REALLY DO. NEED
THE PROFESSIONAL ASSISTANCE OF
OTHER FOLKS AT UC DAVIS THEY
HAVE AN AMAZING REPUTATION
WE'RE VERY CONFIDENT THAT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO DELIVER ON THIS
AND REALLY WORK WITH THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO COME
UP WITH COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL ADVANCE ANIMAL
WELFARE IN OUR STATE SO I WANT
TO SAY THAT OUR RGANIZATION IS
VERY COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESS
OF THAT PROGRAM TO SUPPORTING
THAT AND TO HELPING TO
FACILITATE COLLABORATION. SO
THAT WE CAN EXTEND OUR
LIFESAVING CAPACITY I ALSO WANT
TO MENTION EVERYONE TO VISIT
YOUR LOCAL SHELTER BECAUSE
ANIMALS DO NOT REQUIRE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THIS IS A GREAT
TIME TO ADOPT A PET. THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU. YES MA'AM.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN NAMES
ANGIE MINETTI HERE REPRESENTING
THE CITY OF FRESNO. GRANT I'M
NOT PROUD OF THIS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY OUR COMMUNITY
TOUTS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
EUTHANASIA RATES IN THE STATE
WE ARE IN DESPERATE NEED FOR
THIS FUNDING. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS POLICY PROPOSAL DOES
A LINE WITH OUR LOCAL GOALS WE
ARE WORKING TO BUILD A NEW
ANIMAL SHELTER OWNED BY THE
CITY BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
WE WOULD LOVE TO GET THE
ASSISTANCE FROM THIS PROGRAM TO
INSTITUTELIFESAVING- PROCESSES
AND PROCEDURES THAT ARE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS EITHER DAYS A ROBBIE I
AM A GRADUATE OF UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW AND THE CURRENT PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF UC BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS. ARE
PRIVATE PROGRAM SERVES
CURRENTLY AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS- IN THE
UC SYSTEM AND ALSO ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE TWENTY
MILLION THAT WOULD SUPPORT.
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS THE STATE
HAS MADE REALLY INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS INTO HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR CURRENTLY AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS.
AT THE CAL STATE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL- AND WE'RE AKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR UC
UNDERGROUND'S SCHOLARS SO THAT
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THOSE PROGRAMS AND ARE READY
READY TO. FOR TO THE UC CAN
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF OUR PROGRAM
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A PRESENCE AT
ALMOST EVERY UC CAMPUS OR
WORKING ON USED ARE SAID. UCSF
AND HASTY. BUT THERE ARE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
ON AFTER YOU SEE CAMPUS NOT ON
WERE ASKING SUPPORT EXPAND THE
SERVICES. AND RAMPS THAT ARE
ABLE TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON OF NAME IS
NOT THE THAT I'M WITH. YEAR
UNDERGRAD AT BERKELEY AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS- I ALSO WANT TO
REITERATE- TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS- FOR THIS FUNDING FOR
OUR ORGANIZATION IT WOULD NOT
ONLY HELP FORMALLY CURSOR FOLKS
IT WOULD ALSO HELP.
UNDOCUMENTED OR FOSTER STUDENTS
SO- THIS IS LIKE A REALLY
IMPORTANT- FUNDING FOR. OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR STUDENTS
AND I JUST APPRECIATE IT
ANYTIME SUPPORT YOU GUYS HAVE
FOR US THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS FOR COMING. AT A GLANCE
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
JESSIE FERNANDES SOME OF
FORMING INCARCERATED STUDENT
OVER AT UC BERKELEY PART OF
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS. I'M HERE
THE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT.
THE UC BUDGET ASK TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MYSELF. AND
THE GREATER POPULATION OF POP
FORMER FOSTER YOU. FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS AND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS ORDER THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR COMING. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ROTH- PUSH ON
WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION- SO- JUST WANTED TO
ECHO WHAT OUR FRIENDS AT THE-
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS UC
BERKELEY MENTIONED WE AT THE UC
SOONER SO SOLUTION. ARE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS- FUNDING FOR THE A
DOCUMENT STUDENTS FOSTER YOUTH
A FORMER FORMALLY COURSES JUST
AS ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
PRIORITIES FOR THE YEAR- IN
ADDITION TO THAT I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO IDENTIFY. ANOTHER AREA.
TO US WHICH IS THIS STATE
PROGRAMS- AND THESE ARE- YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AROUND IT- WE KNOW
THAT THESE PROGRAMS WORK THEY
DO OUT OF. WOULD RECEIVE A FAR
DISTANCE IN. CLOSING THE GAP.
AND ARE INCREASING DIVERSITY
OTHER CAMPUSES AND- THAT. EASE
OF ONE OF OUR- THE- STATION AND
LASTLY JUST ACCORDING THE ASSAM
HEALTH SO. TO THE TEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR PRO WE
WOULD TO OF. FOR YOUR SO AS
WELL AS ALSO THANK YOU I COULD.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND SOME A CAL
GRANT- AND YOUR CONTINUES
PRIORITIZATION OF THAT. THANK
YOU THANK YOUR COMMENTS JUST
SERVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN STAFF OBJECT RENDER
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND I'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU AND I'LL DROP
THIS OFF WITH YOUR STAFF ARE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
PRIORITIES LETTER- WHICH I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE THE
FIRST ITEM THAT WE HAVE LISTED
HERE AS A PRIORITY. IS THE
EXPANSION OF ENROLLMENT. THE
SERVER DOUBLE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT STUDENTS- CENTER OFF I
KNOW YOU APPRECIATE METRICS AND
HAVING SOME MEASURABLE GOALS
ESTABLISHED UNFORTUNATELY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STILL
LACKS. ANY DEFINED GOAL AROUND
DEGREE ATTAINMENT. OF
THANKFULLY- WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT- THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA AND SOME RESEARCH
THAT WE'VE DONE AT THE CAMPAIGN
FOR CULTURE OPPORTUNITY. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO LOOK TO SEE HOW
MANY BACHELOR DEGREES DO WE
NEED TO. WORKFORCE THE IS AND
WHAT OUR RESEARCH THE- AC WHICH
ALIGNS WITH RESEARCH THAT WE'VE
DONE TAT I MEANT IS THAT WE
NEED ONE MORE ONE MILLION MORE
BACHELOR DEGREES TO MEET
EMPLOYER DEMANDS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AND RECENTLY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM PTSD
TESTIFIED THAT. DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS IN THE
PAST ADMINISTRATION GROWING
ENROLLMENT NOT ONLY AT THE UC
BUT AT THIS YEAR'S YOU WERE ON
A TRAJECTORY WHERE WE CAN CLOSE
THAT GAP- HOWEVER IT'S GOING TO
TAKE CONTINUED FOCUS ON THIS
CHALLENGE AND CONTINUED SUPPORT.
OUR STATE RESOURCE TWIN ABLE
OUR UNIVERSITY PARTNERS TO
SERVE MORE ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. THE OTHER PIECE FROM
THAT TEST OF THAT I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT ONE WERE ABLE
TO. EXPAND ENROLLMENT CAPACITY
WERE ALSO ABLE TO HELP
DIVERSIFY THE STUDENT BODY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND- MORE REFLECTIVE.
CALIFORNIA'S OWN DEMOGRAPHICS.
OF ONE OTHER THING I'LL JUST
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT. CAMPAIGN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COLLEGE
FOR ALL COALITION IS ALSO
SUPPORTING THIS ASK FOR YOU SEE
AROUND THE STATE THAT PROGRAM-
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE AT HELPING.
OF OUR STUDENTS NOT ONLY. US
BUT SIX. AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL- AND THEN YOU KNOW. THE
SUPPORT ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE
THROUGH TARGETED RESOURCES- SO
THAT OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS CAN
ALSO- PROVIDE THAT COLLEGE
READY THIS CURRICULUM THAT
ENABLE STUDENTS TO APPLY IN THE
FIRST PLACE- SO ALL MAKE SURE
LEAVE A COPY IN THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU SIR. THE SERVER.
RODRIGUEZ ON THE THAT YOU TRUST
WES OF FIRST REAL IN ROLE MEET
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE EXPANDED
ROMAN SLOTS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS- IF THIS ALLOCATION
WILL BE MADE THROUGH THE- BLOCK
BASS RESOURCE METHOD OUTLINED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET. WE
S. LEDGE OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE SOME TRANSPARENCY ON
HOW MUCH MONEY WILL BE USED FOR
THOSE SLOTS AND HOW MANY SLOTS
WE CAN ACTUALLY EXPECTING THAT-
SECOND ALL ACTUALLY WHAT WE-
JUST SAID. WE SUPPORT THE
REINVESTMENT THE COLLEGE
READINESS BLOCK GRANT AND THE
BUDGET AUGMENTATION FOR SAY PET
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY'RE-
EQUITY FOCUS STUDENT CENTERED-
AND ALL JUST A- ADVICE SUPPORT
BEHIND THE UC ESSAYS- REQUEST
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS THANK
YOU. THE SERVER AFTERNOON
SHARING HIS FILMS AROUND I'M
CURRENTLY THE MANAGER OF THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO FRONT STREET
AUNT ANIMAL SHELTER PRIOR TO
THAT I WAS THE MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF STOCKTON ANIMAL SHELTER
FOR FIVE YEARS I HAD THE
BENEFIT OF WORKING WITH THE UC
DAVIS SHELTER RIGHT MEDICINE
PROGRAM IN STOCKTON. ON SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS. BUDGET PROPOSAL ARE THE
EXACT SAME THINGS THAT THEY
CAME TO OUR SHELTER IN PROVIDED
US. ON IT IS BEEN PROVEN THAT
THESE BASIC- PROGRAMS THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE TO THE SHELTERS
HAVE DRASTIC EFFECTS ON
IMPROVING THE OUTCOMES OF
ANIMALS. AND ALSO INCREASES THE
PUBLIC SUPPORT- IN THE LOCAL
AREAS AND ALSO BRINGS ATTENTION
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS. ON THE NEEDS IN THE-
PROGRAMS SHELTERS ARE ARE
REQUIRED. TO PROVIDE- IN
STOCKTON A BECAUSE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT UC DAVIS SHELTER
CREDIT PROGRAM HIM IN AN
ASSISTED US WITH WE WERE ABLE
TO RAISE OUR LIVE RELEASE RATE
FROM 32% TO EIGHTY THREE
PERCENT- IN A PERIOD OF LESS
THAN FIVE YEARS. AND AGAIN THAT
WAS WITH JUST SOME BASIC-
PROTOCOLS- BEST PRACTICES IN
THE SHELTER IN AGAIN ENGAGING
THE COMMUNITY IN THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS SO. I'VE TOTALLY
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM AND THINK
THAT THE- GOVERNOR FOR- PUSHING
THIS FORWARD- BECAUSE IT IT CAN
DEFINITELY HAVE AN IMPACT
ACROSS THE STATE FOR. THE
ANIMALS THAT INTER- SHOPPERS.
THANK YOU THINK. THE SPAM GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TAYLOR
OCEAN I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND ACTUALLY HERE
ON BEHALF OF BROAD COALITION OF
AGRICULTURAL ENVIRONMENTAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT- ASSOCIATIONS
IT'S NOT AN ITEM ON THE AGENDA
FOR THIS BUDGET HEARING BUT WE
WOULD ASK THAT AND SUBSEQUENT
HEARINGS ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
CONSIDER THE BUDGET OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURE NATURAL
RESOURCES SO THE ACRONYM YOU
SEE A IN OUR- YOU SEE IN OUR
DOES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
RESEARCH FIELD WORK AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES ON- REALLY
EVERYTHING FOR NATURAL MARKING
LANDS PUBLIC HEALTH AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS- SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND
COUNTRY. INTO UC ANR HAS
DROPPED BY OVER 40% THIRTY NINE
DOLLARS HAVEN'T BACK FILL THAT
COST THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED AFFECTED BY THESE
BUDGET CUTS ARE FARM ADVISORS
AND ARE FOR EACH ADVISORS- AS
YOU'RE AWARE FROM ADVISERS ROLE
IS TO TRANSLATE THE RESEARCH
THAT'S DONE AT THE INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES AND AT THE UC SYSTEM
TO THE FARMS AND TO OUR
COMMUNITIES SO THE LOSS OF THAT
RESPONSE AT A TIME WHEN THE
PUBLIC IS ASKING FARMS THE
BETTER- IS REALLY A CALL AND
THE PICTURE THAT WE- FROM
HARVARD RIGHT. IS WE LOST ABOUT
HOW ADVISER NOT TWENTY YEARS
ISN'T THE XIN INVADE AND I'M
SERVICE AREA ARE SO PEOPLE ARE
DRIVING MORE IN SPENDING TIME
ON THE FARM I'M AND THEN LOWER
FOCUSING ON IT OF THEIR
SPECIALTY OR ADVISING OUTSIDE
SPECIAL. THE TWO FOR EACH. EVEN
MORE TERM. I'M YOU'VE GOT A-
EXISTING YOU SEE STAFF
POSITIONS SERVING THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES-
YOU'VE GOT YOU SEE EMPLOYEES
LEANING ON COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
TO PICK UP THE TAB FOR-
EMPLOYEE SALARIES AND BENEFITS.
AND YOU AND THE WORST SITUATION
YOU HAVE. THOSE EMPLOYEES GOING
OUT TO THE PUBLIC AND TRYING TO
FUNDRAISE TO COVER THE COST OF
THEIR SALARY BENEFITS FOR THEIR
JOBS. SO WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
EVERY DOLLAR THAT IS INVESTED
IN TAPPED IN THE RESOURCE IN
THE COMMUNITY. TO COVER SALARY
AND BENEFITS HAVE YOU SEEN
PLEASE MEANS ONE LESS DOLLAR.
WE CAN USE TO DO THINGS LIKE
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR FORTY STUDENTS
THAT CAN AFFORD TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM SO WE'RE ASKING
THIS YEAR FOR AN EXHIBITION OF
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. FOR YOU SEE A AND ARE AM
AND WE HOPE THAT HEARINGS TO
COME CAN DISCUSS THIS ISSUE HAS
IS THAT IN THE FORM OF A
REQUEST FROM SOME MEMBER YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT. EGGMAN IS
CARRYING OUR BUDGET REQUEST
THAT WE LOVE. HAVE REPRESENT ON
THE SENATE SIDE LOWEST. THAT'S
HOW THE PROCESS WORKS IF. THE
OTHER IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
TYPICALLY A MEMBER. OR A CAR
COMES FORWARD WITH OVER AGENDA
TEND AND CONSIDERED SO. WE'LL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH THAT
REQUEST ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
SERVER. GOOD AFTERNOON WHILE
THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT UPON
CALIFORNIA- SPEAKING OF OUR
DOWN EIGHT ARE THE SHELTER
MEDICINE PROGRAM- WE YET DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS ITEM
HOWEVER. WE HAVE BEEN A WORKING
COLLABORATIVE WITH- THE-
PROPONENTS OF THIS MEASURE WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A COUPLE
ITEMS ADDRESSED- AND- RELATED
TO. OUR OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
MATERIALS AND ALSO- MADE
ENSURING THAT JOB YOU KNOW THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER BE FIFTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN- WHICH DIRECTS ALL
STATE AGENCIES TO WORK TOGETHER
TO CONSERVE THE STATE'S
BIODIVERSITY POLICY ALSO. BE
CONSIDERED IN IN- THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ASKING ON
BEHALF THE MOSQUITO AND VECTOR
CONTROL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE ON A NON AGENDA
IS ITEM TODAY BUT THAT WE
EXPECT TO POSSIBLY BE HEARD ON
THE ASSEMBLY SITE NEXT WEEK
BUT- TWO YEARS AGO IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN RECEIVED A ONE TIME.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT A
MOSQUITO SURVEILLANCE RESEARCH
DATABASE SYSTEM RUN OUT OF UC
DAVIS AT A TIME WHEN I THINK
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION RIGHT NOW. OUR
MOSQUITO CONTROL DISTRICT HAVE
FOUND THIS TO BE AN INVALUABLE
SYSTEM HELPING THEM GET AHEAD
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF INVASIVE
SPECIES THAT CAN TRANSMIT A
TROPICAL BORNE DISEASES SO-
THIS. FUNDING WAS PROVIDED
DIRECTLY TO UC DAVIS AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED A LIKE I SAID WE EXPECT
TO BE HEARD ON THE ASSEMBLY
SITE NEXT WEEK AND WILL KEEP
YOUR OFFICE IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
APPRISED OF IT. IS IT'S A
MEMBER REQUEST TO RESERVE TO
SUBCOMMITTEE GENDERED ITEM WE
BELIEVE IT WILL BE A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THAT I. WAS A
PROCESS OF THE TWO SIDES BUDGET
ITEMS DOT AGREED THERE'S A
CONFERENCE PROCESS BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR CIVIL THE
OTHERS WERE. YES MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON SUSAN. AMERICANS ERIC
AND ASPCA. GOD AWFUL FOR ME I'M
HERE OBVIOUS INSTRUCTS OF ITEM
EIGHT- SPECIFICALLY AND WE'RE
GENERALLY- THE CREDITS PROGRAM
AND I DOCTOR HURLEY'S WORK AND-
WHICH SHELTERS AROUND THE STATE
AND ACTUALLY NOT NATIONWIDE I'M
WE'VE HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
WORKING WITH THE PROGRAM AND IT
HAD- GREAT EXPERIENCES AND-
FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY-
HELP US ACHIEVE THE LONG
STANDING GOAL OF REDUCING THE
NATION'S EUTHANASIA OF ARE
VULNERABLE I'VE THANK YOU
PERFECT THANKS FOR COMING YES
SIR EUROPE. GOOD AFTERNOON
DELIGHT IN SINGLE DOCUMENT ON
THESE DEPARTMENT ANALYST HERE
WE DON'T MATCH ALL SHOULDER-
I'VE BEEN VERY LUCKY TO BE
INVOLVED WITH THE CASE EARLY
HER TEAM OUT THERE UC DAVIS
OVER THE YEARS. I IT HELPED US
QUITE A BIT WITH THE NEW. AND
BEST. IN SHELTERS I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT THE- BEFORE THEIR
HELP WE WERE. THREE DOZEN WHEN
PERFORMING OUR DUTIES AND
PROVIDING LIVE OUT IN THE
ANNALS BUT WITH THEIR HELP IN.
NEW PROTOCOLS- HAVE YOU SEE
THAT IN YOUR TWENTY NINETEEN
THE ACHIEVED A LIVE RELEASE
RATE OF 87% I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF SHELTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT THE AREN'T
THOSE. LOOK USE US TO HELP
SUPPORT THE THAT WE GOT IN THE
PAST AND THERE'S A LOT OF
FILTERS OUT THERE THAT ARE ARE
EAGERLY AWAITING- FOR THIS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR-
INITIATIVE TO. GO THROUGH. I
CAN'T THINK OF ANYBODY BETTER
THAN KATE EARLY HER STEP OUT
THERE UC DAVIS TWO. OF THE
STEWARDS OF THE PROGRAM I THINK
WILL BE. THE OF. ALL THE
RESULTS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
COMMUNITIES MORE INVOLVED WITH
THEIR LOCAL FILTERS WILL
PROVIDE THE- MUCH. FOR PEOPLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR COMING
IN YOUR COMMENTS ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT. I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION SPECIFICALLY
AGAIN THANKING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE FURTHER
ANALYSIS IN COMMENTS AND SEEING
NO FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.